learn how to create a LinkedIn clone
using react and Firebase nishat Singh is
your instructor for this course he is a
front-end engineer and popular course
creator this course will provide an
in-depth look at the development process
for creating an online social network
the course explores topics such as
authentication States adding posts
implementing a like system and user
search functionality by the end of this
course you will have a fully functioning
LinkedIn clone
and now let's learn how to build this
LinkedIn clone using reactant Firebase
so let me give you a demo first that
work we are building
we have the sign up page and login page
now let me first sign up using my email
called I mean name email and password
so Nishan Kumar
this email account
that will be unique for each user
we cannot use Save email for two users I
mean we cannot create account using same
email now let me add a password
and click agree and join
we will be on the home page with a dummy
image and no data here so now let me
check authentication tab here
authentications tab users
so we'll have one user here now click
database fire Studio database and we
will have a user stable here or
collection which contains our email
image link a domain image link and name
and the user ID okay now
we have the options to search a user go
to home page and manage connections
apart from that we have to create a post
so let me create a post here called
hello
this is a
LinkedIn
clone
by cyber
natiko
so we can add a post like this in text
we can make it bold italic underline we
can make the heading big
all these things
so let me divide it back for now
we can also add a link here if you want
and we also have the options okay this
is not in the app it's in my PC okay now
we can also add an image so let me add
an image here as a post so let me try
this image so whenever you upload an
image we will see a loader
and then the image itself okay take
previewed here then we can click post
and the post will be here
we can like the post and comment on it
so let's say we comment this and may I
mean we can comment here like uh this is
comment
one click add comment and the command
will be here with the username and the
timestamp the timestamp is here as well
with the username
we can delete the post or edit it so let
me click edit here
and let me add something else called
This is nishanth
Umar
we can also change the picture here so
if I upload one more picture here let's
try this picture yes
so again our loader will be here
a product bar and then the picture will
be updated now click update here and
this picture will be updated
no other extra things now if you click
the picture we will be opening a model
to see the picture here we can open it
in a new tab like this and save it okay
now we can delete the post but let me
first go to the profile page
if we click a profile from the name here
we will be on this profile page here on
the user's profile page
same thing is here if you click the view
profile button
we will be on this profile page now we
can edit this profile so let me make
headline as this country has something
else company cybernetico
and Industry e-learning College this
website this let me add about me called
I am nishanth
Kumar
and I am a
front
print and developer
else we can add here like this click I
click save
and all the information that died at the
side it will be here
so this is called the headline and on
each post we will say headline if we
have it
okay now
so you can also change the profile
picture so click the icon here
add an image let me choose one image
here so let me see this image where is
it
okay this folder this folder then this
folder
and let me choose this image where is it
this image yes
so click upload a picture
and we will see a bar here I mean
progress bar to indicate how much
percentage of the image has been
uploaded
and it's uploaded profile has been
updated and all the images will be
updated like in this top bar in this
profile picture here and here in the
post
icon
now go to home page
and we will see it here as well in the
starter post
place that means your LinkedIn
okay now let me log out and create one
more user and by the way if you have to
create a user with same account I mean
same email you will see an error so let
me do that
because it will not allow us
again join again and we will see this
message called cannot create your
account
okay now let me make this or let me make
Uday
Krishna let me add the email called one
two three at the rate Gmail
Dot com and some password
click agree and join
and we will be on this page we will see
no post that we made previously from the
previous account I mean my account
but we can see the user here in the
connections page we can connect with the
user affiliate connect here
and then we can see its post on the home
page we can remember a file here using
the Nishant Kumar text I mean the
username and we will be on this users
page and all the posts will be here
so
this post had one like and one comment
the post liked was from this user and
the comment was from the same
let me add one more command called This
is
uh put there
click add comment and the name will be
here with the comment we can like the
post from this user account and it will
be counted as two because one from this
and one from the previous account
again collapse comments like this I mean
like this yes I mean if click comments
here we will see it opening up click it
again and we will see it collapsing
same thing we have here is we can view
profile from here and we can edit it
from here
then
we also have the option to search for a
user so let me search for Nishant
and we will see this user here now let
me click this and this user page will
open up I mean this user profile page
with all the data and the post
uh I mean with the post
information
let me make a post from here say
I am
and let me post it
so now after this user post I'm in this
post we will see this post called I am
we can edit this and we can delete this
so
this likes that we have here
it's it's based on
single user single post like
which means if you like a post from one
user that won't be afflected in the
another user so that's a good thing
let me delete the post here and we will
see post has been deleted
fine so that was all for the lending
clone and now let's see how to build
this using reactant Firebase
so the first step to do that is to
create a reactive
and we will use wheat the sweet build
tool
so we can copy the command to create a
direct tab and then we can have
LinkedIn clone enter choose react
JavaScript
and it's created now we have to go to
file
and open folder and go to that folder
which is LinkedIn for LinkedIn clone
yes
fine so we have the packages here inside
packages and as you see let me just make
it smaller yes
now let's install Firebase into our
reactor so we can simply
uh where it is view not view terminal
new terminal
and let's first initialize Firebase
okay let's add
link
din
clone
and continue
then create a project
let's wait
for it to finish
now the project is ready in wire base we
can just go to continue or click
continue
so now what we have to do is we have to
create a web application
so click this click the icon here web
and we can get started so let's make
this as a app name so simple
link
din
clone
and a register app
click it here
and then we have to create a file
in our
project but first let's install Firebase
using this command
so do this
then copy the entire thing from this
configuration
and create a file in Source folder which
will be called as
Firebase
config dot Js
and simply paste it like this
we need this app
variable that has been initialized from
all this data
I mean we have to initialize that
getting input from Firebase
and in this initialized app we are
passing the configuration data all the
API key auth domain storage bucket ID
app ID and all
so we have to export it
so that we can use it into our project
so
it's getting installed I mean Firebase
and it has done installing now let's
start the app using npm run Dev
enter
so on this link it has been hosted in
local so click it and it will open up
here
now let's move to app.jsx and clean a
few things here I'm in the code
remove the state for now and the logo
and use data as well for now
only then we will have a blank canvas
for our project 2. be created
let's change the color to this linen
color
and this color is
let me check the color here
so I have an extension called
what font and if you click that it will
show you the color of the background
so it's rgba 0 0 and 0.9 as opacity
so where is the black color in index.jsx
so replace the diagram color with this
color
and if you check and refresh the page
it's not changing okay okay let's have
it as light then
let me remove all the okay we have
changed the color not in the background
color sorry
about it back end
to it okay it's right yes now see it's
working
we can close the console for now and
then we can change the color to black or
say let me remove the color from here
say we can I mean we can say two one two
one two one black
point
we can also remove this a tags here and
the a hover and let's see what else we
have in the
so we can also remove the buttons and
meta queries
and natural styling okay
fine now save this and we have the color
of LinkedIn
I'm in the background color
here
fine the next step to do I mean what to
do next is let me think let me close the
width okay
so we have Inver and we have imported
all the data from Firebase to our app so
let's click continue to console
okay
now
first of all let's set up the project
yes that was the plan
so what we have to do is
okay I'm also confusing getting confused
okay let me close linking for now
so
in the Firebase we have this app
so let's create endpoints in our app
that can help us login and register
first so we will cover them first
so in the SRC create a folder called API
and in this let's say
auth
API
Dot jsx
let me create a function here
so say export
const
or Alexis not auth API say login
API
which will be an error function
like this now we have to call this login
API into our
let's say a page called login so we have
to create that as well
create a folder called
pages and in the previous folder let's
create a file called
login Dot jsx
make it a functional component
now we have this page for login
but let's also create a component here
for login so create a folder called
components
in the folder create a file
called login.jsx
or say not login say login component.jsx
like this
we have this let me expand it a little
bit
let me make it a functional component
and add one H1 here
login component
now we have to import the logging
component to the login page so say
import
login component from components login
and then simply return it here
like this
now we have to
create routes yes that's also we need to
do
so go to this website called react
router
I mean search it on the Google
then we will have this version 6.4
as the latest version so click tutorial
here
then we have to install it using this
command
so again open the terminal
new terminal and simply put here and
enter
then it will be installed here
okay
we can eliminate our app.jsx we can make
the main file as main.j6 because
every Logic for routing should be
written here
so let's do that
let me import these two things here
create browser router and router
provider
so let me do it here
but
this array we have called router we can
make it in a different folder
so let me create a folder called
routes and in this folder we will have
let's say
make it index Dot jsx because this is
the only file we need here
okay now we can I mean remove this and
copy the link I mean copy this array and
paste it here
and Export the cons router
okay sorry export yes
so we have it here
so to use this create browser router we
have to import it from react router Dom
so let's import it and remove the other
thing router provider so okay
here we have this route for the slash
page I mean slash out the path and the
div is hello Vibe I mean the output
so let me import the login page here so
say import login from Pages login
and replace
this hello world with this page
and make the route as login
fine now we have to import this router
to main.jsx
so let me both import
router
okay wait a second
we have to do it like this
import
router from routes yes and then
we have to feed this router
to this router provider to replace app
because we don't need app we can bypass
the need for this approaches file
so we are done here we don't need this
create router so remove it and remove
app as well
now save this file and see what happens
so
what is the problem here the problem is
no problem
where all this
slash dot which means no route so if you
go to login page
we should see the login component here
as you see also
so this is done now we have a login page
fine
now what we need to wish close the main
dot j6 we don't need this and delete the
app.jsx as well
and the CSS file as well
okay let's relate it
sign I mean fine
so also close the index.js X for now in
routes
to remove login page and let's see what
can we do next yes so in the login API
we have
let me import this login API
to
this page
but wait a second
we can do it like this as well okay let
me import the login API in the
components login component.jsx
or we can import it in the pages folder
as well
here
so we can say import
login API what is the name of it
login
API from API slash auth I mean API slash
auth API
so basically it is a function
so we can call it so for example
let's say we have a button here into
this login API
so first of all okay let me import this
into our components page here
fine now suppose that we have a button
here
that sales log in to link
edin if
we have a button here
so let's say I mean let me check the
button it's this okay
fine okay so let me give some styling to
the button some basic styling
it's a class name
uh login
button
and we can create a file for The Styling
as well
so let me create or let me solve one
more Library called SAS so we can say
npmi sass
this will allow us to use scss not just
CSS
then we can create a file called
login or let me create a file in one
more folder called
let's say s a s s and here
the file will be called as login
page
or component
dot jsx sorry not jsx scss sorry
now we have to import the file login
component Dot scss from this component I
mean from this folder called SAS so say
import
so says
uh
slash login
component Dot scss
now the Styles we will write in this
component will be reflected here in the
UI
so say login button
let's add it here
and say something like uh
with
500 pixels
okay it's too much let's try 300
or 200
or say 100.
or 150.
fine now let's add the height here
as 30 pixels
we have the button in this let's add log
in
to LinkedIn in small case okay just
this is a such a button a simple button
now we have to make the login API call
and
a function so say const
let's say log in
equal to another function
and then we have to call this login API
simple as that
now on this button let's have an on
click event
on click
equals to
just login
now when we when we click the button
also let me add one more thing here
called
cursor pointer
background color as blue
what is the color for LinkedIn
just add
cyan
okay it's too bright so let's add
two one two one two one that's black for
now fine now it flux
now what will happen when we click the
button here they should run this
function called login and then it should
call as login API from
this auth API
so
let's just some know something like
console.log
hello
from login
API
and save this now open the console
make it at bottom
and click the button here
okay we're not seeing anything
so it is calling this function
login API
and it's not getting consoled
okay
is the app running so let me check
yes it's running what is the problem
cannot
could not establish connection okay let
me refresh the page
and click login yes now we are getting
it
fine hello from login API
so this is not going to work for us
because we have to change it so let's
return something
so let's return
let's say
hello
from login API
now we have to record the return from
here into our
login number in.jsx inside login
function so say let
res equal to this
then we can simply console
.log
or yes
now click the button called login to
LinkedIn and we will get the same thing
here
hello from login API
let's send it to login apis
just for distinction
and okay let me refresh the page
and click it and we will get it here
like this
so this is how it works
in the auth API and in the auth API we
have login API
let me write the API or the
function to login
so go to the settings page
okay sorry not settings click all
products here
click Authentication
now in the authentications we have this
where where one second
okay we can resize it more fine I think
it's looking fine
let's get started here okay
let it load for now
then we need the email and password
login for now just to show you how it
works the Firebase login
so enable this click save
and it's enabled
now if you see in the users it's empty
so
let me import a few things from here I
mean here so we can import
what is the function name let me add the
Firebase first
so from Firebase I mean Firebase
slash auth
and here let's import
sign in with email and password and get
auth
I think that's the things we need
so say let auth to S and say get off
so this auth will contain all your data
in the project for authentication coming
from the config file but we have to
import this app into our main file as
well so we can say
import
app
this constant app
from
Firebase config and Save
just need to import this don't need to
use it and that's all
now this auth will contain all your data
and now we have to use this function
time in the email password so we can
remove this
and add it here
in this we have to pass our login data
like the username or email and password
so say it takes two parameters function
called
email comma password
and we have to pass it here with the
auth so auth
comma email comma password
so three things three things it will
take
so save it for now
now let's come to this page and create
two input fields
so say input here it will be
class name
say
uh let's say comma input
and add a placeholder
holder
equals to which will be enter
your email
save and we should get it here
okay but something is wrong here
need to provide options when not being
deployed to housing Source in initialize
app what is this I am getting this just
now
let's check this
Firebase needs to provide options when
not to when not being deployed to
hosting wire source
so in this file we have to import the
auth
from our Firebase config file which is
this
and Export it
so we are importing auth from Firebase
config then fitting the data to this
function called sign in with email
password from Firebase auth so it's done
here now we have to wrap
this in try catch block so say try
and this will go inside the try
but if you save the file we will have an
error which will ask us to add add a
catch block
and say error
then return err so we don't need a DOT
here fine
fine say save it and we have the login
API so I have also fixed the login
components and the credentials are
getting set here using on change event
so this is a pretty basic basic stuff
now this button is linked to this
function
so now we can import and we have
imported the login API from here
from API auth API then we can call it
this login API
like this but we have to feed the
credentials to this login APK
so we can say credentials dot email
comma credentials not password
so it takes two things as params which
is email and password
and I mean the function takes the two
but the sign in with email password
takes three auth from config file and
email and password from the function
params
so save this let me record the response
in one variable but first we have to
return it from here so let's say it
response it is
response equals to this
and have a console.log here
which is sorry not console log return
response
so that it comes here from the function
so let's get it here let's say it's lit
res from here
and console
DOT log
Ras
now open the console
and enter your email account which is
this
at the red Gmail
.com so I have not signed up or added my
account in Firebase and if you see this
user's tab is empty but we are still
tried logging in I mean we are trying to
log in
let me add some passwords
and click login to LinkedIn
and you will see this alert that says
Firebase error auth slash user not found
because
this user it not it's not present inside
the Firebase authentication users tab
if you open the Android networks tab you
will see this block
we have error
then inside the error we have errors and
the message
so we can filter it out or just do
this here alert
I mean ARR error dot errors Dot message
now save this and click the button again
and
you will still get the same thing okay
you will not found
so let me refresh and try again
and my email
com one two three four five six seven
okay we're not getting it here so I
guess we have to add the try cash block
here as well
so try let me copy and I mean cut it
paste in here
then we have a we need a catch block to
catch the errors
so if we have an error we will simply
console
DOT log
this thing basically this so let me
revert it back
to error I mean return error
and paste it here save both files and
now let's try
so open the console
click the button
and still we are not getting it properly
what's the problem
hmm
refresh it once I think we have a
refresh issue in my PC
Nishant that's 440 at the Gmail
.com one two three four five six seven
login to LinkedIn
hmm
tell nothing we are getting
okay so we have error
we have errors
and we have message and we have code
so let's try the code here
or what if we add it here what happens
let's try in both cases Maybe
the error will be here in the
dry block
okay it's undefined
um
okay fine
so okay let's leave it for now we will
try to enter it later because
this is just a code setup
so the basic example I gave you was this
you can remove it from here
and from here
so
we have a login page and One login API
that's calling this method called sign
in with email and password but we have
no users that is why it's showing this
error that user not found
so that was the setup if you want one
more API for register
so we can say export
const
register API okay let me just copy this
and add it here and change the name to
register
API here
so this will take email and password the
same way it tick it took here
but the function name will be different
here so we can say
create user with imminent password
so this will create the user I can show
you how it works so just let me call
this function called registered API and
pass the imminent password
so let me clear all these things
and let me log in
I mean click the button
so if you open the networks tab
we will see these two messages
I mean the
what is it this is the
Network request to sign up
so we have email here and all the things
that it's the simple tokens
so it expires in three six zero zero
milliseconds so maybe it means
or it's seconds I don't know what is
this maybe 36 hours fine
so
if we refresh the file back console we
will see the user here and the provider
will be this email I mean email password
so we have highlight here okay we don't
need this for now
so that is how the register function
works let me invert this back to login
API now if you try to log into the same
account or the imminent password
we will be logged in I mean we will not
get an error
so let me bring back the console logs
and login with LinkedIn
so
we will see
that we're not saying anything
I guess we have to make the function
synchronous
I mean asynchronous so where it is
the async
and let's avoid this
now try again
now we are getting it so the provider is
called
I mean optional option operation type is
called sign in
we have the user so basically we can
utilize
this user
to have the username and all
so we have the email we have the
verified false and all the data
fine we have the provider IDs Firebase
all listings
but we don't have display name so to get
the display name we have to use the
Google authentication from Firebase so
let me show you this add new provider we
have Google
so that's how we can use the Google to
have the display name as well which will
have the name of your Gmail account
so that's much the basic setup pretty
much the basic setup of
the Firebase apis and the components and
the pages routes and all
in the next video we will finish the
login page and the registered page UI
with the complete flow of the logging in
registry
users
on your LinkedIn clone app
we will see how to create login and the
registered page in LinkedIn I mean these
Pages this is the sign in page and if
you click this button called join now
you will see the registered page where
you can create an account
so I will create the UI for this too in
this video
but first if you go to the wheat app
the Home Route I mean slash route is
empty
so we have to change it
so go to routes index.js X and remove
login
for now and now we will get this login
component on the page load which is no
route
now let me remove
I mean let me okay leave the leave all
these things let me
see how to I mean we have to create this
okay
so
first on the top we have the logo so
let's create the logo first
and we need the LinkedIn PNG image for
this
so we can get it from here so we can
search on Google that we need a LinkedIn
PNG logo
so let me see which PNG that we can use
let me see let me see let's try
this image for now
okay so to save it just click the button
called download this PNG
and it will download
yes so it's processing Okay click the
alphabets in order to download PNG web
to pass a test
so the order is as
seven
uh where is f and r
so we have passed the test now let's
create a folder here called assets
which will contain all our images and
assets but it's already here
yes
so all we need to do is just drag and
drop this image into the assets folder
and let me name the
file to this file name called
LinkedIn logo dot PNG
make sure to make it camel case
okay now we have to import this logo
into our in login Dot Login component
yes
so we can say import
link
din logo
from
okay
assets slash the file name
and then return it inside one image tag
so let me remove one last two all these
two
and see
it's here on the top I mean top left
so let me just comment out all of these
items first
so that we can have a blank canvas
here
so here we can simply say
sorry image or IMG SRC
LinkedIn logo
and save this so we have this logo here
we have to customize it according to the
size on the LinkedIn page so say class
name
they should be
LinkedIn logo
so copy the class and come over to this
SAS and the login message
scss file
so LinkedIn logo
this will be let's say
uh width
50 or 40px okay it's too small let's say
80 try the size
okay
it's 80 okay now we have to move it on
the top
so we can try this position absolute
top
20 pixels
and left
now this logo is on the Top If you
scroll I mean if you zoom up zoom in the
logo will be still the same at the same
place
so that's done
fine
okay
now the next thing to do is we have to
create the sign in header and all these
things
the input fails forget password field
sign in
and basically in this part we will cover
the login and sign up UI I think I have
made it clear earlier as well
so let me uncomment
this thing which is the login H1 I just
cut it from here and paste it after the
image
so we will get it here
but we have to make it as sign in so
just add sign in here
and we're getting it here but the
problem is
it is in the center I mean here
so I have to fix that as well so let me
go to the integral CSS
and see
the okay it's I think here
we don't need
all these items so let me just comment
out these for now
it goes on the top okay fine so
basically it means
if we remove these stylings position
absolute
we will get it like this
fine in the sign in page
so we can remove this okay and also
remove the login wrapper contents
now we have this but we have to arrange
the sign in H1
so to do that give it a class name
of
heading
and copy the class
come to login wrapper class and we have
to append this like this so in the login
wrapper we are heading
and we have to make this in the center
or not the center I mean here with some
margin on the left so we can say margin
left
40 pixels let's try
or 80
guess too small
let's try okay let's do this okay
what can we do here
what if we make it 180
okay that's fine I guess
or let's make 200. margin okay that's
fine
fine now next step to next step is to
make the
uh change the font size and weights and
the font style
so let's check what font is this so this
font name is system UI
okay
so we can choose our own font from
Google font so say go font google.com go
to this website
and let me choose a few fonts here like
Roboto
okay let me remove the existing fonts as
existing fonts from before
or we can just use these fonts that I
already have here
to import them in the main dot jsx sorry
not jsx index.scss file
like this so at the top import all the
fonts
okay not like this
wait a second just say import here
yes
and now we can use all these fonts here
I think we can also use system UI so if
we try this
let's say
font style
oh sorry font family this time UI yes
now it is like this
if you check here the font
let's see the same thing we have here is
this system UI
but we also have the 400 which is the
font weight so make font weight as 400.
now what else we have
font size 16 pixels so say
font size what is it 16 pixels
then we have color let's say color
this color rgba 0.0 I mean 0 0 0.99
capacity
now save and we will get it here but
it's very much small
to remove the font
size
and I think it will work
okay it's
what if you make this 500 okay
this looks pretty much like this
fine now we have to make one more
uh description header which is
stay updated on your professional world
so we can just copy the text here
and add it here
and it will be here as well
so the same will be on the P tag
so just like we have
in the heading let's make this as
subheading
so say class name sub
heading
copy this class
and add it here
just make margin left 200 pixels
like this
I guess we are doing
it okay fine it looks fine
but we have to adjust the top margins so
say
margin top minus 30 pixels
or 25 will also work
that is too much
or yes I think let's try 20 also
yes it looks fine also we need the font
family system UI here as well
so added
and just like this we have this
also if you see the color of the
background this is not
Grace it is white
so if you hover this the color will be
the same okay
let's try the login wrapper class here
change the color inside
so in the login wrapper make background
color as white
and this will be here
okay it's not fully on the screen but
it's fine
so we have to adjust a little things as
well for example
in this page
let's add a body
and do margin 0
and padding zero I think that will work
here okay also let me add the height
to 50 VH
sorry not 50 100 BH
but it's not working
okay let me see font weight height okay
I think
if we create a screen here
it will be working I mean if we create
the other input Fields it will expand
but if we make this as important it's
not working
fine so
let's say
index.css we have
we don't have any height here so where
does the height coming from
okay so let's leave it for now
fine
now now now now let's make the input
Fields so
let me uncomment
I mean just
remove the comments from here and let's
see the screen status
so yes we have it here
fine
so in the auth inputs we have to make
changes
fine these are display Flex Direction
column and all but we have to make
them shrink
so we can save width
let's say
100 pixels try 100 okay it's too small
or so small let's try 300.
thank you
a little bit more so make it 400
okay 400
I think that's it now we have to make
them in the center so say align items
enter
okay now if we do that it is getting
shrinked
so we can make it 500
okay that's how it is
removal and items and simple add the
margin left 200 pixels
okay let's try this
yes it's another so the width should be
not 450.
or 300
fine so we have this two fields for
email and password
but we have to style them as well
according to LinkedIn
so
okay so what can we do here so this
here we have like this
so let me think
let me change the replace folder first
so it says email or phone so say
email or phone
and simple it is password and second one
like this
so the height of this is little bit more
so say 40 pixels height here and it will
increase
now we have to change
the
background color for the common inputs
with the background color
White
so it's white
fine also we have a outline on them so
we have to remove that as well
so outline will be none
and also one more thing we need is
border
so border will be
none as well so try none first
okay it completely moves the Border fine
so it's the outline sorry border one
pixels
solid
this okay let's say two one two one two
one
two one two one two one
okay now we have the borders on them
but if you hover them the Border changes
to
blue
so I think this is our client so try one
pixel solid
let's try some blue color
first add blue and just adjust it from
this Color Picker
I mean like this so let's try
which color to try
this color fine
now try this
okay it's not visible properly so I
guess we don't have to do this
just cut it and make it as none
then we have to make a
common input
and we have to choose this so it is
a property called Focus
Focus so when we focus on the inputs the
color should change to the suborder
at this
okay now maybe it's outlined here
yes now it's working
we have this outline here but let's
change the color
where we can't see okay because the
color we can't see because the color is
white here
so remove this
just remove the or just make it as
two one two one two one and we will have
this
but if we remove it completely what
happens then we don't see the
placeholder for here I mean
email or phone so let me refresh the
page okay now we are saying it
fine
so I don't know which color is this so
let's try to find out or just change it
to this
okay
it looks fine for now
okay now we have to change the color of
the placeholder
fine so what we need to do is just add a
placeholder class here just like it was
before
place
folder
and in the placeholder we have to
add this font which is system a y again
so where does this font system UI
and we can add it here
and check what happens when we save
okay it has been changed Also let's try
the phone size a little bit more so 20
pixels
it's too much let's try 18.
yes
also we need some margin on the top so
margin top 5 pixels on the placeholder
or if you try 15 okay it's not working
so make it 16 and see
okay 16 is fine
okay also you see the border is curved
around on the edges so we have to change
that
so we can say border radius
let's say 5 pixels
yes now they are curved
but 5 is too much I guess let's try
three
okay three is also fine
okay
fine so what is next here
background colored VR so if we type
anything here we cannot see the text
so why is that
Let me refresh and enter my email okay
let me do this as well in the input
let's make the type as
email and in this input second input
make the type as password
okay
we cannot see the output here
okay let's add color
which will be
2 1 2 1 2 1.
okay now we can see that
so
here also the font family should be
system UI
so that we can see the same font here as
well
Also let's add the font size here
which is 16 pixels
now these look these look fine much
better
okay
now now we have to
make a sign in button here
or convert the button to sign in button
so in the login button
we have margin top as 20 pixels
but we have to add this
margin left
200.
so if you add it here
this will be here
just like this but why don't we create a
div here and wrap all of these items and
make one margin left as 200 so make a
div here
remember to exclude the image here I
mean the LinkedIn logo from there
then in this div add a class of
login
wrapper
so copy this class
and add it in this page which is okay we
already have login wrapper
so let's say login wrapper inner
okay
so in this login wrapper we have login
wrapper inner
in this we can add margin left 200
pixels only once
and remove from everywhere else
so here I mean from here
then from here
then from here and we'll save it and
they will get the same thing
okay
now we have to design the button so
login button class we have here
so wait where is it here so let me
remove
the width let's make the width to Auto
but it will not work we have to make the
bit
according to the size of the inputs
so what is the sign of the inputs
where it is
300 pixels
so make the same here and it's perfect
but the color is different so we can try
the blue color and to get the references
from the color or for the color we can
visit this site called material UI
material
UI
so here we can search for colors
okay where did the search what happened
colors
and
or we can do this as well so we can say
LinkedIn
color code
so it is this
zero zero seven to B1
in HEX code
we can just copy this
and
so this scss allows us to create
variables so we can say
dollar
okay not dollar how to create variables
says so say
how to create
variables in
says
yes
so let's try
the color name
which is
LinkedIn
blue
and add the color but it's not work it
will not work like that
so we are having some problem style
rules
let's try stack overflow
hmm
okay we have to wrap it in a
string but still not working
hmm
[Music]
let's search for this
variable CS we need this
we need to create a variable
so
okay so make a dollar sign
okay not here in the color
and
it will work also add one semicolon
now you can use the LinkedIn blue
anywhere
so just copy this link in blue and add
it here
in
the login button color
here
save
and if you check the calendar will be
changed
the same thing we can do to this border
here that we have on the input fields
so where is it the Border
here
and we will have it here yes it's now
perfect
let me close all of these things
also if you notice we have some margin
on the inputs I mean yes
so
we can say margin
30 pixels
let's check
or 0.
or 0 30. yes
if we make it 10
okay make it zero and this will be 10.
fine
okay
now we have to make the button as sign
in so make the text as
sine
in
I think I is smaller here change it to I
small
Pine now we can do what
so we have to adjust the height
of the button
also we can remove the margin top from
here because we don't need it
okay
now
just make the height as 40 excels
and okay try 50 as well
the height will be changed
now the color
okay the color is already here
okay wait a second
login button we have only once here
no we have it twice that's the problem
so remove one colors or remove one class
and go to second one and replace this
height to 50.
okay
now see the water is curved so
make border radius
30 pixels let's try yes also remove the
outline
and
the border for now
so we will have the button just like
LinkedIn
but if you want to check the color of
this button just click inspect when
clicking right clicking the button
and check the CSS
so the color is
um
7 3 b100731
okay it's 7 2 b 1
just make this as London colored or blue
one
and say
blue
two
so here we will have seven three not
seven two
like this and wherever we have LinkedIn
blue make it linking blue one
and here also
but wait here it should be two now save
this and let's see
okay undefined variable LinkedIn blue
blue yes make it two
now we have it here
okay
that's fine
now if you hover this button the font
size is same which is system UI
so just copy the font size and add it in
login button
and now let's check
also
a few things to be noted here is
the font family okay I mean for not
family
Point weight is 600.
added
then we have colored as FFF so color
ffff
okay six times
fine then I think it's all
here
so we can exit part font and save this
to see what happens
okay let me add font size as well
20 pixels
yes I think it's perfect but if you make
it 19 or 18 let's see what happens okay
it's perfect
now and let's add a hover effect on this
so login button hover
we just need to change the color
so say background color
as something so let's add one more color
LinkedIn blue three
and
we have to make some darker variant of
this color so just slide the marker
down
and change this to 3 where it is
and Save
now if you hover we will see the same
thing here
that we have on the screen
fine
okay where is the button button button
ads let's add margin top
20 pixels
that's fine
okay now what we have to do is we have
to make this thing
so we will not use sign in with Google
account we will use the
uh only which I mean we will only use
sign in with Google account not Apple
fine so
we can make one
HR here
HR for the HR where it is r
here and Save
so you will get one horizontal line here
fine so we have to make this outside
this div
INE fine and let's try to Type R inside
okay the problem is we need to create
one HR with or between them
so let's say text between
HR tag
let's try this
okay we can in HR class data content we
have a property
so you can try this
so make it a self closing tag then
save this
okay it's not working because we can
give this a class of HR text
fine
and then check the CSS
so where it is HR text it's here
so we can just copy
the whole class and add it here in the
CSS
okay now we have this so let's change
this and
to or
we will have this
we have to change the color so let's
change it to
a darker variant
this
now it's changed okay not this
okay where is the color color background
color
okay I think I think I think
this is the color is this
let's try this no this is the font color
okay okay let's leave it for now hmm
we have this R and after or we have the
button called sign in Google account so
we have one more thing for you to show
you
so
we can create the button or we can
import a library which is called
Google
signed in button
so we can check this react Google button
foreign
so just install the package here
where is the ndim command to install it
yes here it is
open the terminal
I mean the console
and now let's see
let's import the button here at the top
then just copy the button and add it
here
after that Dave HR after the HR
and we can
see our button here
fine
so wrap this in a div
and
add the class name here which was
login wrapper inner
no but it will not work
to say
Google button
here
so just copy the class
and let me add here at the bottom
okay now what we have to do is we have
to
add this thing which is margin left 200
pixels
to the current class 10 that we created
here save it and we will have it here so
also we can add width 300 pixels
to expand this or make it important I
guess okay we have to add this on the
button so say class name
button
I mean let's make this as Google button
can
container
copy this class
and just add it or replace it here
in this
we can have Google
button
and add the width inside here
now just copy the Google Google button
class and add it here
I think we have to make this as
important yes now it's working
so we have sign in and sign in the
Google account
fine
so now the next thing is to create this
thing this join now
option
so let's do it in the same div so we can
say A P tag
and just copy this whole thing and add
it here
and you will have this but this join now
it should be a span tag
okay like this
and in the pan let's see a class give a
class name of
join now
so
in the button container yes let's do it
here
the join now will be of color
LinkedIn
where is it the top linking blue one
make it like this
we have this also
font
family
y
um too much points are here
so we only need system invoice so remove
all the left all the other fonts
we also need to add cursor as pointer
so if you hover it
the cursor will be changed to pointer
also let's give this P tag a class name
of
go to
sign
up
okay we should be
after Google button okay in the
container so we can do it here after the
button
and they should be text line as Center
let's try this
okay
it's not fine
so
let's add margin a little bit from the
left margin left
in the top not top margin left
uh 30 pixels
or say 40. 50 okay that is fine
now we have this
go to sign up okay let's change the font
size here font size
as 20 pixels
too much
try 16 or 18 18 is fine
copy the same and add it here in the
class as well
so we have this
fine
but if we zoom in it causes some
problems in responsiveness but we will
fix it later
okay so now we have this done
okay
but the thing is we need to wrap I mean
we have to make
this entire color of the background as
white
so in this login wrapper let's check
make the color as white and make it
important I guess
okay what if we add height
as 100 VH okay now it's working
perfectly yes
we have this and fine
now the login page is done pretty much I
guess
so let's hook up the these things here
like
I mean I think they're already hooked up
so we can try signing in
so we can add one email Nishan s4403
Gmail
.com and the password one two three four
five six seven
open the console
and click sign in here
and the request has been sent and we are
getting messages
so let me install one Library called
react to specify
react
to specify
so in this Library we will have a post
message box that we can use
so install it here
then close the console or terminal then
we have to import
these things
so where is the main component I mean
main.jsx
so we can import it here I mean the CSS
and the toast container remove toast for
now for now
then we have to return this toast
container in our
Dom reference here in the react Dom
create root just like we have in the
just like we have as router provider now
we can use this toast container
so to use this go to this function and
we can do toast
so we have to import those from it's
Auto imported those dot success
and let's add the message
if you look into the documentation here
we should see it
where it is yes toast dot success and
the message say
sign
in
to LinkedIn
now save and let's try to sign in add my
email
and the password
okay we are getting this message that we
are signed in
so
we already I mean we also need one for
error so if the password is wrong or
something is wrong
again simply throw
this message
please check your email and password
your team or District credentials
hidden
Shields
now let me try to change the password
Here and sign in
so we will see this message called
please check your credentials
fine so it's done
okay
now the next thing is to create the flow
for the Google button sign in
so we can just go to this page called
uh sorry not page API
OS api.jsx
let me create one more function here
called
Google sign in API or Google yes sign in
API so we have to import one thing also
called
um
sign in with
okay let's try Google auth provider
I don't for I don't get the name I
remember writing the name
Okay Google Earth provider I think it is
and sign in with pop-up
okay now let me create one instance of
this auth provider so
we can do it this inside the function
here select
auth equals to
uh no not auth
Google provider
equals to new
Google dot provider
fine
then we have to pass this provider and
the auth
to this function sign in with pop-up
so we can say this
and we have to pass provider name oh I
think first is the auth
and then the provider
then let's return this response from
here so say let res equals to this
and return
Ras
now import the function in the login
component
so
yes from this message I mean where yes
from here
Google sign in API
okay now we have to create a function
here as well for
Google provider sign in so say const
time
in
or
Google
sign in
and save the file in this we will call
this sign in I mean Google sign in
API
we will record the response in a
variable called response
and simply console.log
this
response
now we have to click the button and run
the function called Google sign in
so just remove all of the items all the
Callback function and leave it at that
but we need to enable the sign in
Provider from Google so go to
firebase.com
I mean console
now method sign in we have to add the
provider called Google
okay
click this and enable
add your email account and Save
now let's see if it works or not
so it's savings let's wait for it for
few minutes
or hours
yes we have Google provider here
but
we have to remove this here because we
will login with same email no matter the
provider
so let's see what happens when we sign
in with say email but from Google
so open the console and click the button
called sign in with Google account
so I am seeing one pop-up
so if you did just like I did you can
see that too
I think we have to
add the I mean yes we can see that
we don't need to do anything so let me
choose my email account
on the pop-up that we got
now if you check the console
we are getting nothing okay
let me see
okay let me open the Inbox tab
and try again
sign in with Google
choose my email
and we are getting this
yes see now we have the display name is
Nishan Singh that is on my email
if you refresh this Firebase console the
provider will change to Google here
okay fine let me log in with the other
account
my other email account
this email
so if you now check
here in the Netflix tab
we have this display name as same but
the email is different it is this email
and now if you check the console here
we will be having this email here as
well the providers will be Google
fine now we have this Google sign in
button that you can use to sign in
fine so we don't need the register
button I mean register page for this
method for sign in with Google account
it will automatically register you to
that page
now let me create the register page here
so create one more file called
register
compo
net Dot jsx
and in this page also a file called
register Dot jsx
this will be a functional component just
like login
and we have to import this register
component here
import register component
with the second wait is it okay we have
to make it functional as well only then
we can import it
import register component here and
simply return it here
foreign
we have to make all our things here but
we have to add the routes as well first
so click routes
and create one more object and make this
as
register and cop I mean import the page
called register
register
from
Pages slash login sorry not login
register
and return it here
now if you go to the registered page
let's see what happens
so you will see this registered
component page here
so now let's create the registered page
and that same I mean it's pretty basic
as this login page
so now let's hook up this button coil
join now to the registered page
so on this click I mean on click we
should have the Handler two transference
to the register page
for that we need a few things from the
react router which is called
use
navigate
fine let me create one instance of this
use navigate
fine
or we can create one helper function for
this
so let me try to create this or folder
called
helpers in this let's say
use Navi git Dot jsx
so we can copy I mean we can import the
use navigate from react router Dom
and then
this navigate
so let's say export
and now let's try to use it but first we
have to import it so import
navigate from helpers
you will navigate
and on the join now we can say on click
navigate and we have to add the route I
mean we are passing the route here
so
let me create a function here so say
const
navigate
and
we can remove this and
okay let's say
just okay
um
let's say navigate instance
just say instance
so
every time we click the button we will
run this function called navigate
from here
we will pass
the param
and
then we can simply say instance and in
the instance we can pass the param to
navigate to that page
so we have to pass the route so say
register
now let's try this click the button call
join now
nothing is happening so let's check
the console
it let me fetch the page
and
use context
okay hooks can be I think we have to
make this a component
so let me cut and make it function
component
and then add here
don't need return for now
don't need this okay
import it at the top
let me export this
it will not work like that
so I guess we have no choice so what is
the problem let me see
so hooks can be already called only
called inside the body of react
component and blah blah
hmm
so so so so
okay we have to import react I guess
we're not working okay let's let me
add it here I mean we don't need to do
all of these just
create I mean import the you will
navigate so let me
control Z
all these things
let me figure this out and come back
later but but for now let me do it like
this
so on the button we can on click
navigate to the register page
add a slash before the register string
now let me replace the page
now let me click this button
and we will be on the registered page
then that's fine
okay now in this register let me see
what is it here
so we have the login logo I mean the
logo and the strings
so they can just copy
this entire class names
I mean all of these things for now
copy and paste it here
okay save this
but we will need okay just let me copy
the entire component and paste it here
so that we don't have to build it from
scratch
just change the name to login name of
login component to register component
and on the registered page we will see
the same thing now let me change this
string which is make most of your
professional life
so
on sign in we have to do this
fine added
we have this
then we don't need the second Peak last
name in the history component so remove
this
we have email and email or phone number
here so let me add the
placeholder here
then we have password six or more
characters
okay let me add it here
remove the empty spaces between them
rings from strings
and we have this
then we have already on LinkedIn signed
in so we have to change this as well
here
so where it is
sign in so just cut the text I mean copy
the text and paste it and we can see it
here but now this
not now this route will be login route
or slash out not login
now click this button and it will be on
the sign in page
fine
now
we have this thing but I don't think we
need this this terms and conditions and
all also cyanide has been changed to
agree and join so let's change it as
well
agree and
join what is spelling of join g o I can
save and we have this here
fine
so we have no sign in page and the login
page but the thing is
we don't need to use the login API here
we have to use registered API so go to
this API page orthoped.jsx
and
import registered API not login API
so here we place the login API
with registered API
and Save
so we can say
uh you or just say account
created
you can change the those messages as
well
so here let's say cannot
create
your account
so in case we cannot create an account
this will
show this toast message called cannot
create your account
let's try this
now we already have two accounts here
which is this and this so let's try to
create account using these two
and let's see what happens
so we can add nishanth s440 at the rate
gmail.com and the password
so click agree and join
and we will see this thing cannot create
your account because we already have
this account in the console
now if you change something like slide
email changes then click again join
we will see account created because now
we have an account on Firebase with this
email and the provider is this
fine
now let me do the last thing here
which is called transferring us to the
home page
so we can save pages
create one page called home.jsx
make it a functional component
similarly create one component for home
the home
component Dot jsx
same as functional component
now import this home component inside
this page so say import home component
here
and
return it here
like this
make this as an H1 here
to highlight it
now save this
okay
fine
so when we are registering we should be
on the home page or when we are logging
in
in that case as well we should be on the
login page sorry on the home page
so
we can say uh what is the name history
dot push
sorry not history sorry sorry navigate
to
slash home
but we don't need we have to create the
routes here so in the index.jsx in
routes
replicate the object
make the Home Route here
then import the home page so the import
from Pages home and return the element
class I mean element component
now if you go to home page we should see
the home text in H1
see
now
on this login success or related success
we are getting navigated to home page we
have to do with this in the login page
as well
in this function so after all signing in
we should see this
so in this as well I mean in Google sign
in
we should
transfer us to the home page
now let's try to sign in and see what
happens
add my email or just click the button of
Google sign in
okay
we are first getting the sign in page I
mean home component and then we're
signing in so we have to fix that and
that's for the next video
let me sign in with this
so gmail.com one two three four five six
seven click sign in
okay we have to check the credentials
okay
okay let me try
this here
click sign in
now we are on the home component and we
are having this toast called signed into
LinkedIn
and in the next video we will handle
the predicted routes and the home page
basically so thank you for watching my
video
on the second I mean second part of the
series on how to create a LinkedIn loan
using react and Firebase
let's see how to check the
authentication States
for the application
I mean when we're logged in or when
we're logged out
so come to the homepage.jsx we have home
component and in login we have login
component
so
we need a function so it is called
import
on off State change
fine same way Import in the login page
let's we will edit
and
let me import the use effect hook
same way in the login page
and now
we will create the effect so say use the
effect
and in the use effect we will call this
function called on or state changed
so this will take our authentication
variable
from this Firebase config file so same
port
auth from Firebase config so we have to
feed it here
then it sends us a response as callback
so we can say console
dot release sorry console.log res
save it so let's go back to the home
page I mean slash home
open the console now
so we are getting this user impl or it
means the data so it contains all the
data like email that we used to sign in
display name and all so we need the
access token
so
we can filter it out like this
the same thing we need to do is in here
so just copy the effect use effect and
add it here
and Save
so save it here as well
in the login we have used effect which
with this or not State changed and here
as well
it's fine
okay we've absolutely both auth and
edit I mean import it here
now come to the login page and we will
see this same thing
the authentication token
so we have to check here
if this token exists
we have to
go to the login home page so we can
then navigate
to
slash
home
now we need to navigate so let me import
it here import
you will navigate from react router Dom
and say let
Navi gate equals to use navigate
so do the same thing in the home page
and here as well
save and Save
so
we have to also get this checked from
here and add it here
but here in the home page we have we
will have the condition as opposite or
reverse
so if this token is not here go back to
the login page or else state of the home
page that we don't need to write
so if you go to the login page now it
will throw us back to the home page
instantly
fine
so but it's not instantly it takes some
time
so we can add a loader here
so let me install one Library here
called okay what library should be
installed so let's install aren't design
a and t d
and Design
second most popular UI Library
or react
so click development here
we need to install it so we can do it
like this using NVM install aren't ready
so open the terminal
and
paste the command
meanwhile when like it is stalling let's
make let's create a component
so in the folder called components
create one more folder called common so
it will it will contain our common
components like this loader Dot jsx
so fine it's done I mean it's getting
installed
now what are the additional things that
we need to do to use on design
hmm
so so we have to
just do our
copy this let's try
okay I think something else we need to
do
so what
design
okay it's not here
I'm using it after so long click
components
okay let's try this
fine
so in the loader we need a functional
component fine then we can search loader
here
or not loader spinner
in this
all right
so we can choose any spinner
for example let's choose the spinner
import space and spin
so I don't know what is the space
so then we have to copy the screen large
and add it in the div
fine
space okay we have to
let's try I mean add the space here as
well
and Save
now let me import this loader component
in this home page
so import
loader from components common loader
and if
else we have simply turn
this loader
now we are on the home page
we have to replicate this in the login
page as well
for that let's also import this loader
component
like this
now go to the login page
and
we don't see anything it's loading
so what could be the problem
I guess we don't have to do it here
so what can we do
let me remove this
[Applause]
and
this from here
okay I think it has been crashed
open the view in terminal
okay it's reloading okay
let's try this again
it was loading
okay it's now loaded we can refresh the
page
let me go to the login page
and
we can I mean we don't need we don't see
this loader here
so I guess we need a state here so
create a state called
loading and set loading
use state
let's say false initially
okay not false sorry true
so also import the state Hook from react
you state
so
when we will have else here this set
loading will be sent or set to false
so that
if okay one second
okay let's try this
so here I will create a check so if
loading is true
it means we need to show the loader this
component
or else we have to show the login
so in the login let's go to login now
and try this
so LCL order and then the home component
yes it's working
the same thing can be done here
so we need this loading state
and use statehood
then
if loading is true I mean set loading we
have to do here
also
in the false version of this
then if loading
is true then we will have home component
sorry not home component the loader
else we will have the home component
so if you go to the home I mean to the
login page
we will sell order
and within
we will see the home component so it's
working
it's fine
so if loading is true here
it means
remain in the log on the home page if
loading is true
I mean if this is false it means we need
to be the on the home page okay
fine let's save it for now
I also I'm not getting what I'm saying
so in this loader giveness Diva class
name
of
loader
and we have to make the loader in the
center
so
we can create one more file called
uh loader or just say common
node scss
let me import the common file into
this okay and we have to import the
common file into this
file called
loaded.jsx so we can say import
common
Dot scss
and if we write The Styling here for the
loader let's say display of flex
and let me just do this for now
remove this
and if you refresh the page
okay let's make this as
just revert the loading State now we
will save the downloader only
so if you go to the home page
I think it's compiling our code
let me open this in the new tab
okay now we see the loader only
yes so display Flex
justify content Center
align items Center
let's make the height as
fifth t
v h
and say okay 50 is less let's let's make
now we have this loader you can also add
a text here so say loading
please wait
we will have this
so in this loader we have to make one
more thing called
Flex direction as column
fine also let's add some Gap 20 pixels
between them
and we will have this
fine let me make this as a P tag
and fine
so if you do this we have to decrease
the Gap as 10. fine we have this loading
placement
if you want styling let's add P tag here
and make the font family as
what is the what was the font so in SAS
we have this
the font was system UI
and also copy the stylings
other styling
now we have this
Also let's make font size as 20 pixels
now it's fine
now we can close the common clss yes
and what if we import the common scss
into the login component
or even better in the index.css so that
we don't have to use it every time
I mean we don't have to import it every
time
so we have changed this CSS to scss
so we have to change here as well
so now save
and it will work the same
now in this index.css let's make import
URL
I mean one step back assets not sorry
not assets
uh two steps back what happens
one step back yes components common
common dot CSS
so if you are doing this we can remove
it from here and it will work
so let me show you how it will work if
you remove this
and give it a refresh
this styling will be reverted back to
the original styling that it had
previously
fine
so it works and it works
fine so now let me divide this back to
loading if loading is true
or if you go to the login page we will
see loading and then the home component
fine
so that's how in the on or straight
changed or not State change works
in
from Firebase in react or in any other
Library
so I think that's all for now and in the
next video we will learn how to use this
reactant I mean how to create the top
bar from LinkedIn so let me show you
what I mean
so if you open LinkedIn
let me go to the home page you see this
top bar have we have here which contains
the logo the search option home page and
all all the icons
now let's create the top bar
in the LinkedIn clone
the first step to do that is to create a
folder called
uh sorry not the folder yes a folder but
in the common folder so say
um
top bar
in this top bar we will have an index.j6
file
for writing the style I mean the HTML
and one for the styling
fine
so make it a function component and just
change this to
top bar and import the index.ss file
here so import
index Dot scss
now we have this top bar here
by the way I have made a few changes
here for example
in this login okay I have not made it
but let's make it yes
so
replace this margin left with this so
display Flex
Flex Direction column
and justify content Center align item
Center
and just do the same thing
at a place where we have like this other
margin left 200 pixels
so I have done that to make sure that
the screen says I main screen stays
responsive
let me show you what I mean so come to
the pages folder and open the login page
so let me remove this check here for now
I mean let me remove this navigate to
home
and in the home page as well
now let's come to the login page
and we will see this page as responsive
but okay do this as well
name this loading State here
now let's check
okay right okay okay
I guess
oh what can we do okay let me just
revert this to this and remove this from
here
now we can go to the login page
okay it's
getting unresponsive
[Music]
so go to the
site again and we will see this as in
the perfect Center even if you
maximize this page
so that's what we did now
in the login component.scss
now let me divide this back
and save now refresh and the same same
thing will happen again because we have
changed
this condition for authentication now we
have home component
now let me copy sorry not copy let me
import the Stop Bar in
this page called
home page so come to okay let's import
it
in the home component first
so home component it's here
or or plenty way to do that is to create
a folder called layouts
in this page I mean in the folder let's
make a layout for home so say home
layout Dot jsx
now in this layouts page we will have
the functional component
and here we will import the home page
so import home from
Pages slash home
now we have to return it here
fine we have returned it here
so nothing is changing we can send the
home component but it will change I mean
it will not change
because we have to import the home
layout.jsx into the routes
index
so replace this home with the layout so
say
layout
I mean layout slash home layout
and add this here
now save and the same thing will be here
and fine
now let's import this top bar from the
in from this component here
so we can say import
top
bar from this component and render it
before home so that we can see it on the
top like this
now we don't need the layout we only
need
these two files in the same folder the
top bar and we are going to work inside
them
so let me remove the text from here
like this and Save
so nothing we have
so let's give this Diva class name of
let's say
top bar Main
copy the class come to index.cl scss and
say
width as 100 pixels or hundred percent
not pixels
I should be
let's say 50 pixels
now we will see that this home component
H1 has been margined down to this place
let's add the color
so it's the background color let's add a
red color just for demonstration
and we will see this thing just like we
have here
so but the color should be different so
let's get the color
from this index.css which is this color
fine
so we can make
one variable here
so let's try that but I don't think okay
let's leave it for now just add the
color here we will do that by labeling
later
so we have this white color
top bar here we can make the height to
60 VH or PX yes now it's fine
now let me have the logo here so we can
import the logo from the assets folder
so it's LinkedIn logo.png so let me
import
import link
din
logo
from assets
from
uh
go back again go back go to assets
slash this file name
the whole file name LinkedIn logo
save this
now we can use this logo
so in this top bar let's add an image
tag or IMG tag and Source will be
this LinkedIn logo let's add the alt tag
and fine so it will be very much very
much big so make a class name and say
LinkedIn
logo
but I think we already had a class I
mean we have a class here
that we can use so come to the SAS and
login component
where it is let's try let's see
login button login wrapper heading
subheading
LinkedIn logo
yes this
so
we can add it here but we can change the
class name
or we can use let's try the class name
here to see if it works or not
yes it's working but we need to shrink
it down even more not just a TPX
so I guess
just add it here but change
something like divided back like this
and let me copy the class and add it
here
sorry what is happening
here we have to add
so make it 70 let's try 70.
okay try 65
pixels and now I think it is fine
we can also add margin left
let's say 20 pixels
yes let's also increase the size of this
top bar let's make it 70.
so if you are making it 70
we have to make sure that every element
inside the top bar should be on the
center I mean vertically so we can add
display of flex
and align items Center
now it's in the center as you see it has
been moved
now about the other icons let's say
search home and all we need icons for
this
so let me import or I mean what let me
install a library called react icons
from npm
so the command is here nbm install react
icons
and let me click or open the terminal
and install this Library
it's getting installed
fine
so we have the
page here called react icons on GitHub
where we can search the icons for
example you see we have home here let's
search for home
and we will see a lot of icons here
so you can choose your own icon so let
me use this icon
it has been copied to clipboard
and then we can import it I mean just do
this here but first let's see how to
import an icon
so
let me go to the home page and to import
it we can do this so this is the import
command
in the react I mean import yes now let
me search for this icon here AI outlined
home
so we can add it here and see the
type of Icon we are using is AI
fine now we can just copy this icon as
react component and render it here
I think that will work
okay will it work let me let me try
um
I think it should work but it's not
working so let me refresh the page
oh let me open the
terminal
I think it's getting Reloaded
so let's wait for it
um
let me revert it back
to
this far beer and say what happens
let me cut this and paste it in a new
tab
because my PC is getting slow uh slow
and slow
what is the problem here
I think it's taking too much time to
load
foreign
so let's wait for it to be responsive
and
just have the icon here yes now it's
here
I mean it's getting
loaded
yes so it has been optimized I guess
so if you save this we will see the bear
icon here but we need the home icon so
say far
I mean let's say AI
and from AI we can import
home so
let's search for home and it has been
copied if you click the icon
and replace the bear with this icon
now we have this home
so
what are the params that we need for
this
so let me check
okay
let me check the
uh I think it's width
wait can we check that
let's try width
width properties let's say 30 or 40. if
you save
it is not getting increased so I guess
it should be 40. pixels
okay um
that is an prop that is a problem
let's try npm here
what is the
I mean I mean how to
add width here in the AI icons
okay where I can provide a blah blah
blah size yes size sorry not width
size
so psi should be 40.
and we can remove these things
now let's try yes it's fine what is
perfect
so it's a little bit large but it's fine
fine now we have to wrap the icon all
the icons from react icons in one div
like this so that we can
arrange them like this
okay
fine the next icon is this icon called
profile so let me search for this in the
library
so it's not the profile let's use it so
say users
by the way we also use we will also use
the AI like this I mean a icons so we
can try this icon just for demonstration
my friends
and then we can copy this and paste it
and add here the size will be same
now we have to separate them so in the
top bar main class we can have
this so we have we are having display
flex and we can say
justify content
face
between
justify content not self
space between
and Save
so that is the problem they are being at
the last
so it takes
I mean this top bar Main
in the top bar main we have one image as
a parent element and this device parent
so they are on the opposite ends of this
page so in this we have to make let's
say react icons
copy the class
and let me add it here and do the same
thing
here fine
we have to also add some width here so
width should be hundred percent let's
try 100
okay it does the opposite so try
20. yes 20 is too much let's try 100 I
mean 10. or 15
yes 15 is a sign between them now let's
quickly add the other icons
I mean I don't need with I don't think
we need to use this here so let's see
what happens if we remove it
it's much better
but the distance between these two
doesn't increase
so we can have a margin left here
I don't need this suggestions margin
left
30 pixels
yes that's fine also in the icons we can
have one class name but we will do it
later
now the next icon is called this diff
case icon
so let me
search for the briefcase icon here
yes
So currently no icons are from this
Library called AI so we have to make it
from other ones which is called BS or BS
merits boost bootstrap
so we can try this
make this as
slash BS
then you can have this here
and the size as 40
now could not cut just copy this
no save
and it should load in a few minutes I
guess
because I think it's getting optimized
from BS
so let's wait for it
yeah so it's loaded
but see now the problem here is it is
getting
like this so we have to make the width
to let's say Auto or 30 let's try 30.
because it will be like if you add icons
this will go down
like it will sink
the next thing we need icon is this
let's try
okay
let's
add a search icon
this search
and now we have this from AI outline
they can come to this home page and at
the search icon at the very first
save and we have this so also now we can
increase the width 35
and here we have we have
this icons
which is the top bar icons
fine
now
in all the I mean svgs or this
icons give it a class name of
let's say react icon single icon
let me repeat it all over
and let me copy the react icon and paste
it here
and say cursor should be of pointer
now if you hover them the cursor will be
of pointer
let me make the search icon a little bit
more smaller so that
let's say 75 you're not here here
and Save
now I guess it's fine so what else is
remaining here as icons we have
messaging
and we have
this notification so let's add them also
let's say message
let me import it from here
copy the briefcase
and add two more one for messaging
which is this and other four
the
notifications say Bell
let's try this also from AI
and replace this
fine then we have it like this
so we have to make it as 45 or 55 or 65
but it's looking ugly so try okay it's
ugly because I think we have to decrease
the size of the icons let's see
in all other sizes
and we have it here
now let's decrease the width to 55 or
45.
now we have them as here
but it's look it looks a little bit
ugly yeah so I guess the let's try 55
percent here and I think that's perfect
for now so we have a search icon so make
the search icon small so make it as
or 30 will also work yes so let's leave
it at 30. we have search icon home
profile and all
fine so but the thing is if you hover
them the color changes
so
how to do that
so let's try this I mean react icon
uh hover class
whatever it is and then the color should
be let's say red
when we hover them
save
and yes it's working it's red but we
don't need red we need black
so say
two one two one two one
so we already have black colored here so
we have to change it here
so we can make the color change here
we have to make it grayish a little bit
Gray
so
we can slide it like 5b5 5B yes if you
know hover over them it will turn it
turns to black or not black two one two
one to one so let's make it pure black
now it's much better
we can use the hover effect
we can make the color of the icon a
little bit more
on the gray on my I mean white side
that looks premium type thing we have
this effect
now we have the top bar
let's also add one more thing which is
the user icon here
a small user icon
so we can have an image so first let me
get an icon I mean the user icon that
will that we will later replace
with our own icon
so we can have this icon
spng let me download this
any icon you can use
the free download
I have to sign in
to download this
so we don't need this what is this
now to close this from here
okay download PNG
okay
it's downloaded let's move the file to
this assets folder and make it as
user
dot PNG
let me import the file here
here
so import
user
from
assets
okay too much back routing assets and
user dot PNG
now we need one image tag just like this
we have to add it here after the div
IDE now save and we can close all the
other icons
I mean other tabs
so here the source will be not Linked In
but user
and also the alt tag
now we have this user but it's not a
background I mean proper background
image
so
let's search for another another one so
user icon
um in the images let's try
let's try this but this we already used
let's try from PNG tree okay this is the
same
download PNG okay
it's not a background image so say
user icon PNG that's how we search
let me try from here user icons
let's try this let's click download
let's see PNG free
let's see it 252 to 50.
unlock all
formats okay I think that is for free
and this one as well so download this no
matter
and download it here it is move this to
here assets
and delete this page I mean release
delete this file and make this as
user dot PNG
now let's see what happens
if you try to refresh and now it's
perfect
but one thing to do is change the
class name so you say user logo
save and come to the index.scss
and say user logo
with 30 pixels
too small huh 40
okay 40 is fine
also
we have to make them on the right I mean
top right
so we can say position absolute
right zero pixels
I mean not zero in entirely make it 10
or 20 or 30 or 40 or 50.
now we have this user icon here
let me also add the cursor as pointer
so if you hover that cuts it if you
hover this icon you will see
the pointer cursor
now we have all the top bar icons like
search home this that and like
here
we have the user icon
and the home component text
so that's all for today I am in for this
video and in the next video we will
learn how to create the home page all
the post requests and get requests
now let's move on to the home page I am
in this page in LinkedIn the feed page
so click home
by the way let me also create routes for
the home I mean top bar yes
so open this components
common top bar index.jsx
and let me create
one function called navigate or say go
to
or go to route
it will be an error function
so on each of the items here we have to
map I mean not map I'll assign this so
on home we will say on click
and we'll send
the data
to this function called go to route
and this will be
the current route of the page so here
it's slash
home
now in this function
let me first in let me first
uh import the use effect hook sorry not
use effect hook let me import the use
navigate so we can say
import use navigate from react router
Dom
then
let me create an instance of the
navigate so let's select
navigate equals to use navigate
now we can navigate through this
navigate
um
by the way these things I mean this
function takes a value
so let's say route
and here we will just navigate
to route
now if you click the home we'll be on
the home page now let me add this on
click on one more
so let's say on this second one called
user switch so let's say profile
now save and click second one and we
will go to the profile page
but for now we will get this error
because this page doesn't exist
so if you go to profile we will see no
page I mean the error so let's leave it
for that I mean leave it for now
okay
now what to do is just go to home
component and remove this H1
now we have to replicate the entire
thing from here but I mean not the
entire thing just this post message box
first
so
in this common let's create a folder
called let's say
uh
post update
in this component we will have an
index.jsx
and one for CSS or scss
when the j6 file
we will have
what is what is what is what is
happening
we'll have
post status
now let me import okay not import first
just import this scss file into this
component
now it's done
now we have to import this post status
in the home component so we can
import it import
status like this
and return it here
like this
fine it's done
now whatever we will do here we will
wait selected here
so let's first create this box
so let me make a div here
another div
find save this div will be a this div
will have a class name of let's say
post status class
now copy the class and come to
index.scss for post status
and
let me create the card here first
so we will do this
what do I mean by this is
with 100
not 100 let's say ATP percent
then height
uh 100px let's try
for now but I didn't think it should be
100 let's make it 50. now we need
background color
so let's make it white
now save and let's check the
page here we'll see this thing
but it's not a card
I mean yes it's a card but we have to
arrange them arrange it also
let's check the color here what color is
this I think it's not white it's white
smoke
now we can try this and fine it's look
it looks fine
now we have to arrange this in the
center
so to do that
in the home component of jsx make this
as
home
component
and copy this class
come to this scss which is in SAS
and let me add The Styling here for now
so we will say display of flex
justify content Center
and let's see what happens
align items Center
but it disappeared I don't know why
okay home component let's check the
class what
it should work but we don't see it here
but why
let me just comment out this and then we
can see
okay I guess the home component my post
status okay let's do this in this
component itself
so give this
class name of this parent div
post status
mail
in this we will have the same class
host
let us
mean
and we will add it here
save this as well now it's in the center
but not vertically
so we can give it a little bit margin
from the top
so let's move this class here
fine
now we have this I think 100 PX was fine
yes
now let's give them some margin at the
top the margin top let's say 30 pixels
is there
fine
okay let's try to make this as 120. okay
it's also it's all it it's also looks
fine it also looks fine
we need one border 1px
solid
two one two one two one
but this is too much
dark to dark for us
let's try to make them this
still dark
let's move it towards the white
let's see okay this looks fine
but still
this should be fine yes
now we have this box
borders are curved so we can say border
radius
uh 10 pixels what happens
then do we have 10 I think it's small
let's try seven
yes I guess seven is fine
now in this we have a input I mean it's
not an input
it's a
button type thing because if you click
this we will open a model here
so let's create that as well so in the
post status let's add a button
and this will be called as
start a post
now save we will have a button here
give the button a class name of
open
post model
copy the class come over here
then do open post model
then
add this at the bottom
I mean not the bottom let's make Center
so if you want if you want to make it at
Center we can do the here and do this
here as well display Flex
justify content Center
align items Center
yes it's in the center
now all we have to do is expand this I
mean give some weight 300 percent
let's write 90 or 80 okay it is fine so
now we need some height as well so try
for TPX
also so we have this startup host
button
but the problem is I mean the thing is
the text inside the button this is on
left aligned so we can say left I mean
text line
left
let's try if it works or not
yes it works now we have this
but the color is black
so we can say color black
or not black entirely two one two one
two one
we have this
now let's change the color of
this button background color so say
background color
let's try this color
fine
also we can move to a lighter
shade
now it's fine it's gray we can do more
lighter
yes I guess it's fine let's remove the
outline so the outline
none
also border will be none as well
so we have this but I think we don't
have zero border I mean non-border let's
try one pixels solid
and
some color so let's try this color
now we have this okay but the height is
not 40 it slits 50.
50 also the
border is curved around say border
radius 30 pixels
to make it rounded
yes it's fine
also cursor as pointer we need
save and we will have let's add padding
so say padding 10 pixels for this text
or 15
the text is inside this
fine
so now what we have to do is what
change the font size of the of start a
post
so I gets the font size here is
aerial
so we can say
font size sorry font family Ariel
did this change or not
yes it changed
then we have
we have
okay it's not idealist system UI sorry I
think I checked something wrong
system UI
we don't need all the other fonts
save and I guess you will see this here
just as LinkedIn
other properties let's check
so we have the font size 14 pixels
weight 600 so
wait I mean font weight
which will be 600.
color is this RGB and blah blah blah
so we can replace the color with this
so where is the color we don't have a
color okay we do have a color here
so let's replace
and see we have start a post
okay some thing is wrong
here let's style this color
it's too much on the light side this
this is also too much light I mean not
too much but fine this yes this looks
now perfect
we're gonna increase the font size so
try that like font size
16 pixels let's try
let's try 14.
button is fine
so just like this we have this so
let me exit the
what font but
the color is not gray I just notice it
noticed it it's the gray color only when
we hover it
so
let me make one hover effect here on
this open model open post model so
however
and in the model we will have
background color as this so cut and
paste but here the color of background
will be let's say white smoke
save both files I'm in this file and we
will see this
just like this
we have this now all we have to do is
click this
button and it will open up a model
so for more dial let's go to this r d
documentation
yes let's
okay we have one designed five now
so let's search model here
what happened
murder yes
we need a sentence model so if you come
here
okay to Vertical Center model like this
so let's copy the JavaScript code for
model
so how to copy just click this copy code
button
but not one thing that you have to watch
the previous videos only then you will
understand what is happening next
you will find all the videos in this
playlist check this playlist
the model
index Dot jsx paste the code here
something is wrong
okay it's not a functional yes it's a
function but let's make it
model
and
fine let's it is fine fine fine fine
also let me clearance says or scss file
so say index
Dot scss
let me import it here
import
index.scss
now we can import this file
into this post
update component
so import
model
okay
let's try look from local I want to
import
so
model
and just render it here
OKAY model has already been declared
where
okay let's say model let's make this as
modal component
and just export it here
okay
fine then import it here
and save and no error will wear
now I will trigger the model
on click on the button so let me create
one function here
so it will be called uh
just let me
one second
let me copy the state here from the
model component
which is this I mean cut it not copy
this
okay
so
let me cut the state from here
paste it here import the state hook
fine
then let's say model open and set model
open not one so we don't need second
model
and we don't need this either we need
only one model
so whenever we are clicking the button
in this model
it's opening this model
so we have transferred this anglicument
to this button
so
here I will set it as true
like this then we can name the button
from here
now this model takes
this open prop and the open value is
modal to open but it's short model to
open its model open so save this here
also we don't need to
do that so just we have to pass we don't
need button or the state hook
so we need to pass model open
and set model open as props
so first let me receive here
receive it here
Steve
now let's pass them
but let's also
render the model component here
that we are not rendering
so we can render it out here
like this then pass set model open and
model open
plus model open
and set model open
huh
now let's see
if you click the button let's see what
happens so yes see this model is getting
opened if we click cancel or OK this
will be closed
fine so now let's design the model
so if you click this start a post you
will see this text called create a post
in the model
so let me remove all the contents P tags
and action H4 link and create a post
here
okay I think the title should be here
vertically centered model dialogue
so let me add it here
and
fine
now
what to do
the next step is to write I mean create
one input element
so we can say input
and the placeholder will be
what
do you want
to
talk about
now save
and we will see this input but we have
to design this so we can say class name
let's say model
input
now the class model input should be here
and now let's Design This
so first okay sorry this should be here
first we don't see any background I mean
we're sorry we don't see any border so
make border has none for this input
so if you do that we will have no water
also background color will be white
or white smoke
so okay it's not white smoke I think
it's pure white
yes
also it's breaking I mean we need some
width but first outline
also none
so that it becomes simple as that
color is black
to see the post what we're writing
font size
20 I mean it's not 2017 pixels let's try
yes but it's big try 14 I think it's
fine
point
family
the name is system UI
system
UI
contentment changed
we can type
find
if you remove this entire thing we will
see this placeholder Also let's add some
width say 100 percent
fine
we have this width as well
okay let's make the font size 16.
fine
you can write anything here like this
okay
we have also an emoji one image one
video and this document button also we
have this
privacy
select
so we will add them later but first let
me just post data to Firebase
also we have a post button here
so let's create it so save button
class name
post
I mean modal
button or BTN
or say post BTN
yes and it's called
post now save this
and it's here okay I think
we can remove the button
and
just rename this okay
to
I mean rename this OK button
to this post
so let's check the documentation here
customize button props
yes let me check this
okay
on okay button okay I don't think this
is what we need
customize footer yes this is what we
need
so let me copy the footer
which is an array
for your object and in object we have
array
but it's not here it's here
now we don't need this button or this
button we can just add one post button
here
and Save
Also let's import button from
a and t design
and save it loading is not defined
where it is loading let me remove it
fine and the look is not defined also
remove it because we don't need them
right now
so we have the post button here that is
doing the thing
but it's disabled
so we can make it disabled
it becomes this color and if you hover
the color I mean the button we won't see
anything
now if you type anything here this will
be enabled so let me create one input
element here
so let me create it in this page
not an input element but one state sorry
so we can say
let's say
status
comma set status
equals to use State let's make it a
string first just for just now pass the
string to this set I mean pass the set
status to this model
now we don't need this for now come to
model and get it as props
now on this input we will have on change
and we will store the data in set status
like an event
so we will have event
dot Target
dot value
save this
now if you type anything
okay not here here
the data is coming okay it's coming
fine
set status
okay fine
now now let me also pass the status here
as prompts
in the model component
let's also get it here
and here the value should be
this status
fine so we are going to disable
this button
when
our input is empty
I mean this input is empty if we fill it
with something only then this button
should be enabled
so
let me remove or not remove let's say if
status dot length
is more than 0
it means something is inside this input
so we will say
um
let's say false
because if the status.lin is more than 0
we want the disable to be false or if it
is less than 0 or 0 we want it to be
true
save
now let's try
if you type anything
the button will be enabled but if you
remove anything this will be disabled
so this is done
so basically we have a model and where
we can create our post
now come to this post update
and we have the status that contains our
text that we need to save
but we need one more thing one button
not a button a function so say
10 status to Firebase
so we will have this
function
let's pass it on the model as well
like this come to model and just
destructure it from props like this
now we have sent status
and on the button we have on we should
have on click event
and this should run this send status
save
and the UI is done for posting data
fine
now let's see the next step
that is to send data to Firebase fire
store
firestore
so to post data when we need a few apis
I mean from Firebase
so come over to this API file or folder
then make a folder called let's say
fire store
apis
yes it's a folder okay I think
let's make a file not a folder
sorry
so let me delete this
and create a file called firestore API
dot Js
but we need to initialize filed store
so come over to Firebase firestore
so to the strip I mean the step to do
that is Authentication
not all integration come to all products
and choose Cloud firestore here
to set it up we need to create the fire
store instance so we can say import
get fired store
let me first or I mean add
Firebase slash firestore
fine then it will be easy to import the
function
get fired store
now we need one more I mean constant so
say const
ore
equals to get fire store
that is this function and then we have
to pass this app inside
just like we have in Earth
now we have to export the fire store
variable
like this
so now we can close this
come to the main.jsx file
let's import
okay we don't have to import it here but
let's see okay let me create a database
here
let's start in test mode
and click next
okay let's choose enable I mean enable
this
fine
for now what's the problem
unknown error occurred let's also I mean
click again
let's see
let's try Europe
the location of the fire store
um it's not working
they create it again let's try
okay it's created fine
now come to rules
because this has some security tools for
example the person who is not logged in
or signed in
should not be able to write data or read
them but
we will just add it for now I mean we
will just make it public for now
let's click publish
okay see this is saying that your rules
are defined as public
but we will change it later don't worry
now
all we need to do is
create a function here so say export
const let's say post
status
an error function this will be
just like this file auth api.jsx we need
to import a few things and the auth from
Firebase firestorm but sorry not auth we
will have fire store
from Firebase config
now
so we are going to post data so we need
this function from Firebase firestore
so from let me add Firebase slash
firestore
so the first function is
I think it's
add doc
add doc means add document
also we need a collection keyword
collection means a function that will be
helpful to create a collection here
fine
so
we have collection and add doc I think
we also need
one more thing called auth do we need
Earth let me please check the
documentation I am forgetting what is
the thing that we need
add dot Firebase
okay so it's here add doc
you are here import get fired store
okay we are doing that collection in
endoc okay
const review that we are doing on this
uh config file
now we have to create a reference yes
so let's create it so select
dbrev
equals to collection keyword that we had
on the top it takes the DB I mean the DB
is called the database in our case it's
firestore
then let's add the collection name so
let's say
posts
save this now we have to use add doc
here
like this width
and in the add dock we'll pass the dbrf
if you scroll down we can see it here
like add doc dbref the database ref and
the data
so we don't have the data so let me get
it from the post data so
okay we don't need model for now we need
this also only auth API homecoming CSS
wait
the post status component
so it is common post update and here yes
we need this
let me import this function here which
is called post status
so
simply
const
okay
yes import it at the top here okay cons
post status
from this
API file
then just add it here
like this
we will pass the status as RMS
or arguments
then this data will be here or say
status
fine let me create an object here so
let's say let obj or let object
which will be related to send
so we will say status as status
we are making an object because later we
will add other items as well for example
we have image video emoji and all also
the privacy
so let's add the object here after the
daily ref
now
I think that's all but
we need to then block here so say then
and it will send us a response
from Firebase
and we can say console.log
this document has been added
successfully you can try this
custom I'm in this message
but
if it fails we can catch it
so why I'm using promise
but here in auth API I was using try
cache block
and I think of it
I mean not to think of it just try cash
block but both will work
so say error
and second soul
DOT log
error
now let's try this
let me give okay we have problem here
post status has been declared already
where
I guess here post status
okay
let me make the name of the post letters
as small small p
then
change the Imports
now it will work
refresh it
now open the
console
like this clear it click the button
let's say hello
world
now click post
and you will see document has been added
successfully
now check the fire store
and we will see this posts I mean this
posts is the database reference
it takes a fire store from the auth I
mean from the config file and the
collection name so collection name is
called posts
and the status is called hello world
fine
so this is how we add data in Firebase
firestore
let's also do a few things I mean when
we are sending data
let's make the function as async
a weight
then once the function post status is
done we will call set model open as
false I will make it false to close it
now save this
let's say Hello World 2 click post and
it's gone and immediately you will see
we have status 2 as hello world 2 in the
fire store
fine
but we also have to clear it
so we can say
uh of it
thread status is empty
now make it as hello world 3 click post
and this will be here
and if you click the button again
you will not see the text that I posted
that we typed before it's empty
fine
now one more thing to do let me
have a toast here
let me post I mean let me import
toast from reactive I
instead of the
this log console log we can add toast
dot success
and let me try once more which will be
let's say
hello
four
type in type anything
click post
and we will see document has been added
successfully
and it will be here
so that is how this is how we post
status audit I mean we add data or
document
to the firestore
now let's see how to get all the posts
from firestore
to come to the fire store api.jsx
create a function called
get posts
all the posts
basically it's an API yes
so we will need a function from
Firestone called get
what do not get on Snapshot
fine so we can call the function in this
function it takes the difference which
is called dbref
comma then it provides the Callback so
say data
or set spawns not data
fine
then we have to filter our response from
here so we can say
console
DOT log
response
dot data
we are not data let's say Docs
dot map
the sponsor docs dot okay let me just
show you how to do that
but first we have to get the function
here
so export it sorry import it
then we need one more hook called use
memo hook
from react
then let me create the or add the hook
here use memo
then what we will do is in this use memo
let's call this something called get
posts
fine now if you open the console let's
say what we get
what we have in the console
so we have this thing called Excel
so it's the data from the fired slot
that we cannot trade right now we have
to filter our data so we will choose the
docs here
if you see we haven't we have a docs
object which contains our array
so we can just response dot Docs
and if you save we will see this array
so we have to get the data from this
error using map method
we have to fill I mean yes we have to
get the data using map
we will create one more array from this
array which will only contain our data
that we need the posts
in an object so let's say
let's say Doc or Docs
and let's return
dogs
Dot data as a function
now I will get this array where we have
all the statuses like Hello World to
hello world hello world food and all
like this
also it provides us an ID I mean each of
these statuses have an ID let me go to
console in firestore
so you see this ID called atfq and all
it's an ID that we can also get so we
can just make Docs
dot ID
if you save we will have
this array with the ID as well inside it
for each of the posts I mean status
one second let's make this as note posts
get status
okay now here also we have to change get
status
fine but the thing is we don't need the
data here we need it in this component
so let me create a state here called
uh all status
and set all letters
used it
and Eric
so let's pass this get status in this
function
get status
I mean we have to pass
this function set all status inside get
status yes that's what I'm saying
now let's get it here
so we can set it here directly if you
save and refresh the page
okay let's cancel that log this all
statuses
here
and see the output
so we will get this array of four
objects
if you refresh
it's empty but then we get it after some
time
so it takes a few minutes 40 minutes
minutes of your milliseconds to load
so if you check networks tab
go to fetch xhr refresh the page
and it takes some moment to fetch the
data
fine so we have our order that we can
add later not now
so we have this what is it the state
called
state is all statuses
now let me remove this console log
so that we can map the
array here so we can see all set says
dot map
let's say status
I don't know why I named this as status
it should be
posts
wait a second post status you get status
fine it's fine
now we have to return
a div or a fragment but I prefer
fragment
but you can also use it but the problem
is both refer in some cases like each
have their use cases
the react fragment or div
so in this fragment let me return one h
let's say not H3 A P tag simply and send
status Dot
what is the key name
status
so it's odd so let's make it as posts so
that
we can have posts dot status
save the file
but the problem is we're getting it here
and that is the problem that I warned
you about
so we have to wrap this in one more div
so that it becomes the child of this
four states Main
but I don't think it will work fine but
it works
so
fine let me get the class here post
status Main
they should be in index.js CSS
and we have to make Flex direction as
column
now it's fine we can say it
now let me show you this if I add one
more post let's say hello
World pipe and click post
it will be immediately here immediately
and here also
that is the use of this on Snapshot
let me close this
now let me grab one component here for
the card that is on LinkedIn for example
this card
so
we need one component here called let's
say posts
God
in this let's have an index file
and one fcss so index.scss
so make it a function component
but let's change the name to
posts
card here as well
for now
we will have this
uh
text here now let me import the SAS SSS
component
which is post on one step back index dot
scss now save
now we can close the firestore API or
model CSS let's get the component of the
postcard I mean posts card here
so import
posts card
from Posts card
and let me just
returned this component
like this
so we'll see five posts card text here
because this component
is running five times
we have to pass this posts as
um prop
yes
now let's receive the prop here
I'm going to structure it then in here
we can write our
these things like posts so in this step
Let's Make A P tag which will be called
as
posts dot status
now you will see the same thing if I
refresh and it's it works
now what to do we have the card but it's
very basic
I mean it's not a card yet but it's very
basic so give this div a class name of
posts card
now let's copy the class come over to
index.css
and add it here
now in this class let's create a card
here like this
so we can use same styling as this card
so let's get it from this what is it try
home component no I think it's in post
status
where it is
component common post update
yes from here
so
we have this
post status card
no this is the card
wait a second
which card do we have
this card post status
yes let's search it here
and let me get all of these item from
here
and simply paste it here
in the postcard.scss
now we will get these cards but they are
very very small
so we have to make them large
fine so we can make the mid width to 100
percent
still it's very short
okay let's remove wait a second
come over here
okay let's close this
this as well
so I'm fine so let's make this as
300 pixels
or
or 600 or 550.
yes they are not perfect
let's do the same thing in that
component as well let's don't let's not
do its use percentage
so if we are on a bigger screen
this will be response
fine so what about the model
yes model is fine
so we have this all the cards data here
let me lose this one
now we have this text but the placement
of the text
is different
so it starts from the left
so give this Diva I mean pay a class
name of
status
and let's say status
or the status or yes
so in here say status
extra line
left
it's not on the left
so I guess why
we can remove I think
this item just have a Content Center
now it's on us and it's on the left
so it's having some padding so let's add
the padding here
20 pixels
now it's it has some padding
but the width of this card has increased
so basically we can add padding here as
well now the inner element is now
shifted to Insider
now also
we have the font size smaller and the
font is different so let's also check
that the font is system UI
so let's make it here font
uh font font font family
y
is it changed
yes I guess so and now what is it the
size is 14px
the font size for 10 pixels
now it's small
also font family font weight 400 so font
weight
400 pixels not pixels fortnite
also the color is this so let's see in
the color here
so make the color
as this
now we have this
but something still feels wrong here
Earth system UI
but I don't know what's the problem here
let's search
the correct font
okay gets I guess it is working
whatever you copy this font
paste it here
oh okay
fine I think it's fine it's fine it's
fine
okay
now I have this card
fine
now
we can even move it to the top
or leave it here
fine but we also need a few things here
for example the username
we have this timestamp six hours ago and
on so now let's create the timestamp
here
in the post update.jsx
and for the timestamp let's have a
let's have a
Library called moment.js
so let me install it in the direct app
so let me copy this command
and install it
using the terminal
save
now all we have to do is import
moment.js
let me create one helper function for
this
so
let's create it here in the or not in
any file
say in this helper CS so say use moment
dot jsx basically it's a hook
so export
const
dates
or let's say
change or get date or get current date
or say time
it's a function but we need moment
package here so we can import
moment from moment
then it will take a date that
okay not the date
okay
let's say moment
I mean let's choose one time stamp here
which is
let's try
um see
let's try this one
to add it here
so it will
take the current time and it will format
it using this Triple L and this will be
the output for this so we have to return
it
but we can get this Triple L from the
param circle so say
format
or
time format
then we have to just pass it here
and now let me call this function get
time stamp
in our post
update.jsx so import
what is the name
get current
timestamp from this route
and
then what we have to do is
let's say okay
post status we have here
one second
okay now let me pass or wait a second I
think the update is not happening here
so
tell status is here
a wait post status
what is wait a second
set panel option I forgot the code how
it was working
let me open the model and check
no it's not happening here either
so where it is happening
so I guess it's happening in the home
component
no here also no
so where are we calling that function
today is my bad day I guess
so I think this is the function that we
are having
and here we are passing the status
okay
fine is this all
if we click Start a post
this model will open and we have the
send status that we are passing this fun
and this component called modal
component
I think that's it post status yes
so let me create one object so say obj
or object equals to an object
here we will have status as status
comma
then we have
uh what is it then say timestamp
equals to
okay let me import it here as well only
we read it here
so get current timestamp and let's pass
Triple L
in capital
so we can try to control this as well
so concern.log this
now open the console
and let's see what we are getting
we are getting nothing
so we are returning this data
Let me refresh the page once
I guess it's still compiling
so
let's open the
terminal terminal
yes it's compiling and it will say it
will take some time because this weight
also
modifies or optimizes dependencies
yes see we're reading the data which is
the current date and the time
for now
we are passing this here as Triple L
format
then let's pass this object in the post
status here
to open post status in the
API
in flyers for dpa.jsx let me remove the
object and say object here that we are
getting and simply pass it here this
will work as well
we can remove the console log for this
now let's try
Let me refresh
let me delete the entire posts
I'm in the collection
but wait let's also add one more thing
one last thing here which will be the
current email
of the user so the user is logged in
and let's store his credentials
in
let's store his credentials in local
storage
okay so we can do that from login API
so it takes I mean it Returns the
response and made the login API that we
are calling let's check
here
so it sends us a response
so we can simply console.log this
response like this
but we need to be logged out for this
because we can't see this login response
here for now
so how to log out let me delete all the
users from here and start again
from Chris from scratch
so
delete this
Let me refresh the page and see what
happens
okay nothing happens let me delete the
other two
we haven't made the logout button yet
yes we have on this login page now let
me create one account here
using our email or phone so sign
I mean join now
let me create
one minute so if I if you are creating
the account
they should be in the registered
component as well
to set it in the
local storage I mean we have to make the
console log
so we can set spawns
dot email
or I guess let's check
so
let's say nishanth s440 at the rate
Gmail
.com some password let's type
and again join
so account created
okay but okay we hadn't saved it yet
fine
that was the problem so okay we can do
one thing
we can remove
the
we can remove this thing
the Earth
I mean not the auth where it is it
yes we can remove
where is it where is it in the home
component
origin sorry not the component in the
home page
so we can simply comment out this for
now
and from here
from this page called login.jsx also
comment it out
let's make the use I mean the loading to
false
and in this home as well so that we can
see our range
so let me go to the login page now
okay not the login page yes login page
will work quite as well so let me add
the email that we use now
gmail.com
the password
click sign in
we will see all is retired so we can use
in the login page
where is our login component
okay let me see login login component
there are too much files here
yes so res
dot user
and then in the user we have this email
so let's store this thing in the local
storage
so we can say
local storage.set item
it will be user email
the same thing we can do here in the
registered component
so we can do it here not the console log
fine
now let me divide back the changes we
did in this two components here
okay so come over to this home.jsx and
revert everything back to the state it
was before
login as well
now save
let me expand it a little bit less
fine
now
let's try from the beginning let me
delete all the users here
I mean only one user we have we can
delete that
fine
we don't need login page or the home
page
okay
so let me use I mean let me create one
user here
again
so join now
email our phone let me open this thing
which is the applications tab
in the applications tab we have local
storage and it's empty for this so we
can say Nishan there's 440
at the rate
gmail.com
and the password
click again join
and now we have this email here user
email
for the current user
so I prefer I mean we have to use the
local storage non-positional storage
because session will be destroyed after
some time or even or when we close the
tab or when we close the browser
now here we can just get the
email from the user so let
user email
equals to local storage
dot get item
the user email key that we typed here so
we don't need this either
okay save this and save the user email
as user email
now
we have no data here
so open the fire database
no data is here
fine let's try to save one
so we can say hello
World click post
and it's here
then if you check here let me refresh
we will see
all these three items called status
timestamp and the email
I hope so
yes it's here
fine
now what we have to do is
let me just render it out here simply in
the
postcard
so
after I mean before this let's add one P
tag and say
posts Dot what is the key name times
temp
timestamp yes
timestamp
so we will have timestamp here then we
have the email as well
so
okay let's not show the email for now
because the use of email is very
different here
not to show it here
so give this timestamp a class of time
stamp
let me come to
the CSS for this or scss and add the
class here which will be
timestamp is this so let me hover this
font
six hours
the same is here system UI
porn family
font size 12 pixels
okay colored is
this
so color
is this Pond weight 400
what else do we have
nothing
so I save this and the timestamp will be
here but they're not arranged Also let's
add padding 20 pixels for this
so they are not arranged properly as it
should be
I mean as they should be so we can say
justify for you not justify Flex
reduction column
now there will be a column
so I guess the problem is the height
here
or is the it is it the height
let's try justify content Center
yes now they are fine
but still the Gap is too much between
them
so I guess what's the problem let's
remove the height and try
okay it's it is not like this
okay okay okay what can we do
display Flex all the things let me
comment this for now
so it comes at the start
fine
but we have to bring it down
okay I guess we don't need align items
then it will work
yes but still
let me move
or just remove this also and see what
happens okay it's not fine
okay what if we remove this and remove
the padding here as well
okay
if you are having removing the padding
let's add margin 10 pixels
where margin is fine
add it here as well tied 20
okay
so we can do this so margin
10 okay just make it as zero zero zero
zero
fine
if you had 10 here or 10 pixels
this will be moved from Top
I mean its top margin
then this is called
bottom margin I'm in top bottom I guess
this is called left
okay not left
this is left
10 pixels yes the timestamp is here and
the status
fine the same thing we can apply here
not just margin 10 pixels
and it will work the fine I mean it work
it will work
fine
so the timestamp is here and the hello
world text
all we need to do is now is to add the
username
and the image that will be for the next
I mean very next part
because we will need fire explode
Firebase storage for this
fine
now in the next in the next video
let's do
the profile page for the current user
so we'll have to fill the data in the
profile
so that we will do in the next video
let me also start add one more post call
hello world 2.
click post and it will be here
immediately and the timestamp also
if you check both status is here now
like this
so this is not the final version of this
home posts card we will add all of these
things
fine let me copy this post and just add
it here and see what happens
click post
okay the problem is
we have to add the height as Auto
okay not the auto I mean let's add Min
height as 120 pixels
or maybe
let's say
okay if the post is small then we see I
mean if the post is large we see the C
more button
so I guess
we can make this as Auto and see what
happens
or 120 pixels
let's make it as
let's leave it a lotto and add one
padding bottom
to 20 pixels
now we have this and it looks much
better than before
so this is how we created
the
posts card that contain or that will
contain our posts
fine then okay
now let's see a few things that we can
do before the profile page creation
and first of all the first thing is we
need to create a pop-up here
if you click this profile icon we should
see a pop-up and it contains the logout
button or item
if we click this button of logout
we need to run the logout function and
log out of the system
so let's create the API for that
in this API OS API let me have function
called
export
cons on
logout
and in this function
we will call a method call okay just let
me have dry catch block first
and remove all of these items
so the method name is sign out from fire
space
sign out
now we need to use the function here and
just pass the auth and that's all
now we have to call the function here so
let's call it
so import
what is it on
log out
from this route
and just wrap this function in this
button I mean add it here like this
now if you click logout button we should
be on the home page I mean not the home
page on the login page see we are on
this page
file so it works
now the next change we have to do is in
this page called join now I'm in the
registered page
so come over to components register
component
and here let's make the login as
register
and add the function here as well on the
button of the on button only I mean
now what we need to do is we need to add
one more field here for the name of the
user so let's add it here
and that will be
your name there so the type will be of
text
and the name I mean the key will be of
name
and we will have this here
so let's also store the name in the fire
store
okay what I am saying okay not that
I mean what we need to do is we need to
store all the items I mean the email and
the name in the fire store
to get the current user after filtering
so I will show you I mean I will tell
you what I mean with firestore DPI let's
have
this okay
what is this what is this
let me remove this I think I was trying
okay
what happened
something is wrong
if you save wait a second wait a second
wait a second
let me go to the top and remove this yes
now it will work fine
now
fine
so now we need to store the data in the
fire store for that when one reference
call user f
and the collection name is called or
cooperatively called as users so this
will contain all our users when we sign
up
so what I mean by that
so let me
add a function here called export
post user
data
like this
in this let's create one
okay we already have the function here
fine
so it takes an object
and
loads the data in the Pirate Store
collection
so
we are passing the user F here
and the object is already here so we
have to call this function directly post
user data
so we don't need this we need to call it
here
so
we'll just let me call it like this
import
post user data
and we need to run the function here in
this drive Block in the register
function
post user data
and you will pass credentials
dot email one second what is that we are
passing
okay let's pass
the credentials
here
or
let's second I guess
okay we can make it as an object as well
so we can just say name will be of
credential dot name
comma
email will be off
credentials dot email
now save this and whenever this function
gets called
the datability passed here and stored
inside firestore
now let's try this
so we need to delete our
uh
user from here then try again
now let me also delete the
database collection which is called
posts so just delete collection
here
now let's try let me enter my name
called Nishant
Kumar
let me add my email correlation that's
440 at the rate
gmail.com and the password
once again
click again join
and we are signed in
fine and now if you refresh the filed
store
you will see this thing
I mean this current user here
so
let's see the user is here with email
and name
fine
as you already know we are storing our
email in the local storage as well so we
need to create a more function
to get this data and filter it to get
the current name of the user and the
email
so we can export const get current
user
and
just say
what can we say
so we need to use this on Snapshot which
is here
fine let me add it here but instead of
this posts ref we need to pass user's
ref or use the ref
let me just console this for now here
and Save
now
if you check let me call the function
here let me call the function in the
home component
or in the home page so in the home page
we have this as here
okay let's call this in this page or
better in the layout
home.jsx
so that we can pass it in home in the
top bar to have the name as well for the
current user so we can say import
uh get
current user
let me create one memo hook here use
memo
use memo
and just add use memo
and just call this get current user here
now let's say the console what we are
getting
so we are getting
this error of object which is contained
which contains email name and ID
fine so I guess we don't need it so we
can remove it
we just need these two items
fine
or let's leave the ID and make this as
user ID
so that we can have user ID here
what is current user
fine now we need to filter the current
user
that we are on currently for example let
me log out and login with my other
account I may log sign out and not sign
out
okay I am tired so I mean
let me register with my other account so
send me Shan only and this
Nishant
s550123 at the rate
gmail.com password
click again join
so we have one more
database I mean user here which is this
now if you check the console here we
will get two users
see
in this area of objects
this we're having two users let me give
it a refresh and try again
let me have some water first I am
feeling tired
we are having two wizards
but we're going to get the current user
that we are on currently which is this
email Nishan that's 550123 at gmail.com
so to do that
we can use our local storage to get the
current user from here the current email
so let's say let
curve email
equals local storage dot get item
and the key name which is user email I
think
now we have this correct email
then we can filter this here so just see
Dot
filter
let's say item
and
we can return
item dot key name what is
we have here we have a email as email so
email
equals to current email
now we will get the only one email
that we are on currently which is this
so to access
the first element I mean the only limit
that we have make it as zero index or
zeroth index
and we will have this like this
now in the home layout let me create a
state here so const let's say current
user
that current user
equals to use state
empty object
now path this Set current user here
get it here
and simply store it here
like this
now we have to pass this current user to
the home page or home PS home page
now come to the home page where is it
here in the pages folder
then let's get it here
now pass it further to this home
component
and we will keep passing it
so let me get to this component home
component
get it as props then pass it even
further
like this
fine now come to the post status
component
this is post update yes this one let me
just
add it here post
do we have current user here
fine
now when we are setting the data or
sending the data to firestore we need to
also add the user
name
which will be current user dot name
Also let's add the post ID I mean post
ID
that is the idea of the current post
that we are posting
so we can add some random ID
so we can use the package called uid in
react I think let's try this
so let me install the package
View
terminal add one more and install it now
we have to import this at the top or let
me create a function helper function for
this as well
so let's say
get
unique
ID Dot jsx
we need to create a function here which
is called git ID or even better we can
change it to get unique ID
and we will export the function in the
function we will have ID
and we will return the ID so ideal
contain the current ID from uid
from this library then we can simply
import the function here
in this component
and
consolid to check the current ID we're
getting here
now we need to get the ID from here to
this post ID for the current post so let
me remove comment
and create unique ID
now all of this data will be sent to
fired store
here
so let me open okay we don't have the
collection for this for posts but let me
try let me create a
post call
this is Nishant
now click post and this will be here
with a timestamp
and if you refresh this page this
filesport console you will get the
current post that we did now
so it will be in posts
and we will have this
fine so why I did that is because this
contains our email
fine and if we create a profile page we
should be able to filter the
posts based on the current user that
signed what I mean that signed that
signed in yes now we can do one more
thing
so where are we reading the data so let
me check the component
close all the components that we don't
need
fine
so where does it
it is here
so where is it I think in the login
component
in the posts card I guess no not here
post update component let's check here
yes we have all the okay it's in the
postcards itself
okay
here fine so also let me add the name so
if you see
we have this name here called Abhishek
patil I mean for example
so before this time stamp
let's add the name called p
and this will be called
posts dot name
now save this and let's see the name
so add it here
and we should be see we should see the
name here called nishanth
fine let's style it a little bit so
class name will be name
we don't need this component or this
component just come over to the styling
file
SSS file
and let me add a name class name here
so
the things here are same I mean there
are they're all equal
but the name is a little bit Bolder so
we can just copy all our items here
and add it let's make the font size for
10 pixels
and
make the font with a 600. now it's
bolder
but it's sticking to this time stamp
like this
point so we can add it
so where is it the time let me add or
let me have margin or remove margin top
as 10. now we have this Nishant as name
and the timestamp fine
now let me log out and create one more
account for the other email from the
email called let's say Nishant
Kumar will be the name here email
test this
and some password
click again join
you cannot create your account but why
let me open the Netflix tab
and check
again join
okay I think email already exists
do we have the email here
yes okay I guess I have to login only
not sign in
so let me sign in with this email okay
what is the name of the current okay
it's Nishant Kumar fine
in let's do this
now let's
add one more account I mean one more
post from here called
hello this is Nishan
Kumar
now click post
the name is still the Nishant not Kumar
okay what is the problem here
so the problem was this let me show you
what I mean
so basically we were just adding a
variable here and we were storing the
local storage email in the variable then
maybe adding the variable here but now
we're doing it directly
fine and in the post update we need to
store the current user dot email here
not the other way around
so that was the fix now if you log in
let me log in with this email called
nishanth s440 at the red Gmail
.com so the username of this email is
Nishant Kumar
so let me add one update from here
called
hello
okay
which will be hello
this
is this is Nishant
Kumar if you click a post
you will see Nishan Kumar and hello this
is Nishant Kumar and now if you log in
with the other account
which is Nishant
s550123 at the red gmail.com one two
three four five six seven
now we will add
here hello
this is Nishant
and only Nishan not Kumar click post
and we will see hello this is Nishant
and the username is called nishanth so
that's how we fixed it using these items
now let's work on the profile page
first we have this layout which is
called profile layout the same way we
have the home layout
in the layout I mean profile layout we
are having the profile page
in the profile page we are having the
profile component this component in the
profile component we are having the
profile card which is simple just a card
here and The Styling is this note it
down and you can make this on your own
and also we are passing the current user
from the profile layout to the profile
card as you see here
like this we are passing it so that we
can see our current profile name here so
I have been logged in with nishanth the
username let me log out okay we cannot
log out from here because I mean we can
log out
but the problem is we have to set the
same thing that we have open the home
page
we are having all of these checkings
so the same way we can do in the profile
page
so let me do this
in the profile page we have to do all of
these so
we can just copy
these items paste it here
and import the react use the state Hook
and the use effect
and edit here then we need a state for
loading so let me also add it here
like this
then we need the navigate so let me edit
here as well
okay then the use effect hook to check
for the authentication every time the
page mounts
then we are having this so let me just
copy return loading
if the loading is true which we'll see
the loader else we will see
the profile component like this now
let's see like the thing is
we have logged out so now if you try to
go back to the profile page let's see
what happens
maybe it's going back to the home page
instantly
we cannot go back using this button as
well so now let me log in with the other
account called Nishan s440 at the rate
gmail.com one two three four five six
seven click sign in okay sign in and we
are on this page
now we have to go to profile page so at
the route here and we will see the name
for the user called Shan Kumar just like
we see it here now let's style all of
the items in the profile card a little
bit here
so this is a let's say an S4 tag or H3
tag so make an H3
I mean wrap the current wizard.fame in
H3 tag and we're reading the current
user from this file so if you open API
by x2dp.com
sorry.jsx we have this function called
get current user and from here we are
getting the data
so if you save and then it will see a
Min we will have this here the current
username so give the class name of
user name now let me come over to the
SSS file and give them
styling so the font will be I mean font
family will be
what was the name
system UI
so system
UI now save and the font will be changed
okay let me check the font here what
font is this exactly
and all the other items
so the font color is this
so we can add it here like
color
like this weight 600 600 so font weight
font size 24 pixels
okay
save this and let's see we will get the
Nissan command text here just like we
have it here
fine but
it has a margin from the edges so we can
just say
sorry padding add it here so say 30
pixels
or 30 is too much try 20. 28 side is
fine
Kumar
here
now the next thing here we have is this
title So currently the title is not
inside the profile page so we need to
add the title and all the items
all the other items in this page
in the profile page in the firestore
database so let me open this quickly
okay so it is opening so let's wait for
it for some time so we have this users
which contains two users
this and this So currently we have this
user and here we have to update the data
like about and the location and the
about section
and all fine so we can also add the
email so let me add P tag
and we can say current user dot email
save this and we will have the email
here
give this a class name of
user email
now save this
let me make as capital
and here and its capital
now come over to here change the name
here
as well and
this is the user email so margin top
will be minus 10 pixels
or we can just make it 15 let's try
or 25
okay let's make it 20 initially yes it
looks fine let me use all of the items
from here in here
okay font
will be select 16 pixels
and we don't need the bolt
but remove 600 and that looks fine
I mean this is fine for us now let's add
the other form Fields so
first let me create one edit option here
so let me make a div first
and make a button called I mean in this
button in this div let's add a button
and this button will be called let's
edit
now save this and you'll have the button
here
gave this div a class name of edit BTN
now let me copy the class and come over
here
let's give this position of
position of absolute
now right will be
20 pixels
okay if it is happening so we have to
make the card as relative
so it sticks is it sticks here yes it's
fine
so we have this
okay
now
let's also okay just leave the button
like this here for now we will change
the styling later
so let me make all of the items
let's say background color as
White
okay it's not working why
okay it's because
we are having the class
of this edit button on the div not on
the button
so let's select the button here so we
can say button
and remove all of these items and it
will be here fine but let's leave it for
now we'll style it later because let's
run the priority
just we need to do I mean the one thing
we can do is add a cursor
as pointer and if you hover this the
cursor will be changed to pointer
no we need a form so we can create a
component here called
profile edit
let me add
index.jsx
and
index Dot scss
in the jsx make it a functional
component
like this make this as
profile
edit
here so let me import the
styling file here
which is index.scss
save and now it's fine
okay now what to do is
when we click once again
yes when we click the button we need to
show this component so open the profile
card
and let me import the component here so
import profile edit from this
and let me get a state here
so use state
like this
now let me add a state called
is edit
and set is edit equals to used it let's
make it false because initially we will
see this page not the edit page now
let's have a function or not a function
let's just map it here on the buttons on
click
and just revert the state like
this
fine
now
what we can do is
okay let me wrap this in a fragment
and save this nothing will change
now just store like make the component
here as
I mean make this as what is it
what can we say
we can make it a conditional component
but wait a second
in the profile
component
I think we should do it here
not in this page
so
let me
remove the state from here and add it
here I mean add real estate hook here
remove the state from here
and this as well
and just add it here
save them
now let's add a function so say const
uh
on edit
like this
okay
in this function I will set it like this
that edit will be equal to
I mean we will revert the state
now pass the function on edit in this
component
save and let me come to this component
and we are passing the current user and
on edit okay just add it here
and just add the function to this button
we can now import the component of
profile edit in the profile component
directly
so we can say import
profile edit from here
and then add one conditional rendering
for the component
so here we will have a profile edit is
true we will show
the component for
profile edit
save okay also need to add colon right
now click edit we will see
the index which is from profile edit
component so just make it as
profile edit to see the text but here
also let's add a button like this
to go back so just copy this and add it
here in the profile edit
okay just replace it
let me have the function as props which
is on edit
then we have to pass this here as well
the on a date function
now edit and if you click this we will
be on that
card page let's make this as
go back
fine save and Let me refresh
edit this we will be on this page now
let me also add the card here which is
called
profile card
so we can reuse the class name
yes see it's working
fine
now in this let's add
one input element or a few input
elements
so we can say input
okay just add
placeholder as name because what if you
want to change the name
okay
now other apps will be
let's say what else we have about so
about will be f the text
area type
okay now let's say
we have name
let's say
headline
that we see here like this
now save this and we will have the name
and headline okay let's put them outside
this div
because this device is not for this go
back button we have name and headline
now what else we have here the location
so let's add this as well
don't worry we'll style them later so
add
location
okay then I think that's all you can add
other things as well let's add two more
called
uh company
and College
and save this
now come here and we will have five
inputs let me dab them in a div that we
can arrange them
properly
now in this div give it a class name of
uh
profile
edit
inputs
now come over to
the file here in this scss
and we can just say
display Flex
okay it's breaking while it is breaking
profile card
we have
okay
let's do what
profile let me close this we don't need
it for now
okay
let's make it as grid
okay it's fine
also
we need to give a top margin at let's
say 40 pixels yes
let me add some gap between them to 20
pixels
like this we have name headline location
company in college
now let's style the inputs
so in each of the inputs let's give it a
class name of
edit
input
so just copy the class and paste it all
over
here here and here
save them
now copy the edit input Class come here
and we can just say
a width
say
of 300 pixels
and think that's fine height
the 40 pixels also fine
let's change the color but I guess we
already have an input so let's get it
from there all the styles
so where is it
let's say in the registered page I guess
I mean component on the login component
so class name is the common input
the beginning was this so just copy
common input and replace
edit input here
like this
now let's check in I mean save and see
what happens okay currently the input is
limited to
I mean this
common input is limited to this local
file called login component
so we can move that into
this component called
main.scss so that we can access it from
every year I'm in this component
or do we have other page for says
okay
let's try SAS login okay let's move it
in the index.css
and
what is the problem
undefined variable linked in blue one
okay so let's check the login components
as
and at the top we will have all of these
three items so we can just add them here
as also
for now now we have name headline
location company in college looking
better
we can type inside it
okay
let's save
okay we don't need to save this fine
now what to do is
add the states here
so let me get a function
to say
uh
const get
input
and in here
event
and let's add the event on all of them
so on change
this I mean just simply add this on all
of the events I mean inputs
like this
now let's also add the name for example
this is the name that we have
then here we have
a headline
then we have
location
the company
then we have the college
like this
now when we type in the inputs this
function will run
and we have to set them in a state so
let's say const
input
I mean edit inputs
and set edit inputs
and should be small
so you state
which will be an it will be an object
like this
okay
now in this method let's create a
variable called uh
input simple input
and in here we will store
them like this for example
we will let me just redistructure the
name and value properties
so let
name comma
value
from event
dot Target
fine now another input we will have
a curly bracket let's add the key name
which is name
and we will add the value like this
now if you console.log this input after
typing
I mean we will type the text here in the
input and we will see our output in the
console
let's try this
let's add my name called Nisha
fine it's been saved and let's add
headline called
hello but if we type in here in the
second input it will be overridden and
when it will overwrite the first input
that is why we have the state
so we can set the state like this
and also add the previous value which is
edit inputs
so we can append that
zinc Ripple dots and it will be fine
now let me just console this here
see what we get so let me refresh
go to the edit page let me add my name
called nishanth okay it's
happening like this
okay I guess we don't have to use triple
dots here
and then try
Let me refresh once more oh yeah we're
fine
we have to use triple dots on both of
them because they both are objects
now it will work fine
click edit
Nishant
in the second let's add hello and it's
getting appended now all we have to do
is send this data to the fire store like
here so then if we have the name as
something
this will be overwritten by the current
name that we have
fine
now to do that let me create a method
here in this API page or the
I mean API file so we can say export
const edit profile
like this and just as we have we have
don't we don't have it here so let me
add
two properties from firestore which will
be Dock and update dock
fine
so
this edit profile
okay we need a button also
so let me add it here
button
so if let's say in the button let's say
tape
we will have the button here
so let me get the styling for the button
as well from the
register component or login component
so we have it here this button
which button this button
so just copy this
come to profile edit and and the class
name and just rename this to save button
now in this file
for this
CSS SSS let's add
the save button
and just add the class from login to CSS
where is the login button this just copy
this entire thing and paste here
wait where it is it
in this
is it here
is sit here yes here it is
fine save this
LinkedIn blue 2 is not defined
so also can we get it from here
all the three colors
save and
save this as well we know this
okay what's the problem save button is
not working so
the file edit
we have this
what is the main dip called it is
profile card
okay we are doing it wrong we can just
place it outside
and now we have the same button here
so if we have a save button let me make
the card a little bit bigger
so
make the width to auto
and we will have this
now the save button should be in the
center
so
we can make it textile and Center let's
try this
we don't need this for now
okay we don't need the profile card for
now
we will need
these three things
fine
now let's try to make them in the center
but I guess we have to add a div
here
and add it here as well now this day we
will have a class name of
uh
tinted
I mean save button container
or save container
now let me add the class
here
do
display of flex
justify content Center and it will be in
the center
perfect
now the function we're creating here
edit profile should be on this button
so but first
we need to create a function here as
well so say
save
uh profile data
or make it as an update profile data
because we need to update it
Now update profile data
will be handled on this button
so on click
this save this
um
now
let's have the ID of the user that we
are currently on
so
we will read it so to get the ID come to
the
profile component
so we are having the current user here
and let me pass it here as well to get
the ID in the profile edit page
so just add current user
current user ID
okay now let's try this
so save it and open the console
now the button when clicked will show us
the ID for this current okay it's
undefined
so just say current user and see what
happens
okay we only have the
okay we have this okay we have user ID
not the ID
so each user here have an ID that I sent
previously
that we cannot see here I mean yes it's
here so it will work like that
okay where we are getting these two here
okay let me move
and Save
file now click it again and it will see
the ID here for this
now we have to send the ID in the
profile component
sorry here so we can say
user ID
Capital ID in camel case
so first step to the do that is to
specify which user we have to edit so we
can say user
to edit
which will be having a dock
and in the dock we will pass the
reference
which is the user ref
with the ID
and the ID is called this user ID
now then we will call the
update.function
then we will pass
the user to edit
with the data that we need I mean the
data we are editing
so let's just get
the data or maybe
payload
and pass it here
okay then we can add all of these items
like then and catch block
and save it here and if then it's true I
mean if we have then then we can throw a
post called updated
okay
let me add let me change this I just
noticed this document has been added
successfully let's say post
here
now just add the same toast here and say
uh
profile has been updated
successfully
now all we need to do is call the
function edit profile here
and pass the current user ID in the data
so let's make the data first so let's
say let data
and in here let's pass
one second we can just pass edit inputs
so we don't need this object
so we can just pass this edit inputs
so one second
first is the ID then the payload so we
are doing it in reverse
first will be the ID wait
yes not reverse it's fine
now let me call the function here called
edit profile
we can import edit
profile from API folder and just run
this
okay now let me refresh the or clear the
console and
go back
click edit let me add the name called
okay the name is Nishant Kumar so let's
just add the name called nishanth let's
write headline called
hello this is Nishant
location let's say Patna
this let's say this college let's say
vit
let me open the network tab to check the
request
click save
and document admin profile has been
successfully updated
and if you check all of the items has
been changed like the name has been
changed to Nishan location College
company email and address headline now
we can edit
I mean we can add all of the items in
the profile page
so
this was second email that we had this
has not been edited so that's a good
thing I think
fine
okay now one more thing more to do is
let's just send us back when
we edit the profile so we can just call
on edit
now if we can try again
let's say this time this should be
Nishant Kumar again
now click save and we will obey on the
home page sorry not the home page the
profile page
but what if we do this as a weight and
this is a bit as well then make it as a
sink
now let's try again click edit
let me add the name called the same okay
if the name doesn't change
it will not change or if you're not fill
if we don't fill the field
this will not change as well so name is
the same the headline is Nishant
Umar
and just click up save here
okay now it's the same thing okay
the name is empty now okay
let me try once more
click save
okay the problem is what
the name is edited
okay the name is empty
let's add Nishant Kumar and then click
save
foreign
but if we click save again
okay nothing will be edited fine
okay so that's working now come over to
okay we don't need this
come over to this second component
called profile card and let's add the
other properties as well like the
headline company and all
so
let's set the headline here after email
so we can just copy this and say
headline
not heading
now in this CSS or scss
we can add it here
so where is the headline
you're not Reliant let's say user email
just copy this and add it here
so we will have the same thing but we
don't need the same thing
we need something different so add
heading
and come over here
and let's check the styling for this
so we can just
say here
uh
owned family is tell me why
font size is 16px
here
let me seven check
the same thing we are having
okay let's make it as
20 pixels
to make it bigger
but the key name will be username Dot
headline
save and this will be here
okay
let me give this margin top of -20 as
well
or 10
yes it's working
okay
let me make this as bold so font weight
400.
4600 not 400.
okay this is I think fine
when the starting doesn't match this
so
let me divide this back to section PX
and this has 400 pixels
the color will be this
and it will be fine
so I don't think we need to add the
email because we already have the
heading
also then we can remove this class I
mean the margin top best small
differently
or 25
fine it's here
fine now let me maniplicate okay we
can't do that now now we can do that
Nishan Kumar and let me add this value
here
in the headline
save and we will see this
fine
now let's add the location here after
the
heading so we can just say p
current user dot location
save
Now location will be this
fine then on the right side we have the
company and the college
so we can do it but first
let me
see this thing called this heading
this is on the two lines so we can do
that as well so save it
200 pixels
and it's much less so try Theta 400
400 is fine I guess now on the right
okay let's make it as 350.
on the right
let's add
these two things okay we also need to
decrease the line height so what is the
line height here
line height
is 20 pixels
so we can say line right
20px
and it's fine now it looks much better
now let me close this and on the right
we can add the other items so
let me wrap this in a div
INE
in here
let's add one more div for the right
items
but
this is if
should be also wrapped in another div in
the parent div
so that we can make them
side by side
so this day will have a class name of
profile
info
I think that's fine now come to the
profile card and let me add
we have profile card then we have
profile info
so we can add it here
then
we can say display Flex
for now okay let me just add the items
here
so what is the item that we need
the college and
the company
so let me copy to pitax and add it here
this will be
um what is it the key name is college
and Company
so let's say this should be
college and they should be
company
save them and we will see it here
also
the problem is let me add some class
names okay we don't need heading for now
okay save and this will be on the right
okay so now displays Flex justify
content will be space between
to make them on the right side
Also let's add the class here called
write info
for the info on the right
and just copy this
add it here
in the profile info
and we can say margin top
20 or 30 pixels
yes it's better
fine let me
now do what we have vit and this name
let's me let me style this
so both of them have same styling so we
can just say P tag here and
just add the same styling in the both
so
the font is system UI as usual
where it is
and the color is the same okay okay not
the color is in the same is different
font size is 15px
or 10 pixels
then fade weight 600
point with 600. save them Let's see we
have this and this on the right
point
let me just change okay just let me add
some margin from the right as well so
margin right
30 pixels
now it's better
let me declare the line height between
them
light line height 24 pixels
okay that's fine I guess
but that is on the par okay with
I think that's fine
let me get
the proper name
and we cannot copy this
okay it comes at the bottom if you click
this that we can Implement later
now let me edit it once more and add the
company
and college as this
and will lower Institute of
techno
logic now click save and we will see the
two items here
so yes we can decrease the height
between them and for that we need to
make class names first for example it
should be college and this should be
company
now in this P tag okay in this here just
replace the P tag with comma College I
mean dot college and
company
and we will have it here but in the
company when it's a margin top that is
negative
so we can add that to make it a little
bit at the top
so edit here with too much let's try 15.
yes it's better
okay the font size is too small I guess
so let's try 16 here
okay or 15.
the button was
um
what did we remove this let's
it's it's better
or just make it
t
okay a tip pixels or just 30. okay now
it's fine I guess
so our file page is done
fine okay what if you make this as 20
okay it comes on the level of level with
this
but if if if if we make the width here
for the right I mean the left card
let's decrease it
not the card the
heading
so let's make it 320.
I guess that's fine
so if we do this
okay if we did this
we can replace the margin by 30 to 20.
and make the margin drop by 25 okay
that's fine I guess
so this is how we created an edit pitch
in the profile now the next item we have
here is uh the posts
so let me add the card for the posts
so which is postcard I guess which
contains
okay not the postcard post update
one second okay we need this block
so let me come to profile card
we have this div
let me add it after this
and when it all stresses
so where it is coming from
it's a array
okay let me get the array let me create
an edit State here
let me create it here
now what to do is
okay when it import
this posts card
I mean used it first minute to Define so
let me do all the same things here
you will start a new memo defined
when it's the post card
so also Define that
from this component
if
now what we have here is
okay get unique ID note is not this
fire at stored API let me get
this use memo let me create it here
where I will set the status
okay gets status is not defined so let
me also get it
get status
from
quiet store API
we don't need post sorry let me remove
this
Pi navigate to the posts here but the
problem is
okay
let me get the post it is main here or
even better let me have a div I mean
class here called profile or just add
the class here
where it is post status Main
and this will be on the center
but let's make this as profile status
Main
we can just copy the class
but okay let's leave it that it add that
fine
so it's fine but the problem here is
we are seeing only though I mean we are
saying all the posts even when the post
is not our
so we need to see only those posts which
that we have made
so we have to filter through the data
which is all statuses and
we have to add one unique param called
ID
or let me check so we have the
okay we don't have ID do we have ID here
no we don't have ID
in the posts we have the email
so we can use this email
to check the post for us only us
so here we have the email
in one user chapter 440
here we have another
in one post we have one email in other
posts we have another email
so
we need the email so we can get it from
local storage or we can just
filter the data so filter
let's say item
I mean the current item
so return only those hosts where item
dot email
or user email
triple equals to our current email
from local storage so let me get it from
here
I guess from here like this
so where is it we don't need the styling
files we have to add it here
now save and now let's see we will see
the only one post here called hello from
Nishant Kumar
fine if you go to the home page we will
say both posts but if we go to the
profile page
you will see only the post that we have
now let me log out and login with other
account
okay what happens here is it is getting
uh this pop-up is getting
overwritten by this card so let me come
over to
this profile pop-up
so it's
profile pop-up
and
it is having
okay let me have this pop-up card
pop-up card here
okay
one second
where did we add The Styling for the
position absolute
one second let me check
in the top bar yes
come to the top bar component
where is it here
so we have this absolute
and the position as well so make Z index
as double nine now it will be like this
fine
if you click this
you will see this loan level let's log
out
log in with the other account
foreign
Gmail Dot
dot com the password let's add
in
you will have the card as before now
let's go to the profile page
and it's loading
see the thing is we only have Nishant
here and the name is Nishan as by but in
that component
we had Nishant Kumar and something else
I mean let's check the posts
we had the hello but here we have bye
now let's add
okay let's leave it it will work fine
now login
with my previous account that we used so
this
the password
sign in
and if you go to the profile page
we have
this Nishant Kumar let me add one more
status here called
the
profile
page
is done
now click post
and it will be here
now let's try the profile page
and we will have
this here this post after this
fine let's also create the link from
here I mean from the home page so when
we click the name from here we should be
on that profile
on remain on the personal profile
so
where does the home where does this come
one end
okay we have this common
in the common we have
profile card no not profile card posts
update card I think
yes or this yes we have this
so when we click the username okay in
the name let me add stylings here
so
where's the name let's say
text decoration underline
now the name will be underlined
so add the cursor
as pointer
if and we will have the pointer cut sir
let's change the color of this to Blue
ish color
or purple purple is not looking great
so try this
okay I think that's fine
we can make it larger because it's very
big small very small
yes now it's fine now the thing is when
we click this button
not the water I mean the name
we should be on the profile page
so let me create a function
or a common function so
in the page
I mean sorry in this file called
helpers let's say
uh open
profile
but wait okay the problem will be we
will we won't be able to use the route
there because I don't know why so better
to do it here
so let me import the you'll navigate
hook
and create let Navi gate equals to use
navigate
now on this click of the name we will
have on click
and then we can just say
navigate
to
the profile page so we can select we can
say
slash
profile
so let's check the profile page
let me close this this profile card
so here
I mean profile card okay
what is the page it's not profile card
it's profile component
yes so here we are having current user
passing I mean get passed through
and if we are having this current user
we can also get
the current user
here so
okay wait a second
okay we are having the route so just try
this first and see what happens
now click Nishan Kumar and we will see
nothing
so if you open the console
let's see what we are having
we are having this object
okay
but we don't see anything
if you refresh
and then we can see it
so
okay wait let me think for a second
so that problem has been solved
I mean we have two post hosts here post
one and post two one from Nishan Kumar
and one from Nishant too
if you click Nishant Kumar we will be on
this page and the posts of Nishant Kumar
will show up
if you click Nishant to the posts of
Nishant 2 will show up with the data
here
if you click profile page here
the current profile that we're on will
show up
so let me tell you how I did that
first of all we have this
name
and it is rendering the username like
this so when we are clicking this
name like Nishant Kumar we are sending
us to the profile page with the current
ID and the current email
so let's now come to the profile page
which is profile card
here so here we are getting the data
from music location Hook from reactor to
Dom in location
so it contains our ID and email that we
were sending previously
then now we have new two new functions
from firestore API so let me show you
so this function are called get single
status
okay wait a second
this name
get single status
and get single user
and in this two functions we are using
query from Firebase firestore
and let me show you we are importing
query and where
like this now let me come back to this
get single status and get single user
so these two are receiving the ID I mean
in the single status we're reading the
ID
and in the single user we're getting the
email
that favorite saving from location Hook
from react router
then
we are passing the ID in this query I
mean basically by checking if the user
ID
for the post is equal to the ID of the
current post
like this
meanwhile also
when we sign up we will have the ID
stored here so let me show you
this ID user ID which is a
string so when we are making a post this
ID will be stored inside the post so we
are on Nishan 2. we have this ID call it
now come here to post
and check this post
here the ID is five I mean user ID is
five seven a nine whatever and the post
is here
okay I mean whenever we make a post by a
user we will store the ID of the user in
the post
that's what this is
I mean by comparing the user ID with the
ID so if it matches only then we will
get the single status
so
this single status in this function we
are passing
thing set all status
this state and the same way we have get
single user to get the single user
from this so we have the email filter
here as query
so in this we will we are having the
email so let me show you
both users have an email
so when we click the list here I mean
this option here the ID of the post and
the email of the user is getting passed
here
in this component and furthermore we're
passing the ID and email to the function
so that we can filter it out and
so only those posts that we clicked upon
I mean the data
and the username for example if you
click Nishant Kumar here we will see
Nishant Kumar and all of these things
and the post details also
if you click Nishan too we will see this
but we don't see headlines and all
because in this second user we are not
having these items fine so that was how
I did that
file so
also here
we are having the few checks so
the data that we are getting from the
current user we are checking so
if the data that we're clicking in
for example I what I mean is
this current data we have here current
profile
is empty when we click this button so
let me show you why because in that case
we are not passing any IDs
so if you now open the console
and click this profile this will be an
empty object but you go from go from
here
to this page we will have this data so
that's why we're checking here so if
this look if this current profile
dot length we are converting it to an
array
if it is 0 it means the object is empty
in that case we will show this current
user email or name or heading and all
from here or else we will show
the current profile when we are getting
from here
so that's how we did it
I have added one key here also called
user ID which is having the unique ID
from here so whenever you register you
will have the user ID from here that we
will end later
now let's design the profile page in
LinkedIn I mean let's improve the design
because it's very much simple
when it's something like this so let me
click the button here
of user profile
so you will see this thing so it looks
much better much better
but here it's very simple so let me go
to the profile popup
and remove
all of these items so we don't need okay
let's comment out all of these items in
the
UL block
then let me create a common button so we
can say
we can create a folder first
okay here
in the common
say
button
and here let's make index Dot scss
and index.jsx
this file will be of a function
component
make it a button here and remove this
div
and add a button here
let's add the title and the title will
come from drop so we can desecrate
like this
now we need to link the CSS file here I
am in scss
so import
index Dot scss
now save this come to profile popup Dot
jsx and let me import this button so
import
ant from this component
and add it in the pop-up card
then let's pass the title as props title
will be
it is view profile yes
save this click the button here and
sorry pop up here
I'm in the user icon and we will have
this web profile icon I mean button
then let's style the button so give it a
class name of
common
BTN
now copy the class
come over here and here we can just say
display of flex
okay sorry not here instead we can do it
in the pop-up card in the parent element
so
we don't need this
and
we don't need this either just leave the
pop-up options
here make display of flex
justify content Center align item Center
now the button will be in Center perfect
like this
but we have to like make it big
so make uh but can we say width
let's try it 400 pixels
okay 300 or
or 300
or 200
okay common button
okay let's just give it a padding
20 pixels
okay it's big so padding should be here
I guess
yes
fine the pop-up is much bigger and a
little bit bigger now and this also also
we have some height here
so let's add some height
say 30px
yes
the cursor will be of pointed
and
let's change the background color to
white
okay
I mean it's not completely White
or is it just make it white smoke
to blend in the color of the pop-up yes
let me remove the Border or may change
it so border 1px
solid
let's say this color the London color
that we had so we can just copy it
from
I think login page
okay let me go to
where is it says login component
let me have all these three items
okay
okay what did we paste this items in
this index.jsx okay let's not write try
to try to use this
here let's see what happens
okay it is not and it's not defined
hmm
so this this main file
okay let's
okay just let me use the color here I
don't want to miss any time you can just
figure it out on your own I guess
this button is now having a border
fine
now the color should be
also the same color that we have here
but the Border should be led set to
pixels
yes
the color is little bit light I guess so
just make it light here
okay then say color
the same color
fine
border radius
uh 30 pixels
yes working let's now trigger the I mean
check the fonts
so
just click this click this and hover
this
so
we have this a system UI it was one
instance
okay
on the system UI so font family
system
UI the next thing is font weight
size
for 10 PX
and the color is this so let's repair
the color I forgot that we I forgot that
we can I forgot we can do that
now let's check yes it's perfect we have
your profile button
like this
let me close the what font
okay what happened think
the screen size was small
like
this okay no problem
fine now it's fine
okay
now like this we have this
but also a few items is on here like the
title I mean this so let me edit this
part here
fine so first of all let me go to the uh
button I mean on the button close this
profile pop-up then come here
let me pass this on click event
here
so we can just copy or cut the on click
event
from the list and just pass it here
now in this button we can also remove
and on click prop and on the button we
can Target this I mean on click will we
have one click
now if you click the button
it will be on the profile we are already
in the profile page
so click the button we will run the
profile page and it's working
like this knowledge let me also get
these items like title and all but first
we need to update it
okay what I mean is let's see this we
are having name and the headline
so let me edit the headline here
so name will be Nishant Kumar and
headline will be this click save
and let's show these items here in the
pop-up
so
when you locate the items first
so let's get it
okay
so open this API and firestore api.jsx
here we have a function
get current user I think yes let me call
it here
so
yes so import get
current user
all we need to do is call this function
so
let's say here okay we're already
already calling it here
sorry I didn't saw that
now we also have the state here
so
we can just Target current user dot
let's say let me open Firebase
we have the name and the user I mean
name and the headline so let's just say
name here for now check what we get
so if you click we will get the name
here but also we need to arrange them
so let's say what let's say A P tag here
a paragraph tag
then let me just move this here and Save
now in the pop-up card let me close this
we don't need it also don't need this as
well in the pop-up card
class let's come over here and let's
make Flex direction as column
and we will have this
okay I closed it
why did I close it then we have the
headline
so also add one more P tag
after this and just say
current user dot headline
headline save this
and now we will have this but it's
breaking I mean the width we need to
increase of the pop-up card so better to
make the height as Auto
now let's see we are getting it here
but there's the difference between the
designs if you see
here this should be current user or just
make a class name of name
and here make the class name of heading
or headline
now in the pop-up card let's design them
both
so the name is in the center
okay
so let me just click it and check the
design for the name I mean the font for
the name
so
here we can just write font size text in
PX
then color
as
this color
okay can we copy this properly yes this
color
then we have
font weight 600
and I think that's all for this now
close this let's check for the other one
for the heading or headline
let me copy the headline class
and add it here
then let's check for headline
so font size is 14 BX
so make it 14
weight is 400
then color is same so copy color and add
here and I guess that's all
yes save this let's try and it look much
better
let's try the font style okay it's enter
okay we can go with interfont it looks
perfect
yes
I mean it looks great in the name let's
also add texture line as left to make it
on the left
it's not going on the left so I guess we
have to make or remove this no not this
align items
yes now it's perfect
then what can we do we can move the
headline
at the top so we can say margin top
minus 20 PX
or let's say 15
yes it looks much better so for now we
don't have the image of the user but we
will add it later
also one more thing I noticed is if you
hover this button pop-up button it is
changing the style a little bit
so let me come to button
here I mean in The Styling file
just copy
this and
say okay one time only
let's say hover
here we can just copy the background
color and the color and the Border I
mean three things for styling
so what can we change let's check
okay
the background color and let's make this
as a little bit
on the drag side a little bit dark
that will be fine
and this should be dark as well
and then copy the class I mean color and
just add it here also
save and
if you hover it it turns this but the
white is too much Gray
now let's try
Pulsar too much
just leave it at this
and
okay let's leave it at white smoke and
just change the color of the
it's not it doesn't work
so I guess it's fine
but we can also make it a little bit
little bit little bit
yes it's now perfect
fine
okay
if you click reprofile from here from
profile nothing happens
because we are already the profile page
but same way yes same way we if we click
here nothing will happen
also
in the pop-up the name is at the top so
let's make this here as well
Magento just make not 15 make it minus
10 or 5 or 7 something
yes
so now we have this
like this here
okay
now
what to do is
fix the profile from here like the name
okay these are fixed I mean we have all
the items here
okay
but the name here should be on the top
we have Gap here so this shouldn't be
here
so
let me also leave it okay fine
okay
let's not leave it
just add the light tag here
we will have logout option here
we can also add button the same way we
add it here but this time this will be
of
log out text so as you can see log out
save
then just copy the on click event
on logout and add it here
name of the list here from here
save now the buttons are I mean two
buttons are sticking to each other
vertically so we have to make sure for
that also of that also so let's say
margin
10 pixels
and 0. yes
or not 10 that's a seven yes
file
okay
now what to do is what to do yes this
headline
so let me come over to the profile
pop-up
okay not the pop-up say profile card
this component here
let me close pop-ups and this
so here we have
username
let me come to this styling file
so here let's make margin top
minus 10 pixels
yes now it's in the top
also we can
okay I think it's fine
now see the button of edit is an icon
here so let me also get the icon from
react icons package so let me search on
Google react icons
okay
so let me copy I mean get the icon from
here
let me search our first import icon like
far beer
at the top
so let's search for Icon called edit or
pencil
in sale I think
yes you can use any icon here if you
want so let me choose this
it will be from
h i
slash hi
yes and the name of the
uh
name of the icon is hi outline pencil
so we can just add it here
to close this here
let me copy on click event or just cut
it and add it here remove the button of
edit
now save the file and we should have
this
here
but we are not having this here so let
me give it a refresh
I think it is still compiling
let me view terminal
yes now we have this pencil icon here
but also we need to change some designs
here as well
for example add a class name here
for
edit
icon
and copy the class
come to this file
so the parent is edit button so where is
it yes
we can remove this
and okay just add
a DOT for the class
so we will have pointer cuts
also when we hover it we need to see
some
design so that we see on LinkedIn
like let me show you this we should see
this
so we can just say background color
white smoke
also also also with
a TPX
height at TPX
okay the height of this increases
okay I guess what to do
let's okay I think what is it here
the background color is white smoke when
we go over it it's not working
I guess let's try some
bold color like red and then try
if it's working yes okay the thing is we
need some padding here let's say five
pixels
now we have this if we have one we will
see this
then padding should be here as well
yes working
or let's make it three
yes that also works but the color should
be not white let's say I mean not red
say white
and let's change the
Y2 some dark color like this
now you hover we will see this but it's
circulate so it's a border radius
50 percent here
now we have a circular icon
so make this as
5 itself
okay
what if we add margin and see what
happens here
also add margin here
okay that doesn't work
so what if you make 15
yes it's bigger but 15 is too much try
eight something
let's do trial and error like this yes
it's now fine
I guess it is
okay
make it 10.
and now it will be fine yes
still no not not fine not fine not fine
okay what is happening it's
not blend the full icon here
okay what if you remove it from here
no no no
okay let's leave it at 10. I think it
will not fit like that yes
look fine
so we have the idea edit icon here
like this so if you click this we want
the we will be on the edit page
okay we don't need to see this for now
okay
then what to do is what to do
okay okay
fine
so if you look eight icon here
we will be on this page I mean oh one
model will open up but here we don't
have a model we have one
one extra page which is
I think
this page called edit profile
or profile edit
fine
then here we need to add the values as
well so
get input so when we are loading the I
mean click clicking edit button the
values are not getting populated
so we need to add the value so just say
edit input for example
add a value here
and say edit input dot name
and now if you click edit the name will
be here
but it's not
okay give two profile view profile click
edit the name is not here
okay
I guess why
let me console this
we did inputs one second
let's see this
returning it down
Okay click edit
okay it's empty why it is empty which
shouldn't be empty
um
so when we're typing anything okay wait
a second okay the problem is not this
we need to get the inputs I mean get all
the data from here like in the user data
so let me open Firebase again
one more time
and get all the data from user here
so basically I think we already have it
I mean let me check the profile pop-up
you cannot this
so what is happening when
when we're clicking
the profile
icon here we are on this page called
profile edit
so where we were rendering the page I
mean in I think in the profile card
no not here
okay posts card
there was a file I don't know where is
it
profile edit okay
not here either
profile card
no not here either so where is it
I think it's in the profile component
yes here
so we're reading the current data of the
user and we're passing this in the
profile card
so come over to profile card
and we're hitting it here
then we need to pass
this data
where
so it's complicated I think just we need
to call
the
we need to call the API of current user
to get the data
Maybe
so we didn't return profile edit
this page
fine
so let me just call the function oh wait
a second I think we have this current
user already
so let's check
let's check let's check let's check open
the console
yes
yes so all we need to do is just over
this current user
to this because then the name will be
here and we can change it
like this then we don't need the console
log for now let's remove it and just add
the other values as well like headline
so
in the users
we are having the headline
so just add headline
and similarly all the other values like
company
then we have
this college at college
I think here if we left it should be
location
and I think that's all
now check here and
location is okay the problem is
we only have the name and the headline
not the location and the other things so
we can type update let's say Patna
this company and the college click save
and the data will be here instantly now
click the again this button again of
edit
the data will be here and then we can
change it to something like Chennai then
click save
and it will be changed here as well so
quickly
so that's
how we did this now what is the next
thing we need
Okay so
click edit we have let's add these items
like labels
so
for this let's say label
and it will be first
name
let me copy the first name and okay
just add the name we don't need to
decrease I mean break it into first and
then last name
then label should be here for this but
it will break because
it will not break fine that's better
then we have
headline so say headline here
then we have location so let me copy and
paste labels all over
like this here
this here and this here now here should
be College
it should be company
they should be location
we are fine
what the problem is the margin of the
input so common input
let me
check profile edit
where is this class
here
we are having margin top I mean margin
this so we can remove this
so make 0
and also remove this from here
okay
then we don't need the slowest let me
add
margin top minus 10.
or minus 5 something
okay now it looks fine but 10 what will
happen
yes this also works now let's sell the
label
so let me close this file
then label we need to style so
just add the label in the profile edit
inputs
the profile edit here it is
profile edit inputs let's say label
point will be system UI as usual
then all the input Fields will be of the
same type
close this and
this
and this okay what we need is now is
the label is done
okay the input so common input okay
we needed it again
so here
we can
just say Okay The Styling is same
let me
um
okay what is okay the thing is the width
I mean the height of the inputs are
small so make it small
shrink it now it looks fine
okay
also
we can do this as well so label
okay fine it's fine
like this we have
so
let's also add a few more Fields here
for example if you check that we have
headline we are done we have position
that is done
we have industry education
so let's also add industry
so they should be before education I
mean education is this college name
so this should be before education
I mean the college sorry
so just copy this and edit make this as
uh industry
change all the items here
they should be
in
industry
pin what is the spelling Indus
3 yes here as well
save this
now we will have one more for industry
but the data will be empty
and we know data but we will add it in
the post method later
then we have location and City
so
let's add the location
so they should be
location
then let that City
then here we can add the T
they should be city city and here also
fine
the location instead of okay admin okay
I think that's fine then we are contact
info then you can add website
let's add it here also at the last
which will be called as website
so it's the model but we are having
a page will continue to model that can
be scrolled automatically
so make this as website also
fine
we have link
let's check this and it's perfect
fine
now go back
and click edit again and the other
things will be empty
like this
so that's
in the edit page
okay
if you come here I mean let's also add
few more items like about
for example
let me copy this and add one more and
just say about but we don't have we
won't have the input we will have text
area so the text area
like this and on change will be of
it
on change will be of this name let's say
about
me
value should be the same for this I mean
edit inputs about me
then placeholder said will be
about
me
we can remove this and check what we are
getting here
so we are getting this so let's style
Okay add the class name also
common input
now we will have this
we can change the head height and the
width which is called rows and columns
so say rows
say rows will be 4
and columns
will be
also let's say try five
okay the problem is
we can increase it
let's remove rows and try
give it a refresh
the problem is the height is
I mean the height of this is default so
we can remove common input and add
common text area
text area
save
it's not getting big so make this as
rows I think
yes now it's getting big
now come to
the main
dot scss I mean this file and instead of
common input
just add called
common text area
and copy the style all the things here
except the height
then add it here and we will see this
about me where you can write your about
me text
then you can also add experiences
education I mean all of the items skills
and all
so
if we click skills edit it let's see we
are forgetting what getting what we're
getting
yes so we can add a skill so let's also
add it here
last item
so we can just say
kills
then
we don't need this so better to make an
input here
like this now save and let's change the
name to
else here also
also in this edit input.website
it will be fine
okay we need to avoid this as well
these two classes when we are hovering
and one with the placeholder
save and
now it looks much better now what we
need to do is add all the
keys I mean all the input to inputs to
the
this page so where we are posting the I
mean updating the post
open firestore API page
we have edit profile
okay but it's in the payloader directly
so
let me check the call
edit profile
edit inputs yes I think we don't need to
change anything just add the location as
okay wait
here make the location to Country
then add it here
and make this as country
as well
here also
density industry fine now save it and
let me let me just copy my data and
paste it here
so
this is Chennai area
country will be India
the industry will be what is the
industry for me
let me edit and check
it is industry is
e-learning okay
edit website let me add about me let me
add about me from here
where is it this text this text
okay we can add all of these fixed
or just let me add a few I mean just
small snippet of this
let me add skills like react
uh
JavaScript
angular
Firebase
and click save here
and the data will be saved
now if you click it again
we will see all the data that we saved
here populating
now all we need to do is just show the
data here
in this page
so come over to the profile card
and here we can see the data I mean show
the data
in some data like pay tax or at all
so
let me go here so we have name that this
then we have the location so let me add
location okay it's already here
which is called location so let me
append the location with this
so
current user location let me wrap this
in I mean add one
uh
what is it uh backticks the location
comma the country so just copy
this and paste it once more just make
this as country
so okay the comma will be here not there
save we will have Chennai India as
location
now
we have the link
of the website so let me just copy this
paste it here
please leave it okay just make it as
website
here
now the key for website is this
let me try let me see where I have
written that
where where where where
website website yes it's website
so
let me add this but we only need website
so just remove the country from here now
save this and the website will be here
like this but we don't need to make a P
tag here we need to make it a tag
so that we can click the link and go to
the website
so
the same thing we can do here so just
make it an href
and
wrap I mean copy these things I mean you
have copy and paste it here
save
and if you click it maybe we want that
page on my website
but we need to redirect on the other tab
so what we have to do is make this let
me show you what I mean
let me go to the profile
okay we don't see the attack
what happened now
okay now we see it fine so just make a
Target
as
blank
save but let's change the color of the
website first or let me add the other
Keys then we will style everything at
once
okay this is done fine
bottles we have here let's say about
so let's write the about here so let me
copy the P snippet and write
about me
so this should be about I guess
yes we will have this about me but the
problem is these items on the right is
getting shaped
so we have to change the okay we will
change it do not worry please
or we can just move this outside all of
the item which will be here
okay not here
after this div
so we will have this perfect
fine we have a beautiful looking profile
card here
then what did we add here in the profile
edit yes skills
so
let's render it out
and this will be
kills
and here also
which is react JavaScript angular
Firebase
let me add one more I mean one
h A P tag or just write skills here
okay so let me okay we need a space here
so just type uh and n b s
p and one semicolon
like this
now let's change the styling or let me
just wrap
this here in the P tag
gave it a class name of
till
label for now
okay it breaks the lines
just make this as or make
okay make this as a span
and also here
yes now it's fine now come I mean come
over to this styling file here for
profile card
and here we have college company on all
so let's write the selling here
so but first
okay let's do this so what is it let me
add The Styling for the website first
make this as skills
so website where is it this
so
we can write it here as well
so we need to change the color so say
color
of the text will be
blue which is
not here I guess let's try
this SAS
and
this
to copy this color or any color
from here
and just add the color here
but it does not change
what if we make this as important
important
okay let's make it as red and see what
happens
okay it's not changing
I guess
because we have some styling from for
attack in index
that we didn't remove
okay it's not here I guess I guess I
guess I guess okay
so classes website class name
but we cannot see the
okay I think we need to make background
color let's try this
not working Let me refresh
because I guess color will work
but it's not working working why it's
not working
okay a tag we have it should work
one more refresh let's try
so in on undefined it's true but
okay I guess we need to use Focus thing
or Focus so say website
Focus
then add this color
okay not focus
let's say a
tag
what is it
let's say a tag
it tag the name is
for
a tag
what am I right what I am writing I
don't know okay
we need to make the
just check this here
so website
not focus say
link or not link I am forgetting the
class or the selector here it tracks
Electric csscs
yes it's active
sometimes I forget myself
it's not working
let's try
let me go back
or run this
okay we have active here
so
what is that what is it what is it
the active a link
try a link here
let's download again
let's try with it
no still not working
over
till nothing
try that
I think let's leave it it's fine
okay now we have this link here
okay just we can do this as well
I forgot that we have this option
so so so
let me select this H1 sorry another one
a tag
and check the colors
we don't have any color for this a tag
or does this webkit link color
okay yes I think
let's try this
and add this color here
but not on Hover
let me just copy this
go back so we can say visited let me try
it here
it's not working let's say link
not working
let's try it here still not working I'll
leave it
I don't want to waste time for this on
this
so it's fine now what we have is
so this is done
now let me click this button called edit
but this button is go back so
let's change it here as well
so
we are having go back but here
we are having the x button
so let me do that as well
so this is from the profile edit page
let me remove the button
or just let me have the
this icon
so
we can go to this page called react
icons again
and just change the icon I mean add the
icon for
close so we can say close
let's choose this icon from AI
so let me copy this and add it here
and we were using this icon AI
so make this as a i
now replace the button with
this icon
and just make one click
go back
save this now let's try we need to
increase the size of this
so just to make
the size
to be let's say
uh 20 wait a second
okay 20 is fine let's try 25.
yes much better
so it works if you click this okay also
let me let me give it a class name
close icon
and copy the class let me come over here
not here I mean here's
remove the button that we have here
where is it
and we don't have any button like it's
just say cursor pointer on this class
if you hover this the cursor will be
changed to pointer
okay it's not I guess because
edit button we have
okay let me I mean move it here
yes okay not working not working
area button profile card
okay let me move it outside Jive then
I mean this
here
now it's fine so just move it I mean
just add it at the last not the first
so
we have all these items here we can
close this and if you go to home page
click this Prashant Kumar we will see
all these items but if you click Nishant
Kumar I mean okay we have the same user
here
and the posts are we getting here fine
so that was how we did the
okay I think
we only okay wait it's not over it we
only did the selling for the attack what
about these like about and skills so
just in the skills I'm in the span
wait the skill level
let me add a styling just make it bold
so it's one ring sorry let's remove it
just say
uh skill level
on weight
as let's say 600.
not working again
okay not in okay okay I think that was
the problem
we are having this outside not in the
inside of this slide info it's on the
left
so that was that is how that's why it
wasn't working
so just cut this and paste it outside
now it's working yes perfect
fine so if you remove this still it will
work I guess now we had this skill level
so let's add it here and say font wait
600.
now this will be bolder
let's change the font I mentioned the
font here
it's enter so it's I guess it's fine
so we have this and it's working
okay one second
this is not working the country where is
the country we don't see it
location heading
okay
location current user dot country
let me edit this
country is here but not here
so let me just try to console this
okay I guess we made it as country not
location
That's why nothing is here
yes now okay just rename the location to
Country here
where is it
okay okay
what's this
I guess this should be done here as well
wrap it in a back tick and just then add
the country with location
after the location
now we can see that perfect
fine
so this is our profile page
and we have the posts here we can edit
them
and save and then we can go back or just
close this so that was our final profile
page for the LinkedIn clone
all right I don't think we need anything
else here for now okay
so I think that's fine
we cannot integrate all of the items I
mean you can integrate but it will only
waste my time because they are very
simple things okay so I guess that's all
for now if you click the link here this
will be on the new tab and if you go
back we can still see this
fine then
now let's work on the like button system
in LinkedIn or on LinkedIn but before
that we need some fixes and this is it
so if you go to any profile like Nishan
Command 2
this city is undefined here
if you go to profile
it's also undefined to fix that we can
just change this to City the location we
have here
this location make it City
and here as well
and if you now check the profile the
city will be Patna India
Kumar it will be greater Chennai and
this fine now close this this as well
fine
so as you see here that we have one
button here
so let me create a component here first
for the like system so we can say
uh
wait a second in common let's have add a
folder called
like
button
fine
here
let me add one index Dot jsx
and one for the styling
like this
okay here we can make a function
component and the button will be called
as like button
simple
now
let me import
the CSS file or SSS file
so index
Dot scss
now let me add a button I mean wait
so we need one icon here so we will add
it but before that let me add one P tag
and say
like
so now let me get the button here
in this component called posts card
import like button from the component
route and add it here like this
fine
so it's here
now let me import the icon from react
icon so import
from
react icons
slash let's say
let's try bi
and if you type like like button
or let's say beer like
or bi like let's see what we have if you
if you render it here
so save I think it's optimizing the
dependencies
so meanwhile we can check other
uh we can check other like buttons as
well I mean other phone icons sorry
so let's try for like
so we can try outline for AI like this
let me try this and make this as a i
now just replace the button with this
okay why it is not showing up here let's
check open the view okay now it's
showing up fine let me add the size of
the icon to be much I mean to be bigger
so let's say 25 what yes
yes it's big we can try for 30 also
yes also better
this day we have a class and we'll have
a class name of
let's say like
container
fine let me just copy the button class
I'm in deep class and add it here
and we will make display as Flex
then justify content
okay we don't need this this property we
don't need we need align item
enter
yes now it's in the center
so we have like text and the icon little
gap between them so
10 pixels will it work yes
then we need some add some padding
20 pixels
okay padding let's try
20 and 0. okay I think 0 and 20 will
work
yes
if we try 10
fine also working
we try if you make this as 5 here
and I think that's also fine
so we have like button here
let me change the font here
so just say P tag
Point Family system
UI
fine
let me check the fonts here
so it's normal weight is 600 so say font
weight
okay then color is this
so the color
this
fine I guess now let's check
okay we have this here
now font size 14 bits
I think that's all for this button
we can leave it at that
okay
fine
okay in the in this div we have to make
cursor as pointer so if you hover the
icon or button you will see
this pointer cutter also the Gap is Big
so let's make it 5 only
yes and then this padding is seven
okay I think that's fine
I guess it's fine
then what can we do here is close this
okay
okay so we have the like button here
so now what we have to do is
when we click the button we need to send
some ID which is the I mean we need the
post ID and the user ID
fine
so we can get it
so let me create a function here
so okay not here
so this is const
let's say
let's say on let's say handle like yes
here
now on this button click I mean on this
div click we should have this
function
okay now as I said that we need to pass
the ID of the post that we are going to
like and the ID of the user who is going
to like it
so we can do it like this
so
we need two things that I said
okay one second
yes we need the user ID
user ID
and the user ID will be
this ID so we are having posts and the
ID
okay
so where can we get the user ID from we
need the current user
so we can
go to this file store dpa.jsx and do we
have one function called get current
user so let's get it here
so we can just say import
get
current
user
and then we can call the function in use
effective or use memo
say this
okay
get current user
so it takes a param called Set current
user so we need one state as well so say
current
user comma set
current user equals to use State say
let's send object because the data is in
object format
so just pass it like this
and all we need to do is console.log
this current user
so save okay we don't we have to remove
this for now we will add it later
now open the console
here
and we have an object and here we have
the ID and this ID is called the user ID
so we can just say current user.id
so
now this let me remove this and pass
user ID as
this and post ID equals to
posts let me console the posts also
to show you the posts let me just remove
this it will control Z this is called
the post ID so let me show you in
Firebase
yes so if you check here
that we have post I mean posts and every
post has an ID
come over here
and if you refresh the page
okay we are saying
posts here
okay a lot of posts we are seeing
so better to have the ID from them I
mean get the ID
so we can just say posts
dot ID
now refresh it once more
and we will have a lot of IDs here
see so we are having this this this two
times we have every ID
for example
[Music]
um
yes we have all the IDS here for all the
posts four IDs four posts
then second param will have to pass I'm
an argument we have to pass
is the post ID as
this
so the post ID will be posts dot ID
let me remove control law
now let's get it here
so we can say
user ID
comma post ID
fine we have to structured it here now
on this function handle click we will
call a method that will be inside this
api.jsx
so let's close styling file we don't
need it right now
so here let me add one function called
export const
and or say
like
post
and in here we will create one
uh what is it we will create one
document
for example as I say as you see I am
getting the user ID and post select pass
let's pass it here
I mean I mean we will call the function
here let me call it
this function so
import
uh what is the name what is the name
like post
here
so simply we can just call this and in
here we can pass these two things
like this so it will get up here fine so
this step is done
now let me just show you in the console
what is it we are getting
for the user ID
and the post ID
open the console let me open the console
let me close this
so let's click this like
so the post ID for post 4 is all right
something and I am having this user ID
so let me now check users we have three
users
and I have logged in with this user to
zero something
one second which user we have wait no
this is the post that is sorry
this is the post ID and the user ID is
r80
I mean this user second user
so let me show you I mean confirm it go
to profile and Nishan Command 2 is there
like this it will take and all
fine so this is the idea of this current
percent
Nishant Kumar 2 I mean if you click like
you will see it again see it again
then the second one is called the post
ID so for post 4 let me show you
where it is post for the ID is 2 0
sorry 2 2 0 a u whatever this is ID
so we're eating it so now we have to
create a document that contains these
two IDs together so that we can have
they made firestore so first of all we
need to create one reference which is
called a like reference
so I mean like ref likes ref
but the likes collection for the lit
like
ref equals to
collection
let's say fire store comma likes table
now now now now now we have to use this
so we can just remove these items
then we can do this
here so basically
we will create a
let doc
to
like equals to we can say Doc function
that we need to import I guess
yes we are already importing it yes
we are using it in edit profile function
so this takes three things and the first
one is called Firebase
certifiers.net Firebase
database I mean
then the second thing it takes is the
collection I'm in the reference sorry
I don't know I am
missing words to say it takes this like
like surf that contains firestore and
the likes
one second
okay
no sorry we did it wrong it takes the
first as like sir because we already
have fire stored inside it and the table
name which is likes
then we will have to merge these two uh
let's say we merge these two user ID and
post ID
to create a collection ID a dynamic ID
so add a
dollar and say post ID and
I mean user ID and post ID like this
fine
also let me add one underscore here
fine I think that will work
I think that will not work because
this is not dynamic dynamic field are
only user ID and post ID
so let me revert them back
and we can say user ID
outside the curly bracket and underscore
and then say
uh dollar again
curly bracket post ID
now we have we will have any kind like
this that will show up in the like
stable in fired store
now that's done
now we need to set the dock so let me
import a function called set dock
so this is different from add and
because it sets the document like this
using a unique ID
that we can Define our own
so we can say
we can say we can say what is the name
get doc sorry not get doc said doc let
me just import it and in here
we will pass
this document and the data that we need
to store
so we will store the user ID and post ID
as object like this fine
now let's try to run this
so all is set
okay
now let me open the
console and clear it
we can also okay I mean let's just trap
not trap just
add or wrap them in try catch block
so that we may have some knowledge of
the errors if we have them
catch so say error
what's happening
try and
wait I forgot the syntax
again it's not here it's in this auth
API so let's check okay catch error okay
this is how it works sorry I forgot this
so catch
error
console.log
err
or now let's click the like button here
in the first post called post 4.
so we have clicked it
now let me check the fire store let me
give it a refresh
I hope we will have a like table here
yes see we have the likes collection
in this new in this document so
see we are merging the user ID with post
ID
this user ID is from R8 and this post ad
is this
so we have this
so our post has been liked fine but we
have liked the post
now let's get the posts I mean sorry
let's get the let's get the likes here
so to get the likes we need
to have I use effect hook here as well
so I'm in here
okay what I am saying here
it's 1 41 am at the night and I'm doing
all of this so let me have one use memo
so when the page loads we will have all
the likes for the
page
okay we have imported it also then in
this use memo hook
we have to call a function from this API
file so also create its export const get
likes
by
by user
then
also let me add try catch block here to
not have some errors
fine and in this uh in this try block we
will have one variable called let's say
let likes
like this
okay not this but first let me create
one query to filter the likes based on
the post ID
for that we need to First copy the
function and import it here
and use it in this use memo
then we can pass the IDS here
which is user ID and post ID
so I don't think we need the user ID but
let's just pass it so let me get it here
as well
now let me create a query here so let's
say let like query equals to
we can use Query
and in here we can add a collection
so the collection is already this
collection if you go over to this we
have this collection called like serif
so we have to use this collection name
like Express
then what can we do is
we will have to make a
yes where
where
and in the where we will have
we will check for post ID
double equals to
wait what happened double equals to this
post ID
so basically
we will check if the post ID is equal to
this post ID
only then we will return it
now
I mean the post ID of the post is equal
to the post ID of the database data from
we are getting from the database
then we have to
use the on snapshot function
on Snapshot for real-time data and in
here we will pass
this query called like query
like query
comma it sends a response social
response
and we can simply
do this
so we can simply create a variable
called it like
or likes
and in here we can say snapshot
snapshot
snapshot Dot
Docs
dot map
and then it takes a param called dock I
mean
yes we can say a param and then it
returns log.data
like this fine it's done
so now this lags contain all our data
for the like so if you try to console
this
but in a second this wheel where not
snapshot fine
now let's check in the console what we
are getting if we refresh the page
okay we don't need the user ID I guess
so remove it
fine
so we're getting nothing are we calling
this
yes we are calling this but the problem
is we have to run the use memo hook
whenever this user ID and post ID
changes then we will get the likes but
we're not getting it
so where are they missing
so
[Music]
um
on Snapshot like query we're passing
fine
the problem is here see we are having
the post ID from this param
I mean we are passing it from here
but we're not passing the post ID only
we are passing the user ID
so in this case the reactor thinks or
JavaScript things
that this post ID is the user ID because
it's a first param so if you remove this
and save the error will go away
so let me now check see we are writing
this array and it contains our post ID
and the user ID like this
fine now what we have to do is we have
to store the number of likes
count in a variable
so let's do that
so to do that we will create we will
create a lead variable called likes
count
equals to likes
dot length
length yes
fine now we'll filter through the likes
so see which likes are from which post
I mean not from the which post from
which user that is why we also need the
user ID but I removed it so
let's get it back
user ID also let me pass it from here
first param
save this and this
now here we will just do this and this
means
const
light
or say is like which post are liked by
which user because we have multiple
users and multiple posts
fine
so we can just
click the likes dot sum
and in the sum we will have a param
called like and then we will check if
the like dot user ID
I mean from this uh dislikes
we had the user ID if this like is
equals to the user ID by getting from
the Para
user
ID
fine
we have this is liked and likes count
which we need now
in this let me create two states so one
will be
like
count and set likes
count
so it will be a number say zero
or we can make it null but let's make it
zero fine now second state when it is if
the post is liked or not
so still liked and set
light
so it's date
and here we will have false because
initially we will make it false because
the posts will be unlike
now let's pass these two here
as
params
let's get it
in here
here
so like this
now
we'll simply set
in the likes count
I mean set likes count will be equal to
likes count then is like will be equal
to
so it is like will be equal to is light
fine so our work here is done almost in
this git likes by user function
now if you console let's count here CLG
this let's see what we get in the
console so come to the bottom
fine we will get zero okay we are
writing this set likes count is not a
function
set likes count
it's not a function then what is it
so now let me try
light just refresh the page once and see
what happens
maybe some error and it will go away
so
okay it's false I don't know why
set like sound is not a function
so set likes count Lex count let me make
it like this
and see what happens what happens
refresh
set like sound does not function why is
this happening
huh
okay just leave it for now
okay
firestore API 147
okay now 114 this like this line so
let's console it
and
it is like it's not a function now
okay now why are we getting this
huh
what can we do here
okay fine fine we are passing it at the
wrong place we should pass it here
now let's see this will work fine
maybe I am dumb to make this kind of
mistakes
so we are getting false because posts
are unliked okay
so
now this is done
okay now we have likes comment and liked
so if your internet likes count here
so we will see
we have one like on this post and this
post so in this we will have two posts
here I'm into we have two items
and the post ID is same first user ID is
same
yes the post side is different it paints
two of the posts are liked if you click
third one this will turn to one and it
will be updated here
but the thing is if you click it again
this will not be unlocked
so that's a problem
but before that let me show you let me
go to other profile so we are on this
profile called
design command 2.
let me log out and remember that we have
liked post 2 1 and post four not post
three from Nishan Command 2
now let me come to this page called
I will fix that also I'm in this issue
that we have in login page and the
registered page at the last of the video
I'm in this section
now sign in
see
the likes is one but
we are not saying okay
if you click it again the like will be
two
here the like will be two and all of the
data is stored here as post ID and user
ID collection name
document name
The Collection field is here okay now
what we have to do is we have to pass
this light in this like post to handle
the dislike function as well
so let me get here
so we will run the set dock only if the
post is not liked else we will run one
more property called delete dock that
will delete the like from The Collection
using this dock I mean this will delete
the like only that we have had fine
so to do that we can simply add
delete dock
with second delete
doc not delete doc yes and just pass the
like I mean the doc to like this
now save and
now let's check if you click it again
it will be removed from here but it's
not it's not
is it getting removed
one second
I think we are doing it correct delete
dock is it okay we have to import it
also sorry we are not importing it
delete talk
yes
now check click the button
and
still not working
okay
but why
okay let's do this
so if the likes exist
like I mean if the light is true we will
show
light else we will show like
now let's see what we have here
so click this okay it's not working
okay the problem I mean the issue is
here so we are having the ID so I think
I made a typing mistake this should be
user ID
now it will work
so click it again and as you click it
again we will see that the like has been
removed from this post
click it again you will have like so the
current likes number is 2. and on this
post we have zero
so let me close this because we don't
need it right now it's done
fine
now this is done
now let me repeat this thing also here
so
let me wrap this in like so if like this
too we will show the blue sign here so
let me go to the react icons once more
and
copy one more
icon for like but this time it will be
filled so like
okay which one should we use
a I feel like let's try this
will it work
let's try
okay
and in here where
so if the like this 2 we will show
this icon with the size of 30 also
add okay
add them here
fine click like here and this will turn
to dark I mean this color click it again
and the number will change and I mean
number will decrease if you unlike and
it will increase if you like also the
color will change on the icon
fine so do we have a color
ah so let's make it as
red
click it and it becomes set but trade is
too bright
so let's make it as a heart
like this and they should be
just make ourselves just search hurt
here
so we need AI so just say AI
will hurt sorry outline hurt
and then
we will have
field heart
so here we will have
will hurt and the color will be red but
here outlined but
now check here click it becomes red and
if you click it again it becomes
outlined
we can remove this P tag here
and we will see only the like like this
so is it proper let me check
so click if you click if I click a post
we don't see the number here which is
the number here at the top
so let me remove the likes count from
here and just style it
fine
so click it again and if you refresh
after clicking this will persist
see it comes let me click post to like
and if you refresh it will persist as
well
yes see it's persisting now
let me come to the home page but in on
the home page let me log out and
let me log out and log in with the other
account
wait a second let me view profile let me
log in with the other account
so please say Nishan as 550 at the rate
I mean one two three at the rate
gmail.com one two three four five six
seven sign in
so here the like is different
I mean the post 4 is here post three
post one but in that other account we
only like post four and I think post two
so we can go back and check
here we have post fourth one and two
let's check here
just to be sure
one two three four five six seven
here we have only post four and two so
it's working perfectly I mean perfect
now let's position this slides count
somewhere so let me close this and this
all we need is to make here so after
this post
so
just say let's say we are having it just
make it at the top then
here
okay likes count only like this
so we need to arrange that
so make it a P tag
and wrap all of this energy
now in this difficult like container we
will need some styling for Flex
so we already have flex and just say
Flex Direction
column
then
we need justify content Center not this
because the whole structure of the page
changes if you do that
so
now let's style the P tag here
okay it's already styled but it's
different p
so
okay
let's add margin left
20px
or 10 Also let's try
10.
so we can say just like it says here in
the LinkedIn two people like this it
says
U and 219 other likes it like this post
so
we can say just this
this
Mini
people like this post save this and we
will see this
so I guess this should be 5 only
it will work fine
one people like this post okay
let's remove many
and if you click if you like the like
count will increase
so
let me check the styling here
so the font size is same
font is size 12 pixels
family same
size is this
then weight is 400
then the color is
this
let me copy the color and just replace
this rgba
whatever we have here
now let's check
we are getting it as blue
well it's not blue it's gray yes I can
see that
okay if you hovered it then it's blue
so just remove this and let me invert
this back
but let's change it to a grayer version
so just slide the Color Picker color
now it's fine I guess
so just make the font size as 13.
yes
fine so we have implemented the like
system
okay so the thing is we have the like
like we have the like
uh text here
so in this div let's say one more P tag
and it will say like
so it's here
fine
okay
in this div let's give it a class name
of likes inner
copy this class commode to index and in
here this selects in Earth
display of flex
align item Center
and we will have this like again let's
add a p and add all of the stylings but
make this as 16
remove this
and make this as 600.
now we will have a like text here as
well
like this
but the thing is
one more thing we have to do the light
if you have lagged the page I mean the
post this text will be turned to Blue
so we can also handle that
so their class name here
so if like is here it means so black
sorry blue text
else for black
fine
so in the blue one
here let's do in the blue
let's add this color that we had on the
way we're getting
this color
so say color
this but if we have black
like
we will show
let's say
which color
this color
save and Save
let me click remove this
so if it is liked we will show Blue
but okay this should be here also this
color should be on this like button also
so just make it like this
click it again
the both will turn to zero I mean it
will decrease
so that's how we used like button here
and we can also change the
uh this here this should be 15 or 14
also
and I guess
uh margin top
minus 10 pixels
okay not here
just in this
class
or 20
will work so also if you see we will
have we have a heading tag here am I
head not heading tag one HR
between these two posts or two people
like the post and the like button
so we can
just throw one HR here
like this
so it or we cannot see
this HR I guess because we are having
this
so let's wrap it in a tape
now we can see it
fine
so I don't know how to change the color
of this HR but
two people like this post in this p
I mean let me see
here we can do margin bottom
sorry
margin bottom minus 20.
okay too much fine distance
okay still too much zero
too much let's say
or five
music video again
okay which I am which on which I'm doing
I guess remove this padding and see what
happens
okay if we are using this as
but if you have the line items here also
and this will make it in the center
so where okay margin bottom should be
here not here
let's say minus 20 or 10.
yes it's working or not I don't know
what
okay
so let's make it as 5 only then see what
happens
then make this as 0.
nothing will work so I guess that's fine
fine
if that's fine it's fine but something
is still not right here
margin top 20 this text should be
not here I mean this should be on a
little bit on the bottom
from the top so margin top
10 pixels
or c0
okay I think that will break our design
so let's leave it
fine
so I guess that's it for this section
also
okay if we remove this Leaf what happens
I think that's happening because of this
div
so give this a class name of HR line
so
copy this class
come to this page I mean this section
called like container
and say margin
top minus
5px
or 15
yes I think okay sorry
or 17
yes now it's fine
so how to change the color of this HR
let's see this
change
the color
of
HR tag
let's say let's say let's say let's say
let's see let's see
okay
let's try WF schools
HR
new five
okay let's
add a color here
I mean let's try this green color first
then we will have an idea okay it's it
works so I guess we don't need these two
we need border top this and then let's
see
[Music]
um
what if you make a border only
gets covering this okay guys if we
target HR inside
and then move the border right here
okay that will change the color
fine got it so we need to make it gray
so just move it here
and it's gray a little bit more on the
white side
but it's too much
so move it now here and it's yes it
looks great
so now we have the like button if you
click like the post will be liked if you
click it again it will be unlocked
fine
so that's all for this section
I mean the like button
now let's work on the comments input I
mean command system
so
we need to replace the name of like
singer to likes
comment inner
like this
so just copy this class
and change it here as well so I mean
like signal will be like comment inner
fine
now it is breaking
so why it's breaking
okay save it here as well yes now it's
fine
okay the same way we have this like
comment in here
make one more for the comment box
so let me get to this Library called
react icons again
and
add for comment
add one for comment which is this AI
outline
so let me add only one let me add only
one icon here
which is this
and Save
we need to import this
save and you will have this so make this
as comment not like
see now we have to wrap these both divs
in one more div a parent div
and here
this day will have a class name of
let's say like comment just to this
or likes comment anywhere anything you
want
now come over here
say like comment and display of flex
okay not
let's not make it Flex make it grid and
just say
uh grid
template columns
uh let's say let's say let's say
Auto auto auto auto
fine
okay
I think we did it wrong I think we named
it wrong so this should be like
I mean it should be comment and they
should be like yes now it's fine
okay now what will happen is when you
click the comment box
we will see your input so let me add an
input here
input
okay placeholder add a comment
just like we have on LinkedIn
let me give it a class okay one more
thing
if we click this thing called two people
like this post this post will be unliked
because we are having the Handler here
so move it inside like comment inner
so now only when we click the button
like the post will be liked
now in this input say add a class name
called
comment
input
now let me come over here
and
in this let's say comment input
height 35 pixels
background color
let's say white smoke
padding left for the text inside let's
say 5px
or even 7
border radius
30 PX
30px
okay
now what we have
okay let's add border
1px solid
two one two one two one save
where I will have
this option to have a comment box yes
but what if we focus on that on that so
Focus
let's say
border will be
okay let's make it light a little bit
light
on the gray side
so
let's check this one
yes it's gray
now here we will make it slightly more
darker
to get it highlighted
now if you click this
we will see highlight option here
let me Mark let me add or I think this
should be not border this should be
outline
now let's check yes it's now perfect
we can just move this to 10.
to have this okay just like we have on
LinkedIn
find now we can type inside anything
okay the thing is the text color we have
to change as well
so
we can make color
as this color
I mean
let's say
let's try this color
yes it's working
let's also change the font here so tell
me why let's add here
or what if we just add it here
okay
so here also the color should be changed
to this
yes
let me add font
uh font size 16px
yes it's better
so if you make this 16px let's add the
height to 40.
yes
now we can write a comment here okay now
also we need a
button here
so we can add a button
so we can just use one button that we
already have
which is called
this button
save button
or we can create our own button here
so just say
button
add
comment now say when we will have a
button here let's also sell the button
here so say add
comment BTN
let me style this after this
say
let's say width should be of
200 pixels
or maybe 100 let's try
okay 150 what about this yes fine right
35px
background color
this color called Blue
let's remove the outline
now 10 will be none
fine
so yes outline is none
also
cuts are as pointer and one more thing
is border as done as also
the Border
and none
okay we have a button uh cool button
also let me add water radius as 30 to
make them rounded
fine
then let me add margin top a little bit
let's say 20px will it work yes or 15
then margin bottom
also 15px
yes
fine it's working I mean it is here add
comment button okay
now
this button is here okay what can we do
we can wrap them in a fragment I will
tell you why
because these two things should be
conditional
I mean when we click the command only
then this two should show up so let's
create a state here
it's a const
show
comment
box
and set
so comment
box
used it let's make it false because
initially we will not show them
so let me add The Styling sorry this
conditional here condition here
if it is true only then show them else
show an empty fragment
so it's false that's why we cannot see
it but if we change it to true we can
see it so the show that it this function
called set show comment box
should be on this thing called uh like
comments in its second div so say on
click
we can make this true true
because if you see in the LinkedIn Let
me refresh the page and try again
so click it then we can see the comment
box
so here also we have comment if you
click this we can see the comment box
but if you click it again
this doesn't hide
so we can implement the same thing here
okay
find
let's change the color of the comment
there
or when it is active
so just say show command box then blue
else black so refresh it once more
so this is now black okay here also we
can make
ah okay they should be
one second
make it in the color
crop so if this is true blue else show
default or this color called two one two
one
two one
add one hashtag S6 code
now save
click this
it will be highlighted and fine that's
done
now let me get the comment from here so
we can just say const
comment and set
comment so equals to use State let's add
a string here
now we need a function so say get
comment
I mean get comment from the input this
will receive an event
and get comment will be here on this
input so
on click
this get comment let me add the name
here called
comment
okay
now if you need to store the comment in
this that comment
the set command will be event
dot Target
dot value
fine
okay that's done
now we have the command now let me come
over to this file in the vs code which
is the I mean which is API file s.jsx
so here we have this function so let me
create one more function called export
const
comment
like this so let me have this try catch
block here as well
we have try then we have catch
that catches the error what's the error
and CLG error
now this post command will take the post
ID that we have
for the Post
okay so let me pass it here in this
function
so they should take a post IDs
wait a second not just the post ID it
will take
the post ID the comment and the time
stamp of the post comment
these three things
so let's pass the data from here so
first just let me import this post
comment function
and add it in one more function called
say
add comment
here then just call this
and pass
the post ID
of the post then whatever the next thing
the comment which is this comment and
the time stamp
so the timestamp we can get from
moment.js
so let me go to helpers use movement
and we can just cop we can just call
this current I mean get current
timestamp
here
so just to get current timestamp and add
the format so let's make it Triple L
like this just like we had on post
I mean when we post a status or a post
so this function will be called when we
click the button here called on click
like this now save this
and we have this post comment here now
come over here and the rest of the
things will be done here and the first
thing to do here is to import I mean to
add the add doc function
to add the document to the filed store
but before that we need to create a
collection for the comments
so just like we have here so let's say
let comment or comment shref equals to
collection
firestore comma
uh let's say comments
fine
now we need this to pass I mean to pass
it here
in this add-off like comments ref
then the next thing we need is the data
so just add it using in curly brackets
like this all these three things
here
fine just like we have in the
get like by user sorry post like by I
mean like post
so fine it's done and I think that's all
also
let me close this when we are adding a
comment
this should be a then block after that
and
then we can just clear out the comment
now this comment should be also as a
value here
so
just add a value
as comment
now let's try this and see what happens
I think let me open fired store
from Firebase
okay
let's try I think it will work
it will work so post ID will be having
and comment and timestamp
so let me add a comment here called
this okay we cannot type here something
is wrong
add comment
I mean get comment function is getting
called
and we're setting it here
let me console this
wait a second on change
okay this should be not on click sorry
on change
so
mistakes
on change
now let's try to write a comment called
this is post one okay the thing is it's
the color is very
light here
so drag the marker here
and copy the color and add it here
save
let's also add it here
I think that's fine now let's click add
a comment
so if you check here let's see what
happens
I think the command is not sent
something is wrong so let me open the
console and check what is wrong
click add a comment okay
get current timestamp is not defined
where
I think this is not defined because we
haven't imported it yet
so import
get
current
timestamp
just let me copy the import from
somewhere
for example from here
this post update page
so let me close and add this here
now save and let's give it a try
add a comment
again the problem is cannot take
properties up then
line number 24 here
okay I guess we can remove it from here
and I mean remember then block and just
set the set command as empty
now let's try
yes I think the comment has been sent
because we don't see it here
let's check the console in file store
oh let me move the mic here yes now we
have a comments collection and in this
we have two comments
okay this is first one and this is post
one again let me delete this collection
and try once more
okay
so let me add a command called
this is comment
one
click add comment
let's check here in the store
firestore
so we don't need this limit so close it
because we have added the comment button
here just like LinkedIn yes now we have
this comment and we have post ID and the
timestamp
now all we have to do is show this
comments here
so we can add a function also one more
called export
const get
comments
here
and also at try block here
and a catch block
so console.log
better
save this and
just copy this I mean import the
function here
from
the API file
now we need the I mean we can have it
here also
and this function I mean get comments
this will take a few things for example
it will take
the
What will what it will take it will take
the post ID
so let's pass it here like this and
so in this function let's also get it in
the try block let me create a query to
get the comments
only for a single user or a single post
so let's say let uh
comment or
single post
query equals to
let's add a query
I mean this and add the
time I mean at the mm reference for
comments like this
then we will have a wear
and in where we will check if
the post
ID
for the comment
where
comma
double equals comma the post ID so if
the post ID
of
The Collection or the document is equal
to the post ID we are passing
that will show the post ID for
it which is a post ID for only the sync
I am in the same post that we commented
on
fine
okay now
we have this reference now let me have
one snapshot here so so snapshot
or on Snapshot
then
we can just pass this query which is
single post query and
it will add it will show us a response
through the response as callback
and then we can just add
comments or cons
let's say
comments equals to
okay I think
yes let's do it it's fine so comments
response dot Docs
and we have to map with rocks just like
we do in every other snapshot like see
like this we see here
like this
so I mean this for the current user this
is this is for the single user
okay
so
map so let's say it sends us a dock
single dock
and then
we get the ID
wait we have to return this so we can
just say return
and ID will be equal to
doc dot ID
comma then we will spread the data from
the dock so dock I mean triple dots
doc dot data
like this and if you save this so we
will have the comments in here in this
comments for each post
fine
so we can try to console.log this here
so we can do that also
sorry this comments
now
we are calling it here get comments okay
save this now let me open
the our application
okay
so
so we have the object
which contains the comment and it says
that this is the comment one
okay
now all we need to do is store this
command in a state
so let me create a state here called
we have comment so let's say const
comments and
that comments
so equals to use State and an array
pass this set comments
in this get comments
come over here
and let's get it
then just set it here
fine
so our comments will be in the state
called comments
so all we need to do is map through the
comments here so
we can do it like this
let me come over to the bottom
okay let's do it here
after the show comments box
so we can just say or
should we do it here or here let's try
it here so comments
dot length
if it is more than zero only then we
will show the comments
so if it is more than 0 then we will map
it
so we can say comment or comments dot
map
then
we will have a single comment from them
and
then we will return some things
I mean some jsx
so add a div here first
and
if there's no data we will show an empty
fragment
like this
so in this div
let's add
2p tags
and here we can say comment dot comment
also one more I mean other P tag will be
for the timestamp
so this should be
let's say the name was time stamp I
guess
okay it's not here
where is it we are sending it
get current timestamp
this post ID here yes timestamp sorry
so where is it time step
fine
now
let's close the console and give it a
refresh
now if you click comment
okay we don't see anything yes
here on this page in the post called
post one we have this is comment one and
the time step
on others we don't see it because we
don't have a comments so just make the
comment text to comments
so
we will see the comments only when when
we click the comment like this or even
middle is that when we click the comment
button this thing we can revert the
state
we just don't need to turn it to true we
can revert it so if you click it again
this will be hidden
so where was the state here so show
comment I mean set show comment box
so just make these two
comment box now click it again and this
will hide
it also hide it also
fine
so our comment is on this post
one
let's add the comment on post four
so this will be
this is
post 4 add comment and this will be here
instantly
now let's Style
the comments some in some manner so
let's make this a class name of
uh all comments
okay let me copy this all comments so we
don't
okay we will need it one thing we have
to do here also that is the name of the
person who commented or the username
so in here let's add this all comments
let me make this here
here
okay so they should be display of flex
and
so
between them we can add one dot I mean
it's not a DOT so let me go over to this
website called uh
bonds okay what was the name
uh color then fonts
yes
we need one dot thing I don't know what
is it is called
let me check the glyphs
so I think no this is not the this is
not it
then we have not this
no this no no no no no no no
it's a small DOT type thing
okay let's try this here
let's add
a p
okay no not this this is not it it's
just a degree
okay where is it
we have to search for it today
okay
yes let's try this
yes this is it that we need
so this is post 4 and we have the date
but I think
we are doing it wrong let me open
LinkedIn again
and check one comment that we have
let me add one more comment here
this
is post 4 again
click add comment and this will be here
so yes I will style this
so let me get the again the class name
here as
comment
and here they should be as
time stamp
save so let me check the comment here
one comment
from any post
for example
click this
we will add this box
it's loading
okay and here it is so we can just say
the name also so let's let's store the
name also
of the person who commented
so
we have this user ID but we don't have
the post I mean the user data
or do we have it get likes by user get
comments
um
okay so we're calling the like button
here so let me copy
I mean check it here we're calling it
here and here I think we have the
current user
so we can just pass this as well
in this component as props now head
is done let me receive it from here
now let me just console
DOT log
this current user
okay something is wrong here I think
okay we will fix it no problems so we
need the person's name
so the name is
what is the name
name is this I mean current user data
or current user
dot name
let me pass this name here
when we are adding a comment
so post ID comment
and then let's add the name
in this API let's get the name I mean
the name
also this structure I will get it from
the
params
now the name will be here as well if you
comment
so let me add the name in this
uh input I mean in this P tag
here
so we can say
name and here will be name
now if you comment once more
let's see what happens
this is
post 4 or Focus yet
again
click add a comment and now the name
will be here as well
okay so now we have to arrange them I
mean style them
so what is the problem with timestamp
here no problem what is the problem with
comment here
do we have
okay fine so let's style them in this
all comments
let me copy the class
we have it here
make the line items as Center
okay now they are in the center
but the thing is
okay what is the thing is the thing is
the name should be on the top
so let me comment out all of these
things the name should be here of the
person
find now
I mean the name is here like this
then we have the comment
here by but we don't see the timestamp
okay
so let me just
copy this P or cut it and add it after
name
let's see what happens
this is post okay we have to add it at
the bottom of this name so
Lex Direction
column
then justify content
enter
we don't need align items here for now
fine this is post four okay let me
delete all the comments and try again
from the beginning
so let's add this is
comment one for the comment four
or add the comment
and the name is here with the comment
okay so in all comments let's make
the
class of name
so the name will be our color of black
so 2 1 2 1 2 1.
save we don't need the text and line so
remove it so text decoration has none
then font let's change to system UI
and the name
okay I think it's already here
fine
so the name is here
and then we have the comment
so also add
this thing called
what is it
comment
so
here should be let's say the margin on
the left
4px
or 10
yesterday is fine
for us also margin top
minus 10 pixels
or seven
five
or even 0 will work will it work yes now
it looks fine
so we can make this a little bit more
fine I mean more grid if we wrap or make
the color of this background
as Gray
so now we will see this gray box here
so water radius should be let's say 10
pixels to make them rounded
like this the current is too much so
decrease the
yes this now looks fine
just like we have it here but it's much
lighter I mean it's more lighter
fine I think this is it
and we have this
okay yes we have the timestamp at the
last I mean on the right so let's add it
there
so
let me cut this and remove these things
or just leave it for now let's write a P
tag the timestamp will be here
so we can wrap this in a div
and then this one inner div as well
now this div will be on the opposite
ends
okay
so
what to do
we can remove this and try what happens
align items we need then again
okay what can we do is
divide back the style in column
and remove the tips
here
and this timestamp we will have some
extra class
so
here we'll be having where here we will
we will be having
position as absolute
right as
then let's attend
self
okay if we are making right as 10 and
this is absolute this should be relative
so position
relative so that this sticks Inside the
Box
then let's say top 10 also
we will have this
let me add one more comment here
this is
comment
for again
click add a comment and this will be
here
so let's add a gap between them I mean
these two
in this two
what is this
to comment boxes
the margin
30 bits
to Too Much 20
so we only need the margin on the top
and bottom
so we can make this
okay from this much I meant too much
okay 10 and I think that's fine
now we have a comment box as well where
we can comment
so then we can like and remove this
let me add a comment here as well this
will be called as this is a comment one
on
post one click add a comment and the
comment will be here from I mean in my
name
like this
now this name is here Nishan Kumar
that's why we are getting this okay
ahead of here we don't see the command
find because the scope of the command is
on the only the home on the home page
wait a second no it's here as well
so on post 4 that the Nissan Command 2
made
okay wait
okay
if we click Nishant command to
this post
4 will open up
because this is the only post this
person has made
and if you click comments we will see
comments here and we can add comments
from here as well so let's try
this is comment or yet
again
now click add a comment and this will be
here at the current time which is 108 pm
now go to home page
and see the comments here so we'll see
three comments so that's a great feature
that I just added
then
if you click this
I mean this open this will open up with
no comments if we have a comment it will
show up
fine
now the last thing we did I mean we need
to do is log out
and when to improve
the inputs that I promised to do in the
previous video I mean section
so what can we do is
okay we are having this login component
in this
we have this input
so it is called common input
so let me search for this class
so height is 20 pixels
find
let me remove the height from here
so X once again login component here
let me add style Here style prop
so we will make the height as
I mean height here
as let's say 40
if 40 is too much try 30.
so that is here so they should be here
as well
yes okay what else
let me open
this
s file okay not in the SAS it is it's in
the integral.css common input
so height is 20 okay margin
we have to remove
now it will work
fine
they may here also it will work so I
guess we can name of child from here
because that was not the issue that we
were
having it's much better now
now let me sign in
let's check the
inputs
for
the profile
page and profile edit card
this is fine yes
real profile edit this
and the problem is here now
so if you bring back margin top it works
fine
so I guess we can do it in the label
we can have margin bottom as negative
so where's the label components common
profile edit
here we have a label class
I mean this level so just make margin
bottom
minus 20 pixels
or 15
fine I think that's fine and now it's
not breaking
so it's done
now let's handle the image upload in
Firebase
so Firebase has a bucket or a storage we
can say where we can upload images or
other files
so the first step to do that is go to
storage here in Firebase
now click the get started button here
they can I mean we can start in test
mode here okay starting so let's wait I
will list difference this I mean take
the blog this block is reference because
I don't remember
the exact steps to do that
click next
we need this click done and we will have
our default bucket here where we can
image I mean we can store the images
meanwhile if you check the blog here we
have to import this thing called storage
where where is it one second
yes see get storage from Firebase
storage so import
from
Firebase
slash storage
so let me just add git storage
like this
and we will have to create
a constant a variable for storage
instance so
storage
equals to
get storage
that we just imported
and in here we will pass the app
like this
now just export it here
and we are done for this now the next
step is
to we have done the bucket thing I mean
we have created a bucket
fine now the next thing is to do that is
go
into this file called components
common
let's say profile edit
here we will create
okay it's loading here we will create
this image icon type thing or let's say
a button first
so let me just let it load and then we
will create I think it's compiling and
optimizing dependency or something
okay meanwhile let me explain the code
here what is it so we need one reference
fun download URL I mean git downloader
and one upload bytes is available to
upload the file
Okay so we can also create a function
like this can we also do but first
uh okay so here we should create a
button or an input
so
input and which would be of type file
save and we will have our input here
okay which way is this when this is edit
page
we don't need it here we need it in the
profile card page
the components
or should we make it an edit page or
here
let's see
okay let me see
on LinkedIn we have on this page so
common components common profile card
here
so we can make it here
okay
let's just uh make it in the profile
card itself
and we will have this
we can click this to choose a file
okay
so
this will send us a
response I mean this input will send us
a file if we upload a file so we can
create a function let's say get image
and this function will be on this so we
can say on change
this so it will send us an event
and to get the image that we will have
we can just do uh console not log
event dot Target dot file
I files
so if you save now let's try this and
see what happens
open the console
let me upload for an image file here
for example
let me have my image so it's in this
folder I mean in this drive
let's try this image
yes so see we are having the file list
so if you are uploading one file you can
get it like this
so now if you choose a file
you will get the images data so let me
do that
see we are getting all of these items
so we are having this event okay
now let's store this
event you know trigger dot files zero I
mean the current file into a state so
say
uh
current image
Set current image
equals to use state
so it will be an object so make it
object
then simply
store it here
like this now let's check the
documentation here and what we have
so we need to create
an API for this so in the API file okay
wait a second
okay yes in the API file let's make a
let's say storage
or let's say
image
upload Dot jsx
so in here let's do our things that we
need we need to store we need to import
the storage from here just like we have
here so let me show you
in the fire store we are
update we are just importing the fire
extra from here so same way we have to
import storage so import
storage
from Firebase config
then we know we need these things also
so these are
import
a few things that we will add so import
these things from Firebase slash storage
okay so these are called ref
the reference to create a reference
get download by your download URL to get
the URL when we upload a file
successfully and then upload by its
reservable to upload the files
successfully
so we don't need this file so just close
it okay then what we have is
we need to add a function so let's say
con export
const let's say
upload
image
like this
so in here
first of all we also need to create a
ref I mean reference to the storage
bucket so the say const
storage
or say let's add this for
profile
pics
and in here we will use ref then we will
pass the storage and the folder we will
create a folder here
so say add backticks and say files
slash
the name of the file
so
this should be done here
I mean inside this because only then you
can access the file name
so we can just say
file dot name and we will get the file
from the parameter parameters
okay that's done
now the next step to do is just say
upload tasks
wait upload tasks
okay we have to create the reference for
this as well
so let me do it here
so const
upload task so this will be the task
that will complete our current image so
we'll use upload bytes resumable
and in here we will pass the reference
which is called the profile pics
just make this as Profile Pics ref
pass it here
and then the file that we are getting
from parameter
so we know in which in which folder to
send our data I mean upload the file and
what will be the I mean the task I mean
which file to upload
fine
now we will have upload
task this one that we created dot on
that is mean that means that our fourth
that means our image is uploading the
state changed and if it changes I mean
it's a param
then we will add a snapshot
not snapshot snapshot
and in here the snapshot will contain
the data of our image upload
so first let's check the program so say
const
progress equals to
let's
do this I mean snapshot dot bytes
transferred divided by snapshot dot
total bytes this means that how many
bytes are uploaded and how many noodle
bytes so we can use this for a product
bar
and we have to multiply this by 100 with
the
okay we have to multiply this by the
set progress percentage
what is this
okay
okay let's leave it for now just wrap
this in uh like we have to round the
value so we can say
math dot round
find
okay now if it now it's done now second
thing we can do is the error so we have
to catch them also
the error
and we can alert if any errors have any
error happens
so we say console dot error
just add error
find now the next thing to do is get the
download URL if it succeeds
so we can have an empty callback I mean
the param will be empty
and it and in this we will use this get
download URL
where we will pass the upload task
dot snapshot
dot ref
so when it is done
we will have a
callback again so say then
let's say response
and in the response let's just okay
let's just cancel the response to get
the image URL
if it succeeds
now what else do we have we don't have
anything so just save it
we are not using the progress but we can
use it later
okay I don't know why is okay okay it's
what it was hidden okay
what we need to do is just multiply
this switch with 100 to 500 percentage
100.
then we can just say in the console
so do this
now let's give it a try
and see what happens give it ready fresh
first
now click the let me go to the profile
page view profile click upload file I
will choose file
let me choose a file here some I mean
some good file let's try this
now we have chosen this okay one second
but the problem is we don't need this
file
okay one sec
components common profile card index
okay so the we are not running
this okay we have to run the function
also okay we are not running this
sorry
this things happen so import
upload image
from API file
now let me create a
functions the const
let's say
upload
uh picture
and if you want to change the name let's
say upload images
upload image API
now just make this as upload image it
will work
fine
in this we will call upload image API
and we will pass this current file which
is the current image
like this so we need a button as well
to trigger the upload so let's create it
just a simple button for now so let's
say
upload
now just copy the function name upload
image and add the function name here
it's on click upload image
so it refresh the page once let's try
from the beginning
select a file
let's say this file and click upload
dependent Network tabs and let's see
what are we getting
we are getting nothing
okay so let's check the storage
and see what we having what are we
having here
okay we cannot upload an image for now
so what might be the problem so let's
try rules
okay for killing upload the upload image
function is running and it's passing the
current image here
which is the file
it should work but it's not
okay image upload okay now it's working
okay the button was not clickable but
so now we have this link so click the
link and we will be on this we will have
this image in the new tab and this is a
link that we can store in the fire store
now go to files and we will have a
folder called files so let's make the
folder to be
profile
images
now if you will upload a file the folder
name will change so let me delete
this folder
so let me go back
this and just click this and delete
now let me upload one more file here so
I don't need we need the block for now
so let's remove it
Let me refresh the page
let me upload another file so just go to
choose a file
let me see where we have or where I have
my images
stored
so in this folder let's say this and
then say this now let me upload this
image
the best image that I have
Okay click upload here
whatever we are saying the percentage of
the image upload and if it reaches 100
it will show us
the link of the image that we have
this is the image
we can zoom this and zoom out
now if you refresh this
you will have the image here in this
folder called profile images
like this
now
we can use this URL that we are getting
and
add that URL to the profile picture as a
profile picture so
let me create or let me create a let's
say what is it
let me create a state here called
uh image
image link
comma set image
link equals to use state
let's say a string we have to pass the
state email link
to this function
I mean upload upload image API
let's get it here
and just store the uh
image link here so we don't need the
progress for now so let's remove it we
can add a progress bar later
so this contains our image link
and
we can do this also
let me create a user Factor so say use
effect
and when this image link changes or we
will get it when this we have it we will
run a function to upload the database I
mean the name so let me go to file
explore database
and in here we will have the users table
see this table
so whenever you upload a file the link
will be sent to us then
if the link is sent to us this user
effective hook will run and we will
store the image in the database as
profile picture
so open the firestore api.jsx let me
have the file or the option I mean let's
have
to update the
what is it to update the profile so
where is it
like post get like by wizard post
comment
post user data get single user
okay I think this is it this is it
let me search for this
no it's add doc we need something with
update dock where was it
on Snapshot
on Snapshot again
post okay let's check edit profile
okay where is the update dock let's
check this search foot yes this is here
edit profile
so we need to get the function from
quiet store
so say edit profile function
and when this is a factor hook runs we
will just call the function
so don't need this for now and this
neither
so we have to pass the user ID and the
payload
well in this function so the user ID is
the ID of the user
and
the user ID is I think this no not this
so let's say current user
let's console this
so
okay wait a second
what is the problem here
function dock cannot be called with an
empty path okay let's just comment it
for now
okay now we will get our
object and in the object we have the ID
of the user
so we can just filter it out like this
so we are on this user coordination
Kumar so let's check
this is a
Nishant Kumar
yes and the ID is W2 eec
the same ID here if we pass the ID in
this function called edit profile with
the payload that will upload our file
I mean the payload will be the file so
just say the payload where is it let me
clear this and image link
so just send this in the edit profile
when the image link changes
this will be sent
in the edit profile
and it will come up here
so let's try this
okay
invalid data
[Music]
let's refresh this
what's the problem here
user ID English address
we are passing the ID in payload here we
are passing the ID and the image Link in
the edit profile
so what is the problem here
function dock cannot be called with an
empty path
okay the problem that we had is solved
so what I mean is
we are having this upload image that is
running on the button click and inside
we have upload image API that is upload
image
in here we are having this API and when
the
Filip load completes this will call this
method called I mean function called
edit profile coming from file API that
up address updates the profile
so it takes the ID and payload so we are
passing the ID current user and the
payload and we are passing from here as
well
I mean this ID and payload comes here
then this function gets called and the
ID and payload then goes here and it
updates the profile
so now let's try this let me choose a
file here
so any file let's try this file
click upload
and in some time our image will be
uploaded and we will see a toast here
so let's wait for it
and see we are getting this profile has
been updated and we have removed the
setter functions from here
we only need file and ID which we are
passing from here
now if you check this link here let me
go to this link
and we will see it here
see this image that you uploaded
fine now
let's just cancel this and show the
image here
so
if you okay where is the image so it's
in this
let's say this current profile or
current user in any one of them so just
console.log current user and check it
here so we are having an object
inside we will have the image link
so just get it here
like this save it and you will have the
image link fine
so now let me create one
image tag here
so where should this be
okay let's it let's add in the profile
info
so
the stiff contains our H3 and all so
let's try here so the image or IMG SRC
in here let's just add current
user.imagelink
and make the alt tag as uh
just say
profile image
save and
we will
have the image but it is very big so we
have to style them
so let me add a
class name called profile
image
so copy this class
come over to the styling of the file
and where is it I mean profile info in
this let's add it here
so
here we will have width say 100 pixels
Okay small let's try 300
okay 300 or maybe 250. fine this is fine
okay now border radius fifty percent to
make them or make it rounded
then we also need to add the height here
so height say 250
PX
so now we have a
circular but circular image here just
like LinkedIn
but let's make it 200.
okay so we have this
here
so
in this name I mean in the wait
in the current
I mean profile info
we have this username
let me give some margin top or even the
margin top from here
and we will have it like this fine don't
worry we'll style other things like this
image and upload image as well
so what can we do now is
where is the image that we just added
okay let me add some border here around
so let's say border
2px solid
uh two one two one two one save and it
will have a border so let's add some
padding also control pixel
pixels now this color of this border
should be lighter
so choose this and
find now make it a little bit more light
okay then make this padding to seven
or even five
now we have this image just like link it
in
fine but the border is
getting it's fine it looks fine now we
have the image as well
now I think that's all for this section
I mean we have uploaded image and we can
see it
now let's design our file upload model
so what I mean is on LinkedIn if you
click this we should see a model opening
up
so the same way we have to do it here
let me create a component for modal
so this will be
um let's say file
upload
model
this should have an index Dot jsx file
and one for index Dot scss
when the jsx I mean j6 file here
let me make a function component and
this should be
pile
upload model
like this
so we should get the model from the and
design but first let me import
this
style pile I mean style sheet file
index.css
now let me choose this vertical centered
model
but for this
we need to add two states but you know
two states one state in the profile card
which is called Model open
fine
now let me create this here
just copy model
into this model
vertical centered model and add it here
we need few things which is modal and
button
the button we need to create a custom
footer so come over here and you will
see a footer crop here in this
wait in this customize footer model
if you see here this will be like this
so we had just added here
we can remove two buttons like this
button and this button
we only need this button and remove the
events from them
now they should be model open
set model open and this also
now where to get all the three things as
props
so model open
I mean two things not three things and
set model open
now let me return the component in the
profile card
so import
file upload model
let me just return it here
and in here we can pass model open and
set model open
and save this
and now what is this what is what if
what what do we need okay let me move
the input and the button from here to
here
wrap them in a div
like this
now we also need get image so let's also
get it as props and
the upload image
so also get from also get it from props
so we don't need the button
this upload image will be here on this
submit button so on click
and let's change
upload
profile picture
save this now save here also but
we already have that so we also need to
pass get image and set image
I mean get image
and upload image
to set it and upload it now if you click
here
okay also I need to add this event
called set model open on this profile
picture card
so
on here it's on click
when we click this
they should open the model so set it to
true
so that we can see it on the screen
now also on this class called profile
image
let me make cursor to be pointer
here
now save this and click this button and
we will have vertical Center portal
so we don't need this for now here let
me check I mean change they should do
this too
add a
profile
image
save and you will have it
now let's Design This profile image
selection button or input
so we can add a label here
and let's say add an
image
if
now on the input we can give it a ID
so let's say this is uh
let's say image
upload
now this ID we have image upload we have
to use it on the level also but as for
so we have this label for the input so
save this
now if you click the add an image text
this label the file selection pop-up
will open up on Windows
so we can make this as hidden so that we
don't see it
now let's style this label so say class
name
let's say
upload
between or something like that
and this div okay leave this div if not
leave this just write a class name here
called
uh image
upload Main
now come over to this
CSS file here
and set this as
display Flex justify content Center
and align items
Center
now we need some height let's say 80 or
60px will also work yes
now let's add this level inside
and in the label we can add border 1px
solid let's say
uh two one two and two one
now I'll collect made of padding say 10
pixels
and we'll have a padding then cursor as
pointer
you will have add an image
here let's say font
family
system
UI
okay I think that's already here
now it's done
we can put the image and we can upload
it
fine but the thing is
a problem is here we should only upload
an image when we have selected an image
so let me pass one more thing here
called the image
I am in current image this
so
let me pass and get
so we can add one P tag here as well
that will show us our current image name
so select a file any file
and the name will be here
so we should make the flex detection
I mean Flex as
X direction as column
like this
now give it ready fresh
so if you click this we will see this
then we can select the image but
if you click or we can click the upload
image upload profile picture without
selecting any file and that will do what
is make our images blank
so we need to make the button as
disabled
if you do this nothing will I mean it
will be disabled
we need to only enable it when
our
file is here
so this is the current image let's
console this in the log
yes so what we can do is we can just get
the name from this so current image.name
so initially this will be undefined but
if you select an image
this will be not undefined this will be
like have a name so we can use this
property to check for disabled
so if the name exists we don't need to
disable the button so make it false but
if the name is undefined we can make it
true
so add an image here or let me start
from the beginning
refresh the page
and select I will click the button add
an image let me use an image here let's
say let me use my image here
this image
now as soon as we click I mean add an
image we can see this button as enabled
fine so click upload an image and this
will be uploaded
also when we are uploading an image or
when it is successful we can close the
model
so
how can we do that is just sit
the model open as false
here
or just just pass that model open
here and come over to the upload image
API
right here
upload image API note API just upload
image
so it is here okay this is the function
name
and we should get the
save this we should get this that model
open
here
save both files
and
here when we are uploading is done
let me close the file
so
yes
make this as false
now we can try this once more
okay
so let me choose the file here any my
any of my image
so let's try
this image
now upload an image
and it will not close until the
upload file is done loading I mean image
is done uploading
so let's wait for it and see it has been
changed
also
we can show the loading State here
so
let me create one state here also which
is called const
ant uh progress
and set
progress
equals to use state
a string okay not a string a number say
zero pass the set progress in the upload
image
API
and get it here at the top
I mean from params then we can set the
progress here
so this will run every time our progress
changes and it will set the progress
now paths are progress in the file
upload model
as this
and we don't need this
let me get it here as the progress
now we need a progress bar
that will help us to show the progress
of the
pile upload so say check for Progress
here we can use this progress
from art design
any progress so you can choose circular
one or this one
fine let me use this blue one
so JavaScript
we need these two
so
let me import progress and space from on
to D
progress commas please
okay
now we have to use it in the model say
where should we use it let me open the
model
let me use it below the add an image
say here
so we only need one circular progress
and the percentage will be this progress
so it will be 0 initially yes so okay
what if we remove the space here I think
that is what we don't need
basically wrap this in a div
and
add a class name called
um
progress
bar
now let me come over to styling file
and here say
product bar padding 20 pixels
okay I told I think we have to make the
height as Auto then
yes now it's perfect
but if we remove this okay it's fine
let's leave it
so we don't need to see this progress
when the product is zero
so we can create a condition here so if
progress is
nothing or an empty fragment else show
this div
now let's try this add an image let's
try to add an image here
let me choose this image
click upload a name upload profile
picture
and we will see this progress bar here
and when the upload completes the model
will be opened as I closed and the
profile picture will be here with the
toast here
so that's done
so this is done yes now what I have to
do is see this image is not looking good
I mean it's
not perfect
so let's make it perfect so come to
profile card.jsx
and
also close this yes
open the index
so here we have the profile image width
and height
so we need one property called object
fit has contained
so that it contains our image like this
one more thing that I forgot to when we
upload an image
we need to clear all of these things
from here from the file upload model
so we can come over to profile card here
yes
so
upload image when it is done
so how to clear them
okay where are the date with data
if we close this
and open it again
let's
do what okay
we need to clear the name first so let's
do that
I mean Set current image to an empty
object like this
so we can pass this here as well
that current image that we can set as
empty
so save this come over to the API slash
image upload let me get
this that current image and then just
set it as empty object
and I think that's all
okay so fine I think that's all for now
in this section now we can upload an
image and see this image here
so let me upload my image one more image
here and then
now
when we upload an image Okay click
upload image
and again we will see this product bar
and it's done and the model will be
closed so click it again
and the name will be not here
so one more thing yes I can do is
hit the progress to zero
so where is the progress
say that progress as 0
fine and that's all for now let me try
one more
this last image
just to show you what happens now
I have set the providers to zero it
means
the progress bar will be hidden
so which image should I upload now
let me try this image
upload profile picture
so it's getting uploaded
and it's done
it will be here momentarily like this
now it will be an empty
model
now let's add the small icons or profile
pictures at the place of your post for
example
Command 2 has one image this so we need
to add these icons at the place of the
post
so what we can do is just come over to
this file called API
and create one more function
so just like we have great status
we have to create one more call get
users
sorry export
const
users or get users
what's happening let's say get all users
yes
so let me just have this here
just to copy this let me copy this on
Snapchat function
and we will replace the posts ref with
either user if
and
we need to add one state here called get
all
users sorry not here
okay
this would be here yes get old users
so
they should be set to all users
and let me get from the parameters
now let me call this function
in the index.js file we have where we
have all the posts
so we can just copy I mean just import
it from here and we can call it here in
this use memo so when it when the page
loads this function will run
now what we need to do is just say I
will create a state called let's say
all users and
set all users
so it's use date
this will be an array
let me send this set all users to this
function and it will be automatically
set
now we need to check the all users here
first
save this
let me open the console
okay
so we are getting an array
so each array
is the user and it has some image link
for example
this user called nishanth where is it
the name Nishant comma 2 it has a link
I mean this link image link
similarly this user another user
nishanth Kumar has the image link
so let me get the link from here using
filter function so we can say all users
not fill all user filter
it will take an item
and this way we'll compare the item.id
so we'll compare the ID of the user so
if we make a change I mean if we update
a status that ID will be stored here
so let me also do that I mean we have to
change there a little bit in post update
so here the user ID should be not
current user dot user ID
this should be ID
so that if you make a post let's say
post three
click post
so it's here post three and if you see
in the posts
where is it post one post three this
user ID is starting from R8 something
and
this is the ID that we have
yes so we are on this user called
nishanth
Kumar 2 yes we are on this user that is
why this ID is getting stored inside
this current post
yes wait what was the post this post
okay
come back to this component called posts
card so we'll compare the ID of the user
which is this ID
okay I think we should be user
okay no not in this
so
vertical what we can do is just say item
id dot post
I mean posts Dot post
ID
wait a second no user ID here also
so user ID now save this and let's check
the let's check in the console what we
are getting so let me give it a refresh
so we're getting an empty
array so I mean we are not getting empty
ideas we are getting the added with
objects as well
so
now
what we can do is just map through this
array so map
let's say another item it will take as
param
and simply we can return item dot image
link
save this and we will have an array
which will contain the image links
so we can access the links using
zeroth index like this
and we will have that
now let me just use this in this image
tag but first
let me create it do not worry I will
explain what is happening here so image
SRC
this
let me close this let me add one alt tab
alt tag they should say
profile I mean not profile
say yes profile
image now save this
and we will see that we have the images
here for the user so let me give a class
name here called
post
image now copy the class
and come over to this CSS or scss file
and let me add the styling
so this would be width
for T pick cells
yes so C
Nishant Kumar let me convert to this
file
so we are comparing the item ID
from the item in the all users basically
what you mean is
all users we have we are getting the
user's ID for example Nishant Kumar this
idea I mean this user and this user so
we're getting these IDs and we're
comparing them with post ID
so when we make a post we are sending
the user ID to that post
so it can machine scene here
this user ID that we're sending so if
they're both equal only then we will say
oh I will we will show that image which
is the image link that is why each item
is getting their own image from profile
fine so if we doesn't have any image it
will show us a blank image
so I will get that too later
now let me just
style this image so border radius
let's say 50 percent
okay object fit
contain
okay let me also add height say 40 PX
yes they are here but we need to add it
just before the username called Nishant
Kumar or Nissan command 2. so let me
wrap them in a div
user and the image His image
now give this a class name of
uh
user image or say
post image
wrapper
now let me copy this class
come over here
and in here we can just say display
of flex
now that side by side okay what if we
move
this
okay that will break the I mean it will
not break
it will not be proper so what if you
make it as cover
okay cover also works but it is
pixelated
so we have the image but the problem is
the image quality is too much for this
to hold
so that is why
so
it's fine then I guess
then in the post image wrapper
where is it where is it here let's add
padding of 20 pixels
and gap of
20 also
to add a gap between them but one is too
fine too much then
it should be 10 as well
or 15
15 is fine
okay so we have nishanth Command 2 I
mean the name and the profile image so
let me check on LinkedIn
how is it on LinkedIn
let me go to home page
so
user here is here
fine
I mean this user is here then his
about so we can also show the about of
the user here
so in this case do we have margin on
this name
okay margin is 10 so make it seven
or even 0 will work
fine so I don't think we need this to
remove this underline text
although we have it here
so let me I have removed it fine
okay now also remove the color just make
it as
this color called Black
or even two one two one two one
now it is here
the font size should be 18 pixels
yes now the second item we can add
is the like
we are adding timestamp
let's add it here
so after this P tag let's add timestamp
but we need one more I mean let's make a
fragment here and see what happens
okay make a div we need to arrange them
as Flex Direction column
okay they have already arranged
on their own
so there should be zero as well
so we can just remove this it will work
fine okay it's not fine so I have the
username and the timestamp and the post
so let me change the post width and size
so status
is here
so
this should be bigger so make the post
font size are 16 pixels
or even 18
is fine
okay
let me get
other let me get I mean let me use a
font called enter here
and Save
this will be fine let me also change a
few fonts here and there
for example in the like button let me
come over here
like button
here
we should have
uh like comment
where is the font
font font family
this
okay this is now enter
okay now the next thing we need is okay
let me come over here
to like index
what else do we have here for zero I
mean this text called zero people like
this post
where is it
here so it is like container and in this
we have P tag
so let me check that as well
like container
okay
what is the P tag inside
we don't so we can add
tear
and say this
okay do we have P tag here
yes we had
here
now changed also
fine also I think this is not looking
fine this like button so let me come on
to react icons again and change the icon
to like
yes
so say
like or thumbs up
so let's try from BS bootstrap
let me close this
import icons
from react icons
slash BS bootstrap
so we need
BS like
one sec no it's B I not BS
B I don't know what is bi but fine
so this we need
and we need one filled one
so
okay we don't have field one
just say
thumbs up
okay we do have BS here
so just make this and make it as
BS we will use from bootstrap
the one is for
failed and one is for outlined
so where does the filled one
here
and where is the outlined one
no sorry this one is the outlined one
BS hand thumbs up
outlined here and filled one
here
now let's see
it's updated
and it works
fine
let me also add a margin on top of them
I think it needs some margin a little
bit only
so in like comment
uh let me add margin top
4px
or even 5 fine let's make it five okay
now it's fine so we can see our
like and we also have comments
so let's add a comment like this okay
the comment breaks so let me change this
as well
so
in the comment box where is it
um so Summit so show comment box let's
say all comments I think we have
search it for search it here let's make
margin 20 or just make the 10 pixels
margin for around
okay
then the name here
should be margin
left 5 pixels
or what about 10
is fine
then margin top
5px
or 10
yes it looks fine
so now we have the name
of the user that commented
and
the comment with the image here so we
have the image and if you click the user
the user page will open up like this
now let's work on the edit and delete
posts from the home page
so I have added two icons from react
icons
pencil and dress and we have SIMPLE
spellings here
so these are on the right side
so just add position absolute
and write 20 cuts are pointer display
Flex to make them in single row and all
very simple stuff
if you hover them we will see the color
of the background changing like this
very simple okay
now
What will What need to happen is when we
click the alt icon we need to send the
data to this posts page so this page is
post update here
I mean this page
so let me create a function here
const let's say get edit data
like this
and let me pass this function to a modal
component
wait a sec no in this posts card yes
sorry let me pass it here like this
okay
now let me get it from here
and add this method or function
to the pencil so on click
so you will have get edit data and let's
pass the post that we have
I mean
this posts
the current post that we click on
fine
so we can simply get it here
I mean posts and check it in the console
so open the console once
let me read this and you will get this
data so we need to get the status from
here so we can just say status
and if you click it again
status will be here
like this now we need to set this into
set status
so that it comes here so just set it
now post one is here click it I mean
click edit
then click this and the data will be
here so you can change it like this
so fine now we also need to open the
model when we click this just like we
click it here and it opens
so we have to set the model
to open I mean set model open to so here
also
so do this here
okay one okay we have to remove one
extra curly bracket
so let me click edit the model will open
up with the post inside
fine then click this hi this model will
open up with a post data inside
fine so
but the problem is when we click it
again I mean start a post this will not
go away
so when we close the post I mean sorry
when we close the model when we have to
when then we have to clear the status
I mean this should be empty string again
so set status will be empty like this
so let's find where we are closing the
model
so we can just pass this as okay we are
passing send status here
to come to modal component
here and set status
will be false when the model is closed
so let me wrap this in an incredibly
bracket
and set this to false
same thing we can do
in here
if now
edit this we will have post one
so close this then pick it again it will
be false okay
say okay this should be not false it
should be empty string sorry
yes now click edit post one is here
click this
nothing is here so that's done
the next thing we need is to uh
I mean if you click this one we will
have post method I mean post button so
we have to change that to update so let
me create one more State called is edit
and set is edit
so it was to use State say false
so when this function get a data it's
triggered we have to make it to true
but if we are closing a model
I mean we are clicking the button
from here they should be false
so just make this as
false so save this and
click this again
it is post
it's again post so just pass this to the
model component
and come over here in the model let me
get it from here
then in the button
so
wait a sec yes here
let me just have if it is true we will
have the update text as button
but if it is false we will have post
so we can test this
so click it from here so we will have
post click it from here we will have
update
so also we need to change the status of
the function so if it is true
we will have update
status
else
10 status
now come over here
we will have posts now we can convert
update status don't Define yes we have
to get it from props and add the
function here so
the const update status and like this
in here we can console.log status
and Fitness
so also we need to pass here I mean this
save
now let's try this
so if you click this
we will we currently see post buttons so
if you type let's say
hi
or say hi again
and click post
this will be posted hi again but if we
click edit
okay so it's when it hasn't posted
so if it is posted
then again we have to set this to false
I mean yes
so if you click it again I mean this
let me post one more thing so
I
yet again
now click post
so this will be here now if you edit
anyone
okay we will get okay I think we don't
need to do that
I think it's perfect okay so if you
click hi again and click update
we will see the data in line number 37
it means in this function update status
now we need to send this data to
firestore I mean we have to update it
so we are getting the current
post
so I'm in current post so get in in get
Edge data
where is it
here
so we have posts
so we can just say let
payload
okay great status okay let me let me
create the current post so say cons
current post
that
current
post equals to use state
let's say an object
now we have to set it here
so we can just set
this
posts
fine
now we have can use this
so let me remove I mean leave it here
and select
okay
let's say okay leave it for now let me
create a function in firestore a pair of
jsx
here
this will be export
const edit
post
or not edit
update post
this will be an arrow function
we will get the ID here
and also the status that we have to
update
I mean status update
now let me call the function here in the
post
wait date post okay it will work
so we are are we getting it from here
now just call the function here
and pass so we are having ID and status
so
in here we can just pass
posts
dot ID comma status
here
this will come up here
and then we have to update the
so first we will select which post to
update
so we can use dock keywords to say no
doc
yes we have to select the dock so say
post to update
equal to dock
and it takes the first param as the
which collection to update
so it's I think
Post Service
fine then it takes the ID which is this
ID and then the payload which is status
that it
okay not here just these two things
first
okay then we need update dock function
and this will take the dock to update or
update to dock
what um what I have written update to
update sorry dog to update
and then the payload so the payload is
simply status
so then we can have then block here or
even try catch block
so let me trap I mean wrap this in try
block
and one more for catch that's a catch
error
let me add the toast or just console.log
error for now
we can give this a try and see what
happens
so let me edit this post so click edit
and say hi again to click update
we will have some error posts is not
defined
where
update status
okay not here I guess
post update update status okay we have
to get from
one sec
posts
oh sorry current post we should be
dot ID now we can try again
and okay yes it's getting updated
so also we have to close the model so
set it to
balls
okay now let's make this as I again
three click update and it is getting
updated
no other post is getting updated but
only this one now let's try to update
this one called high it again
so make this as
two click update and this post will be
updated
and if you check posts
the data here will be updated as well
so
let me try to update this as
I am Nishant
Kumar Now update
and this post has been updated so the
data is now I am Nishant Kumar so that's
how update post work works
now
yes it will work fine
click this I mean
all the posts under this name will show
up here okay
we can read this from here as well but
it's not working I guess we have to
change something
weight yes this will not
okay yes one more thing I want to do so
let's say this post called from Nishant
Kumar this post is not from our user
it's not our post
so we can't update or delete it so we
have to make sure that also so come over
here
and we need to hide this container when
the post is not ours
so how can we do that so we are having
this current user
so let me console this
we will also have the posts
so let me control this as well
so append the console
so okay let me just control the current
user first only
so let me just
we will get this
so this is our email
and this is our ID so let's try the IDS
ID first
so we'll get the current ID of the user
now let me add the current post
so this also has an ID
I mean post ID one sec no user ID yes
let me get from this
so this is the user ID of this post I
mean this post where we are having
I mean any post
what I mean is
this post sorry dot post I mean post
sort user ID
is the ID of the post
with the user made
so let's say Nissan command to make the
post so this ID is for Nishant Kumar 2.
now we have to compare them both
so
in this
here it will just make a
we will make a conditional operator
and we will check if the current ID
is equal to post ID
if it's true only then we will show
this edit
yes only then we will show
the edit option and the late option so
add a question mark add this else an
empty fragment
now save this and
this is
other account
so we cannot see eight icon here but all
of the other icons is here
like you didn't delete that means that
these are our posts so that's also works
fine
also okay not also okay now let me work
on delete icon on delete post
so let me create a function for delete
as well so say export
delete
post
so we will need a function called delete
doc so is it imported yes delete dock we
have it here
so we have to make a dock to delete
which document to delete
let's make this two dock to delete
which will take the post ref and the ID
now let me just have delete talk
wait
delete
doc so we don't need the status or
anything we just need the ID
so let me get ID from here
this should be here okay now we have to
get the function where we have delete
icon I mean here so just let me get this
here
and on click
we will add
this and we will pass wait what is
what I am doing and then we will pass
the ID of the post and this will be
posts.id
or user ID
no just the ID so don't use the ID
fine so the ID will be passed around
here
and then it will lead the post
okay
let me also add one post message here in
updating and deleting
so this I mean this
so just add it here
uh post has been deleted
and here
has been updated
post
now save this
let me delete this post first post
so delete it and we don't see it here
let me delete this I yet again too
anymore if you check
this post won't be here
so this is how delete works and we
cannot delete the post that is not our
like this post
so that's how delete and edit Works in
Firebase firestore now we can delete a
post and update it
so let me make this as I am nishanth
command 2. and we will get post has been
updated
now let's create this profile card that
we see on the home page which contains
the name image in the bio
I mean headline so we need to create a
div here first in the post status Main
so make a div
give this a class name of post status
because
the same thing will be here I mean with
yes but okay the same thing
this is not the same thing let's try
this class post status okay no this
class let's try
okay no no no no no no let me create our
one our own class say
uh let's say and the name will be user
details details yes
now let me come over here
and we can just add
the height as 550 PX
sorry wait says 50px hide this uh height
and these items yes just add them and we
will have a yes we will have a card here
like this but
if you see the height is big for this so
just make this as
wait 200
yes now it's little bit bigger but let's
try 180
yes I guess that's fine okay now in this
card we're going to show the current
detail of the user which is logged in
so we have one state here I mean one
prop here called current user that we
are getting
so we can just check it in the console
then we can just map through the items
in the object in this object
which is current user
so first is the name in the profile card
on LinkedIn
the add name so say
current user
dot name
so we will see the name here then we
have the headline so just let me copy
this paste it and this will be called as
head
line
headline is here
now before that we have the image
I'm in the picture so say image SRC
let's add an early tag called
uh
let's say
what is the name of the key here
it is called
what is the name image link yes so just
add it here and
current user
dot image link save them the image will
be here but it will be very very very
very big so we have to cut it so the
class name let's say
uh user
image
or let's say let me just remove the
class name
in the user details let's add IMG tag
and sub width as 100 PX
so it said it has been shorted
okay width is fine let's say border
radius 50 percent to make it rounded
so if we are making this we have to add
the height also so say 100 PX
okay
then object fit let's say contain
okay or cover what about cover yes cover
is fine
now we have all of these items
we can make this height as Auto
that it can May Fail automatically
so it's fine now in this we need to add
the items in the center so the display
Flex
Direction column to make the things the
way it was
I mean in a column then align items
Center
so these are in the center now
so this image should have a margin top
of let's say
30px
yes so we have this just like this but
the width is I think
too big
or we can add border
one pH solid
and
let's say
this
but we cannot see it so what if we make
it a little bit black see what happens
okay leave it that limited leave it at
that and say padding 10 pixels
okay 10 is too much let's try five yes
five is fine
I think yes
so we have this image and the name after
this so let me design the name so
if you check here
okay let's make this class name as
name
now in here just let me add dot name
Point weight
say 600
yes
font family
say system UI
yes then what we have here is
the headline so make this as headline
then in the headline
let me check okay let me just need the
font
I mean fun family yes
also let me shift this to the top so
margin top minus 20px
okay 15.
yes 15 is fine
okay so we are rating this
okay but the thing is if you check that
this image is on the edge of the card
okay
so we can move it to the top so say
margin let me name a margin of 30 or
just make it minus 30.
okay it goes up so here in this one we
should say I mean we should make margin
top as 50px
or 100
yes it's fine here
so
okay now let me move this a little bit
called ftpx or
yes I think that's fine
yes it's fine so we have to remove these
items
and just make this as two
or one
yes I guess that looks
fine
but this is small at the image so make
the width as 80 and height exactly it's
hard to calculate the exact
Dimensions so if we are doing this
margin top should be 50
or 40
yes 40 is fine but it is very much small
so only divided back to 100
now this looks fine
okay
now we have this image at the top here
k
so what is okay one thing we have done
okay let me also add the image here in
the starter post card
so we will have we have this button
so before that let me just copy this
image and add it here
wait
this image let me add it here okay let
me give this the class name of
post
image
and let's see what we get okay I don't
want to I want I don't want you to to I
don't want you to see this
the positive H width say 100px
okay
this should not be here where is the
rates in post status here they should be
yes but but it is too much say 50.
also height as 50.
then let me also use these items called
object fit and Border edit is 50 percent
yes it's now centered I mean circular
sorry
okay what else do we need
okay we have post status
here image and the button
so justify content enter align items
okay
so just let me make this as uh
what is the name of the property
space between
okay if we are doing this so
we have to decrease the width say 450 PX
okay it will not
so better to make padding 20px
okay not padding like it's margin
okay that also doesn't work so let's add
margin here
and here
um
or what if you make space evenly
or space around
hey
wait a sec
this is a
post I mean open post model
we are having margin 20 here
let me remove this
from here as well
I think that's fine
we can increase size of this image a
little bit so say 50px
to 60px
yes but it is not looking
five minutes kind of breaking
so contain I mean it's not plugging it's
pixelated
because the image quality is too much to
hold for the app
so it will be fine if I upload a
simple image so let me
show you
let me upload
uh this image
upload the whole picture
it's getting uploaded
done
and it says profile picture has been
successfully updated and this looks fine
now I guess
so in our data I mean in our profile
pictures
it has been updated
okay
so I think it looks like this
not much but fine okay
now one problem I have encountered if I
click
from here I mean let's say Nishan
command was the current username
if I click we will get all the data I
mean all the posts for this data for
this user but if I go from here
we will not see any posts
so let me come over to this component
called let's say top bar
is it this component
wait let me check you know if I click
this view profile button we have I think
it's in profile pop-up
where is it yes here
so we have this
uh button called
what is the view profile yes
so this should be not user ID this
should be ID only because
we have changed the key name from our
from user ID to ID let me show you open
the console in filed store
let me show you what I mean
so in the users
we will have
if I check this
we will have ID as this
so if we make this as ID it will be
fixed
so now let me check it here
and
let me go to home
and click view profile and you will see
the data here that we weren't sending
previously
so that was the problem that we just
fixed make the user ID to ID
now we have problem in our application
that we will fix now so the name from I
mean name for the current wizard is
nishanth command 2. and the post is also
done from here this current username
but the name that we are having is from
the posts collection not the user's
collection
so let me show you what I mean
so if you check here
we will have
this we will have this post dot where's
the name
okay this is not the name where is the
name this times yes username we have
and this username is inside the post
collection post collection
so what will happen if if we change the
name from Nishan command to Tunisian
Kumar
the name will be changed here but not
the name from the posts so we have to
show
the name from the users table
so we have this array here called all
users
so let me just try to console.log all
users and then let's console the posts
and if you go to the home page
and open the console
let's see the output so first on line 21
we will have an array and it will
contain the ID
so each one has ID like this and this so
we will use this ID to get the name
for example we are adding this ID in
post collection as well so let me show
you
so in posts let's say we have this user
ID so we compare the ID of the user with
this user ID and if it fetches only then
we will show the name of the user that
we have here
so let's Implement that so we will just
filter out through this all users so say
filter
let's say a user
and then we will return user dot ID
if it is equal to
posts dot user ID
so we will we are comparing the ID like
five ways is whatever and this ID I mean
with the ID of this so let's say
this user W 2 e c c f
is having the post
so let me show you what post does this
have yes let's say this post
so the ID is same I mean this ID and the
is ready
so if this matches
only then we'll map or you will get the
data and show the output
so
let me just
okay let me just go
I mean get the zeroth element from here
and give it a refresh so we don't need
this post so remove it
and then let's see what we get
so we're getting all these items so let
me just get the name from here
coordination let's say the name
save this
we will have the name of the user that
we have on currently
now just copy the entire thing
and just paste it at the place of
post sort username
and Save so both users will have the
same name because we have changed it and
now if you change it again let's say
um
wait
just add a question mark here and let's
see I'll give you a profile yes now it's
working
this allows us to get the undefined
values and load the page I mean load the
page even when the value is undefined
initially
now let me edit this is
Okay click edit make this as 2
and save so the name here will be saved
as well in all the places
okay
now if you check LinkedIn we also have
the headline here after the name so
let's also add that
just copy this I mean copy any P tag and
just cut this here I mean copy here not
cut and add it here
so the name will be called as headline
now we will have headlines here for the
user
and
also okay we need a headline you know
timestamp
so changed it
now let me come over to CSS file for
this or scss
and we will have status time step and
all
let me add the heading
so let me check the style for this
okay it's same as
this time stamp
but the font is little bit bigger I will
make it little bit bigger
so just let me copy all the item paste
it here
this will be here
but font size will be of 14px and this
looks much better
also we can decrease the font Here Also
let's say 10 okay I think that's fine
also let me make this as 500
and yes it looks much better
what if we make this is
15 okay it's bigger make it 15.
it's like it's I guess that's fine
so we can do the same thing
okay we are having these items so
yes
okay now let me log out from this user
and login with other account
to show you what we get in the
let's say what we get in the home card
home profile card sign in
so we are seeing this headline here and
the profile picture
with the image of the current user here
now let's work on the
connections page that we see on LinkedIn
so when we add a connection
only those posts or yes those posts we
can see in the home page no other post
so one thing I have done here one change
so when we are registering we have to
send data to a collection called users
so I am attaching one dummy image link
so that our image or what I mean is
our
profile image is not like this
so that's why we are doing it so it
comes like this this image okay but we
can change it if you go to web profile
and this
fine
now let me come over to
this component called
layouts let me create a layout called
not the folder a file
called
connection
layout Dot jsx
now we can just duplicate these items
here
and make this two okay let me create a
page so in this
I understand this in this Pages folder
let me create
connections
Dot jsx
so the same thing we have in the
home.jsx will be in connections page but
this component called home component
will be
uh replaced with connections so let me
do that let me come out to component
and create a file here called
connections
component Dot jsx
in here we will do same thing
okay yes let me create a functional
component here
and this will be here
fine
now we have to import okay we don't need
home component we have to import this
connections component in here
so we can remove home component import
and say
connections component from the route
and add it here
now we have to import
I mean we have to change the name
of this to connections
and then import this
page to
this layout so let me remove this and
same port
connections from Pages connection and we
are done
now come over to routes so we can just
collapse this
come over to routes
and in here we will create one more
layout
so basically
we have this icon so this is not profile
so we can create one more for
which is called let's say connections
and
we have to get this layout so we can
close this
okay we have to get this layout so let
me import
import connections
what is the name connection
layout
okay I think we have to change the name
yes it's not changed
connection layout
now if we type
it will be here
save this and this now this will be here
on connections
now you see this icon after home this is
for connections so let me add the route
there in components common top bar
component here
so
go to Route this should be node profile
it should be connections
save and now if we click in the page it
will be connections component seen here
I mean visual layer
so in this component
we will do our stuff
okay
so
just like the registered component do we
have an sas where we can write our style
link file so say
connections
Dot scss
or connections component
wait a sec okay yes so this should be
not in pages
connection component where it is here
let me import this so import
let me go to any component
and get the folder name here
and this will be just
be known as connection
component or connections component Dot
scss
so name the
import air file now styling file is
there and the jsx file
now here we need to show all the users
so let me get all the users so we can
say import
get all users
okay what is the name so let me come
over to
API
we had one function to get all the users
I created it so we'll get all users this
so get all users from
API slash firestore API and wrap this
because we have to export this like this
now one use effect hook we need
so that we can call this function
and it takes only one param called set
all users
so we have to create a state and fade
the set function return function in this
so
used it and then const users set users
equals to use state
let's say an array
now pass this here
okay and this will contain our data for
the all the users
so we will map through
this users so the same users dot map
user
and we will return a component
so we can just say this let me create a
component
here in common folder so say
first a folder we need say
all say just say what can we say
um
connected users
let's say this
and inside we can add a file called
index.jsx
so let me make this functional
so this should be
what is the name that I added connected
users
just added here fine
so let me import the common component
here called
connected users
and just we have to return
this component
like this
now
okay one sec I think we have to import
let's do this yes
now it will be fine
now pass the users in here
and we are reading this text four times
because we have four users
we just have to print the name and data
from this so let me add a P tag here and
then I will say user dot let me come out
to fired store
and same name first
let me just add the name now
we are saying the name and just one more
I mean let's say two more one for
headline
and one for the image so let's leave the
image for now
because we will sell it later we are
just focusing on the functionality
so in this day give a class name of
uh
connections meet
now let me copy a class this class
and in here we can say in The Styling
file display grid
grid template columns
Auto auto just save to autos
fine
now what we can do is we are having a
div let me make this device
grid
child and we can use this class here as
well
so we can say grid child
let me add Gap here
20 pixels between them
in the great child let's add a border so
border one PX solid
let's say two one two one two one
save
okay something is wrong here
okay I guess
no nothing is wrong it's fine
okay
now we have to make the width of this to
be equal so save it 100 PX let's try
to a small 300
okay 300 is fine
now let me
align them in the center so justify
content Center
they're aligned
let me give margin top
or align items Center yes
then let me add a finite height here
called
300 pixels as well okay it's too much
yes fine
here let me add padding 20ps
okay
here also
yes okay
let's say margin they should be not
padding
or we can also add padding a little bit
called
10px
okay it's breaking so what if we add
margin here okay okay okay okay okay
Gap let's attend
or zero
okay I guess it's fine
make 10 okay this is fine yes
so also we need to make the texture and
Center to make the centered text like
this
now we have four users
and also in here let's make cursor
pointer so designing is done for now
so we can close this component
let me create a function here
so sick const
get
current
user
and we will pass this function as props
to this connected users
let me get over let it let me get it
over here and when we click this child
it will send us the ID of the user that
we are clicking on
so we can say user
dot ID simple
is this idea or something else no it's
ID I guess yes
so we can get it here as parameter
parameter so console.log
ID let's try what will happen when we
click any of the items on the screen any
user
so let me open the console
click Nishant we are writing this ID for
this user click this the ID is like this
okay
now
we will focus on the same principle that
we used when we are when we are having
the like I mean add like so
where is it like post the same way
exactly the same I mean not exactly but
fine
so now let me just copy the entire
function and make this as
add connection
so we don't need light for now so let me
just leave the set dock
so this will take the user ID and the
target ID that which
which connection we have to add so
replace post ID with Target ID
you also need to replace the difference
so let me come over here and create one
more reference called connections
ref
equals to collect
collection keyword yes fired store comma
the name so say connections
now let me copy this function
come here come over here and replace
like surf with this
let me add
these two connection
to add
Now set doc will take connection to add
ID
we will also throw a toast when added we
can I mean when the connection has been
added so we can say
connection
added
now save this let me import this
function in the
okay let's say where should we import
this
add connection we can add it here yes so
let me import
from firestore
add connection
so we can call this method here and as I
said we need to pass two things
so first is the current user ID
so we can get it from props so let me
come over to pages
where we have a home page
so connection okay home page let me come
over to layouts
you have home layout
and here we are having my current user
like this so same way we have this in
connection layout
so in connection
connections page we are passing the
current user so now let me come to
connections page
which is the pages folder here
connection
and here also we are getting the current
user passing into connections component
I mean here so we can just
restructure this
and now we will have the ID of the
current user
so first thing we have let me close this
and the first thing we are passing the
current user ID so say current user.id
then simply this ID
yeah we don't need control lock so
remove it
so now we can try this and see what
happens
okay I think everything is set Target ID
and all so this set dock will create a
collection with this ID I mean it will
combine both the user ID and Target ID
so click anyone let's say Nishant Kumar
wait
connection added
if you refresh this
let's see what we are getting here
we have connections and inside we have
two things Target ID and the user ID
so the user ID is the user ID I mean let
me show you come to users remember this
starts from bw9
so come to users
this is the user ID bw9
that we passed and the other thing we
passed is the
okay the other thing we passed is the
target ID
from the users so
we have clicked Nissan command 2. so let
me search for this
Nishant Kumar 2 where is it
where are you
yes this is the Nishant comma 2 and it
is r a t i
so come over here back and this is r at
ti so it takes the ID of the current
user as your user ID
and the ID of the user that we clicked
upon that ID which is called Target ID
now one thing I have to do here is C
we have having all the connections here
like this okay
let me remove this other one
okay we are having all these connections
but we also have the fourth user which
is my user I mean this is me I think
this Nishant
but we cannot add our own user it is not
I mean it's not the not the proper use
case it will be a bug so we have to fix
it
so
in this
we will compare if the user dot ID is
equal to current user dot ID
if this is true it means the user is our
own
we are the owner of this user card one
second do we have user ID or something
else no we have IDs if the user ID from
here is match if the user ID from here
matches the current ID
which is our ID
we will not show this
so we can just say show an empty
fragment
when it is false
okay
one second there should be returned
should be
here I guess
okay no wait we did a mistake
um
let me okay we have to just copy
this and paste it here
I mean return
yes now we are not seeing
Nishant Kumar which is our current
which is our current user the user yes
so that's done
now we have to filter
the connections here in the home page so
that we see only those posts from the
connections that we added so come over
to this 5x4 dpa.j6
so we also have a function for like I
mean get likes so this get likes by user
let me copy this
and we will
add it here so let me add this
so we will place a few things for
example let's say get connections
so this will take the user ID and Target
ID
so let me remove these two for now set
like then likes comment okay
so we will compare the target ID with
Target ID
and inside is here already so same way
that we had in the likes we will get all
the
connections so let me just
check if is like this true or false like
this
so we don't need this remove it
make the likes to connections let me
change a few things here
and this like slip will be connections
ref
connection ref and this will be
connection query
connections query let me pass the query
here
as like query okay now this connections
we are just filtering through the
response to get the actual data
now we will choose if the if event one I
mean
even the I mean
even if the first or one element has the
user ID equal to like okay let me
research connection
so even if one user have the ID
equal to connection.user ID I mean
this so connection will have a user ID
if this is true we will throw this as
true so this should be is connected
basically it means that the ID we are
passing here the user ID is present here
or not
if it is present it means we are
connected else we are not connected
now let me get this get connected here
so let's say um
where can we call this
so let's call this here
I mean yes
now let me
let me create one more use effect hook
so we will call this function every time
when our ID I mean current ID and ID
changes
so one second connected users
okay let's try this here and see what
happens
we need the I mean we need to use effect
we already have it okay get connections
so let me create one state here called
uh cons is
connected
that
is connected
I think I have misplaced the spelling
connected
equals to
U State say false initially
now just pass
this in git connections
wait we also need to
pass user ID and Target ID which is
basically these two things
so pass them here with set connected set
is connected
let me get it here
and set it like this
now this will be this will have if the
user is connected or not
now save and let me check
so
Let me refresh the page once
Okay so
we are not getting anything
connect okay this we have done something
wrong because
they shouldn't be here they should be in
the home page
so let me go to the I mean this page
called
uh post card okay posts card I think
here
yes
wait a second note here I think let me
see where should I add this
so where should we where should we add
it
um
we should edit some place where we are
having the profile cards
so I think
here we can edit yes here we have to add
it
so
let me cut this function and add it here
so it's connected we need to create I
mean this state so just cut this also
and
add the state here
fine
now I think we are done at connection
okay we have to import get connections
from the firestore API so
let me add this okay use effect is not
defined
basically okay use effect is not defined
where yes
so let me Define this
fine
okay it is not defined
ID this ID so
this is a target ID from Posts
so how can we get it
okay
again I think we did it wrong
we don't need to edit here we have to
add this in the
posts card
where is it here so that we can get
access to the ID of the current user and
our ID
so
let me just add this here
okay
we can we don't need this remove it okay
now let me come over to the top and
import the things that we add here like
the state here
just cut it
and edit here
so now other thing we need is the
we don't need this we need the get
connections keyword I mean the function
name
so let me copy function name and
add it here
save
the user effect is not defined let's
define it
okay
now we don't we don't have the current
user.id okay we don't have it and okay
we don't have this ID
so instead we will have to pass the
posts.id
so or it's it user ID let me check in
posts
yes it's user ID
so say posts dot user ID
so this is r at something
and do we have a connection with this
yes we have it so we will see only this
connection on the home page if it's if
it is successful
so it's connected is here we are passing
this let's check
so we're getting all these options like
false false false false false
but don't worry
okay here we are having this okay we
need to pass the post slot current ID
here as well
now we're getting mixed responses like
true or false true false true false like
this
so
disconnected I mean it's connected we
have state here
so now let me come over to this
here let me
okay we only need to show those posts
where we have added the connections
so how can we do that
this div is
okay let's say this entire div
wait like button no here we can do it
and that at the return at the parent
return
so if it's connected it's true it means
we have connected to the connection I
mean we have it's connected we have
added him
if it is true else
we can just throw an empty fragment
that means no we are not connected to
that user
so let me just collapse this div and
after this diff add a empty fragment
now save this and you will see that we
are seeing the posts from only Nishant
Kumar 2 like this no other posts
so let's check the ID
foreign
so where is it this is Nishant Kumar yes
this is it I think yes
it's Nishan command two see the name the
ID is rcti now come over to connections
and the ID of Target is riti so only
that we are seeing here
now let me delete this uh what is it
this document
and we will see nothing here
but here we will have these three
connections so let's say we add Nishant
Kumar this
so it will be added now come to home
page and we will see the post of only
this user
now one more thing is remaining so if we
add a connection this connection name
should be available in the connections
page
so we will do same thing that we did
here in the uh which in this page called
post I mean posts card
so we will hide
this connection when it is
I mean we will hide the name connection
when it's connected is false sorry if it
is
true or false
yes if it is false
no not false true
sorry
so now we can do this so we need what
those things we need we need to get
connections so let's get it here
okay we also need the use effect hook so
let me get it also
add it here after this second use effect
it takes the current user.id and
posts.id
okay
current user.id okay I think in our case
it is user.id
but the thing is we are mapping the
users from here
so we won't be able to use the user ID
outside the scope of this block this
block so we have to again move this
inside the connected users
so where is it here
so let me add this here
and we will have the user ID
so
yes we will have the user ID and the git
and the current user ID
so
user ID is this okay just let me make
this as user ID
and
then we need this current user so we can
just pass
this
I mean this we can pass where is it
current user here
so just pass it like this
and we can get this from props
so save
one sec
what happened
okay I think we are passing I mean it's
not getting passed properly
now it will be fine so the things we
have user which is the target ID
then we have the current user our ID
but does this have user.user ID or
something else
I think this is user.id not user ID so
make this as ID and here as well
okay use effect is not defined so we can
Define this
so let's say
use effect
if
get connections is not defined so let's
add it import
get connections
we have defined that is connected is not
defined so also let me Define
this
let me remove it from here okay
connect what is the name set is
connected
so add a state here
const is
connected
set is connected
plus the U state
uh empty let's say and it's false
Boolean value
now
this is connected we will have to filter
through this
so if it is true
it means we don't have to show anything
it means that we have already added the
connection
so
we will not see Nishant Kumar here we
are only seeing Mission comma 2 and
Nishant
now let me delete this
document from here
and if we delete this we will see the
all the three connections here now let
me click add on anyone say Nishant Kumar
2. this will be hidden from here
and shown here with all the posts
so that's how we added connections
our main that's how we implemented
connections
now let's design the connections page in
LinkedIn that we see I'm in this page
we have button call connect and all so
we can design this
so we will have we need to use this
component class name called I mean style
called uh
connections component so first of all we
need to make one border on the
connection main which is the parent
element
so
make this as 10 as Gap and padding as 10
as well also let me add margin as 30
pixels
30 30 PX
safe when it will be here let me just
temporarily
okay let me not this just make this as
or 250
yes I think that's fine the height to be
200.
yes now this looks fine we also need to
add an image here so in this connected
users we can do that this component
so add one image I mean IMG
tag head Source let's say user dot uh
image link
and let's design this so in the grid
child we will have image so width say
50px save them and here as well
so images here
but let's make it 70.
okay much better
then height 70 as well
okay then border radius 60 50 percent
to make them rounded
then object fit cover
okay now it's fine looking fine
now let's change the color so
I think let me give the class name here
called name and in here let's say
head
line
now save them both come over here and
here say dot name
and let me check the styling for all the
items which is the name so I think
font family should be system UI
system
UI
font size make 16px
font weight
say 600
okay I think that's fine
now in the second one which is
headline let's also add some styling
so say
margin top
minus or say 0px
or I think you have to use minus minus
20. or 15.
yes I think that's fine then we have to
add this also so copy this and paste
this should be 15px and this should be
500 only
okay 500
or 400
yes 500 is fine
so we have the name and the headline
with the image so image is Big so make
this as 80 then
here also
also might be 90.
and here as well 90 yes also we have
some margin on the top on the image but
we will not add margin top here I will
add display of flex
justify content Center align items
Center
then Flex direction is column
now they're perfectly looking cards now
let me change the color of the border so
they should be BBB
yes just copy this and add it here as
well
also we have some background color on
this great child this is a background
color
let's say white smoke
okay it's not here it's I think here
in this class yes
now it's here okay now what we have to
do make the borders as correct so border
radius say 10px
and in the child also great child
so we have this border radius okay now
one thing one thing to notice is we have
button was also here so let me add a
button
and this will be called as connect
so we have button here
called connect now let me come over to
react icons okay let me just install I
mean just style the button first
so after the image or say at the last
after headline
save button
and width as hundred percent
yes
and then
let's say Max
not Max say height
should be 40px
yes
but the thing is the card will be have
to a little bit bigger
so make this as 250
yes it's now big
also
let's add the button at the very bottom
of the card so position absolute
then bottom as
10 pixels so we're doing if we're doing
this we have to make the parent of this
to be relative so position as relative
now it's here perfect
so make the uh width to be 90 percent
yes it works
so if you are doing this
let me make the height to be let's say
300.
okay 300 pixels not three thousand
yes now it looks better
okay
okay okay okay so the thing is
what if remove I think let me remove
justify content Center
and simply add some margin called margin
top called ftpx percent
okay not here from the image
margin top
50px
now this looks better than before
or does it so if you make this as 150
and here also
it's bigger so we have to make this 20.
now this looks better than before
so here make the cursor as pointer also
now we have to style this so background
color
say white
color as some this color so let me
choose the color
let me go over to what font and
choose the color which is
this color so add color here
we also need border so make border 1px
solid
this color
save it and this will be here
okay
so I think this should be not wait it's
pure white
what is this color then
okay it's this should be white as well
now they will blend in perfectly
yes
now let's design the font so font size
18px
okay too much 16
yes I think that's fine then font family
system UI
okay
then
border ideas
to make it rounded like this also let me
add margin top
or the button so 20px
maybe not margin top set only top
20 PX
okay this breaks it then
okay remove it
so what is now what can we do yes we can
do the hiding I mean make the height as
the empty
now it's perfect but if you mean 30 yes
that's also fine
okay now
if you hover the button we will see this
thing
so
let me close this if you hover you will
see this highlight option so make it
here as well so on the button
we can say
over and when we hover we need to change
two things only the Border should be
2 pixels
and they should be
a little bit little bit Bluer not white
so let me come out to blue and just make
it like this
okay it's not blue it's purple so let me
copy this color instead
and then we can
Slide the marker on the lighter version
okay note this let me save this
yes
so let me slide this like here
I think
which is the ideal light blue color I
think this one
no it's still too much so this
still it's not better
so what can we do
let me
if we scroll this it will become darker
save this and now let's try
this okay it's also dark
so let me search for
or let me do this instead
yes the color is okay
no it will not fit like that okay
so say let me go to material.com
and search for colors
hopefully we'll add some color that we
can use here
color
this is not color this is rating this is
so we need light blue
so let me try this color
now let's check
yes it looks better now
also
we have to do font weight as 600 here
now it will be
bolder
okay that's done now let me add one icon
here in the button so come over to react
icons
let me close this
I mean
okay let's leave it let's search for add
icon
or add yes add icon so we can choose any
one let's say this icon
where I have to import it first
so import
this icon
from react icons
Flash
air
now just add the icon before the connect
save this let's see the output
so we will have an add icon here let me
make the width remember sorry not fit
size to be 30
okay one day is fine yes now in the
button
we have to make display Flex
justify content
enter
a line item Center
to make all the items in the center and
GAP as 10 pixels as well okay it works I
mean it looks perfect
okay we can close this then we can do
this so this function that we are having
on the div
should not be here they should be on
this button so add it here now if you
click a button
we will add the connection so let's try
for this
and edit and it will be here on the home
page with its posts okay so that was
how we used I mean yes how we designed
the connections page here
now let's create that search option in
LinkedIn that we have
first step is to do that is to create a
component here in common folder called
search
okay or maybe search users
so in this component we will have
index.html or I mean not HTML j6 and one
for styling so index
Dot scss
so make the jsx story functional
component and then change the name to
say search
users
now let me import this component here
I mean sorry not here let me import The
Styling here so index Dot scss now save
okay now let me
make this input here
okay yes so input
which will be empty but now so make the
class name as let's say search
or make a dip first
or maybe just remove the search users
and make an input like this
and give this Dev a class name of
search
users now save now let me close search
results for a while and let me import
this component in our top bar
so we can do it here so import
search input or search users
and okay let me create a state here the
second
is search
and
that is search
let me make this as uh empty I mean
fault value for now because we will not
see search input basically in the I mean
at the start
so let me do this so when we click the
search icon we should see I mean we
should turn this state to true
so where's the icon
here it is
on click
uh let's say uh call back a function I
mean make it to true true
now we have to do same thing on this
that assignment search users so let me
just call the component here at the
bottom
let me let's say where should we call
this
let me call this here
I mean search users so we'll see input
here but the thing is we wanted to see
this input when this is true
so just wrap it and say if it is true
then show this
if it is false I mean this state show
this div
so edit and I guess we should see I mean
we should move it out after this in
LinkedIn image yes now click this we
will see a input here
but what if I mean we need uh I mean we
have to pass the function set search
set is search here as well
to make it fall from this component so
let me add it and get it from here
now let me style this search input so we
don't need this
and let me come over here and copy
search users
and add it here and then say input
inside that we will have the height for
TPX
too much say 30 that is fine
with
let's say 60 percent
Okay small let's say 100
or maybe I think height should be 100 as
well here
okay it's too much make it 50 then
yes still too much 40 I think it's
perfect now
White
look and then border one pH solid
and say
let's make the border to be BBB
this
so we will have border here so border
radius uh 10 PX
this is now rounded
but the color should be changed as well
so color should be
so one two one two one
now let me add padding left
10 pixels
okay it looks fine but also we have to
change the outline or basically make it
none
now if you do this we will not feel
outline
but we should have a Focus effect so
input
Focus
link
you will need only one not two then we
will change the Border color
to be slightly darker to make I mean
Slide the marker down to make let's say
seven zero seven zero seven zero
now border will be changed now let me
add a placeholder in the input so say
Place folder
they should be
let's say search
users double dots and this will be here
fine now we will also need to add a
placeholder here
and in this we will make the font size
same as the input so make section at
both places
so here and here as well
now we will see this but 16 is too much
or maybe we need to do font family
let's say enter
okay so I think this should be 15 or
even 14.
so here also
yes I guess that's fine
let me add this here also
yes we are having this
okay one more thing we should have a
margin left on the search user so margin
left uh 20 Pips
yes it's now it it's now perfect
or maybe 15 will be more perfect yes
okay now we have the search users we
also need an icon here so we can place
the icon in this div
so that we can set this to pause to see
the uh to see the top bar so let me go
to react icons
and here let me add our tools close icon
some close I can from here
so we can choose this icon called AI
outline closed Circle
so let me import this
from react icons
slash AI
now this should be on this x button I
mean let me just first create it
okay let me check here
so we have a icon here let's make size
to be
20.
yes now on the click of the icon they
should be false so take on click
this should be
pulse now if you click okay
also I have to
close this yes
now click this you will see the top bar
icons and then if you click it again
I mean search you will sits
now we have to arrange this icon so add
your div around it
or maybe not this just add a class name
here
and they should be
close icon
now let me copy close icon
and come over here to
search user damn it search users here
so say close icon
say but first we also need to do display
Flex here
to make them in a single row like this
now in the closer icon we can say margin
left minus 20px
yes or maybe 25
or what if we add 30.
it's 30 is fine
okay now we have to make a learn items
Center
to make them in a single I mean win a
single row like this perfect
we can close it also
okay if we close this we will say this
then fine now also we have to change the
color so just copy the color
and add it here
and then make the color as BBB
save this and it's too light so I guess
we have to use this color
now we have to use this and I guess
that's fine
yes
so it works perfectly
now we need a state to handle the search
input
so let me create it here
let's say const
uh search input
comma
set search
input equals to use state
they are a string now let me pass this
set search input in this search users
then we can simply get it from props
and on this input we will do on change
like this
and then we can set search input to the
event dot target.value so the event here
and in here we can do the event
dot Target dot value
now save this now what we can do is we
will have
this search input as the value of the
input
now we'll create one more div here
to handle the search options that we
will have so
let me make a div
and this table only visible when we have
search input
so first let me create the contents so
make this as
search
results first
save this now let me come over here I
think we don't need this okay let's
leave it come over here
okay not here in the top bar class
here and in here we can just add this
called search input this class
and it's a bit
400 pixels
hide the same
background color
as white
and save so it will be here
so let me close this for now
so
one more thing is to do here is make the
position as absolute
now it's on the very left
then we can say left as 100 pixels
and yes and top is also let's say 100
.
okay 100 is too much try 70.
yes I guess 70 is fine then this should
be also not 100 I'm in the width or not
400 so 350.
or 300
yes I gets that's fine we also make to
70 or 20. or 290
I guess that's fine
also height should be
let's say 300 for now yes now we have
this search option here
so we can just make border radius 10
pixels to make them rounded and let's
add a small border to one piece solid
say BBB
if and we will have border around this
we can move them to the top a little bit
more so say for T fixed will be top or
or 60
is fine I guess
now we have to only show this when we
have the data in the search user's input
so we can just hide this
when it's empty so just copy search
input
and say if it is I'm this if the length
of search input
wait if the length of this
is equals to 0 then show nothing
if it is not 0 I mean if the actual
input is there so this so let me search
for something called Nishan and then it
will be here
if I close this I mean remove this this
will disappear
okay
one more thing I want to do say if I
search nishanth here
then I closed this input
so it will be here also
so we have to make sure that this tip
disappears
so what we have to do is we have to just
set the search input here so we are
getting it
so whenever we close the search input
using this close icon we have to close I
mean we have to make this as empty
now let me try let me search for Nissan
then X
and this will disappear
okay that's done
in here in the let me search for Nishant
and let me just make this as permanent
for now so revert the state I mean add a
exclamation mark before such input dot
length check
now this will be permanent
and in here we will map through all the
users for now
so let me get the users I mean all users
API calls so say import
get all users from this route
let me create a user Factor
here
it's the use effect
in here they will simply
return this function which is called get
all users
okay now we need a state to store the
data when we are calling this functions
as response users
and set users
equals to use state
the empty array now simply pass this
here
and then we can map to the users here
so let me come over here and say users
dot map
single user that we will need and then
we will return
a dip one more div
and in the div we will have one image
stack first for the icon of the user
the image source this will be
user dot image link
and then save this and you will have the
big image for now now second thing we
need here is the name of the user so say
user dot name
now let me give this P tag a class name
of name
let me go more Let me give this Diva
class name of
search
inner
now save this let me copy this search in
a class come to top bar class and let me
just do this first we will have the
image so save it
so it should be for TPX
height for TPX
save and they will be smaller
okay we have this image then
I think 40 is too small make it 50.
and what when it is border
radius 50 percent
object fit
object fit as cover
yes now they will be rounded
so meanwhile also we can do to make this
as Auto so that it figures I mean it
contains the data perfectly and it
changes when the user list changes
dynamically
now
in this certain
displays Flex
and flex Direction on Direction let's
say the semi content
paste evenly
yes but I think we don't need this to
remove it we can just say gap between
them
Gap
20 pixels
so we will have a gap between them let
me add padding as
10 pixels
yes I guess that's fine
okay
so I think Gap is so much to make it 10.
okay then make align items enter as well
okay I think we can remove Gap and see
what happens
okay
fine okay I think we can make this as
let's say 40 and 40. because 50 is much
bigger I guess that's fine
then comes the P tag which is dot name
so here we will have Point family as
let's say enter again
I think internet is default so make
system UI
okay
okay one thing I can do is make the Gap
is 10 only
and make justify content Center
okay this is not looks good I think
that's fine so I think we can decrease
the height here I mean width here
so make case 250
or 240 okay I guess that's better
then
if I remove padding anything what
happens okay but it doesn't work
okay now
we have the names so make font size as
16px
or maybe 18
yes they are now much better looking
now when we hover this search in Earth
we have to change the background color
of it's a little bit darker let's say
search Inner
over
then say background color
as
say this baby baby
now hover them the color will change
Also let's add cursor as pointer
like this now it's better okay
and one more thing
we will have
here it is border radius
10 pixels
yes it's now look it now looks fine
you can write same here and see what
happens in the hover class
I think that's fine okay
wait a sec no I don't think
okay I think that's fine
maybe it's not
I think we can remove it from here and
then see what happens
okay this is the problem here
border ideas should be
10 pixels should be here
okay let me leave it here this radius 10
pixels
okay
now what we have to do is okay if we
so this is done
we have search items here
okay what is the next step that I wanted
to do is if we click close
it will not open up because it's
reverted the state is reverted here
so let me now
create a function here
so set const and this will be handle
search
so this function will be the bounds
function that will run after one second
after one second of typing yes
but wait second yes this will run after
one second of typing
so
in this function we have to filter
through this users
so we'll see user dot filter
and then this will take a param called
user a single user
then we have to return this thing so
basically whenever we search we will
filter and each user we have to go
through some checks checks the first
we will convert the user value I mean
all the users to a value and an array so
make objective values and pass users
here
then we will join I mean we will just
convert the data in a string
array
and then we'll convert it to lowercase
yes
so that when we type anything and the
data will inside the array we have to
match them together
so basically we will convert the name
like Nishant command to Nishant Kumar
two small case
and then the search input as well to
small case so that it matches perfectly
and then we will have includes and this
will contain our search input
and this I just I that said that we have
to convert this into lowercase as well
so make it to lower case
and simply
it will be returned now let me sort the
data in a state called response or maybe
third
here
let me create a date here called
const
or maybe fill just researched
but this will call I mean this will
cause
name clashes so make
this let's say
filtered users
that
filtered users you can make this a
search results as well
so it's used it also an array
so we will just have to set this search
in here
but we will only store this search in
here when this filter I mean search
input is not empty
so I'll make a check so if the search
users is not empty
wait only then we will run all of the
stuff
else we will run I will we will set
this set filtered to the real array
which is called users
this here
we have done this
okay now all of this is happening in
handle search and this function will go
inside a device function that I will
create now
so now let me just map through this and
we will see nothing because we have new
users
okay okay so what we can do is create
one more use effect book here
to handle our demand function
so
this will run I mean the similar Factor
will run whenever our field I mean our
search input changes the state changes
like this now what we have to do is just
call this function so let me create one
thing called let the bounced
equals to set timeout
so whenever
we are searching the set timeout will
run
and
it will run every one thousand second I
mean on 1000 seconds
sorry one thousand second no one
thousand not one thousand second one
second
this is millisecond
okay so when we run this we should have
this handle search inside
like this
and then we have to clear the timeout so
when we unmount the component or when
the component gets unmounted we have to
return
this so let me I mean we have to clear
the timeout so clear timeout
and then pass the bounce here
and this will run our search
now you can try this we have tried
refresh
so we see this uh we see this here
so how to remove it is just make the
height
wait a sec
what is it let me come to the bottom and
see the problem here
third inner
search result
so search okay make this as
remove this now it will disappear
now let's search for Nishan
so all of these users will come up here
like this if we search for Nishant
Kumar to
only this user will come up here here
if you remove this
and close it we will see nothing
now let me search for some random thing
and we will see nothing
so we can make sure I mean we can add a
div here
or maybe a free tag and say what we can
say let me just copy search results
again and add it here
and then here we can say
no result bound
I think we should get it here
okay I think they should not be here
because this is on the uh they should
this is only on when the length is zero
I mean when the search input is empty
so let me invert this back and think
what can we do to avoid this
so we are filtered users
okay
so
um
let's add this so if the length of the
filtered users
is zero
then it will show that the result is
empty I mean the array is empty or else
we'll map through it so if we type
something like
no data
or let me make this third day first
and here we can say
no data
so we will say this
so make sure to add
that make sure to add this class name
here
so that it comes like this so maybe we
can change this to
no results
found
and we will get it here
so now let me search for Nishant
and we will get the data here
like this after one second basically
yes I guess we are doing it one more
thing so if we click a user from here we
should be on this user's profile page so
we can do that by passing
a state so on this let me create a
function here
so they should be called as const
open user
and when we click I mean when the
function runs we will navigate to the
profile page with the user's ID and
email
so
let me come over here and on this div
search units say on click
okay open user and in here
we can simply pass this user the current
user that we have
okay so now come over here and have user
then we can say navigate
so profile page
and then
we can have a state
and in the state we will have ID
which will be user dot ID
then we will have a state I am another
called email
which will be user Dot
I think it's email or user email let me
check
come to this component called
profile card okay not profile card
postcard
here we will have a state so it's user
ID and user email
so let me copy
okay it's from Posts not from this so I
guess
we can close this this and make this as
simply ID and
let's say user
email but let me check if it is correct
component or not
I think it is or maybe it's just user ID
and user email
to make the ID here it has user ID
and we already have username
now we can try this so click let's say
Nishant Kumar and the last one
okay let me give it a refresh
let me search for
Nishant
now let me click the last one
okay so we are having on our own page so
I guess this is ID not user ID
now let me check again
click I mean search for user
let me click Nishant Kumar in the middle
okay we already we are having on this
page only
so
why it is happening
we are passing the
user
okay
let me check this
array called users
say the correct state that we need to
pass I mean correct values
so we have an array here
with three elements inside
so we have ID
okay we have also have okay I think we
were passing the IDS
1 6. iD is this email is this
okay name is navigating to that page
it's working here but not here
to ID is this okay and I think the email
is okay we have email not user email yes
now let's see if it works or not
so search for Nishant
sir I mean click the last one
yes now it's working we're on this
user's page
then let me click Nishan remain search
and click Nishant Kumar in the middle
and we will be on that users page
so we'll see nothing because we have no
posts here
so that was how we added such
functionality in our application
now let's work on the image uploading in
posts
in our LinkedIn clone app
so what we will do is first we will need
an icon in this
starter post
here so we can check
this posts card no we don't need this
and neither this come over to this
component called post update here so
that I mean here we have
uh this currently okay not here I mean
button
so let me open model component here
here is this modal component CSS model
so in here we can simply do this after
the input
I'm in this input and one more thing I
want to do is change this input to input
I'm in text area not input
so make this as I mean this
and so that we can do this I will expand
this
okay but one thing is wrong here we need
to change the I think width of this
so
if you remove it what will happen
okay not width we have to do this so
rows
should be let's say three
and columns
will be three as well so initially let's
try this
okay let me close the model and try
again
okay this does not change
if we remove this
okay I think we can do this as well so
if I replace the page
I think then we click okay do I have to
bring it back and now it's fine
so we can drag this and this
but the problem is I want to stop
dragging or hide the button
so let me search on Google how
to hide
uh I have to hide the text area
resizer let's remove this disable this
so we can check this so we have a class
called resize I mean we have a property
called
it is size none so let's try this
and yes it has been disappeared okay so
we cannot resize it
here
so we only have this where we can type
our stuff and fine
so now just I said that I wanted one
icon here so let me go over to react
icons again
react icons
here
we will just search for Icon called
let's say picture
and
let me try which icon should we use
so let's try this outline picture
let me import it here
so we can just say
AI or plant picture from react icons
slash okay
now just let me
add this icon here
and let me check that if you have icono
here or not yes we have
so mix size let's say 30
yes it's now a little bit big
also we need to change the color of this
so make the color
to be
wait or better to I mean one thing we
can do is just to give it a class name
so this should be
picture icon
now let me copy this class name and come
over here and we can do it inside or
outside let's do it outside because I
think
modal input is this so it will not work
if we added it inside
so we need the color blue so let me come
over here and
choose this color I think
yes
add it here like color will be this
now color has been changed let me also
add cursor as pointer
pointer where is it here
like this now we have this icon
and we can upload our image from here
okay
so
I think we can do this so we can make it
at the bottom
so I mean in alignment to this post
button so just make position as absolute
bottom
uh 20 pixels
it's now it looks better I guess
we can also make it bigger so just make
it 35
and it's here okay
we can change the icon so I think I
think it's perfect or maybe you can use
any other icons from here
okay let's see where that
okay
now what will happen is when we click
this icon I mean picture icon we should
be able to select a file
so let me make a input here
input and maybe give this ID as let's
say
pick upload
like this
okay
we will have input and also the type
will be of file
now we'll have this okay now let me add
a label here
and we will use the for
CE and this will be called as pickup
load
yes
so let me add it here
so
we don't see a label yet so if I just
close the model
Okay add the text also so it should say
upload image
now it's it so now if you click this
upload image text
this
file selector will open in Windows
so we have to make this as hidden
so that we don't see this other
input we only have this
so we can try we can move this inside
this label and
we will have the icon image uploaded to
it
but this and replace this
now if you click this icon we will open
up
pilot load window I mean image upload
window
now what we can do is close this now we
need to select a file and store its
contents in a state or a variable
I mean State yes
so we can do it
in this so we need to create a state
called set cons current image
set
current
image
equals to use State say object or an
object not an object an object
now let me pass set what is it Set
current image
to home order component
let me get it here
and when we click this button
we should store the contents in that
stage so say on change
so Set current image so this will take
an event param
and then we can store
event dot Target
Dot
files zeroth index and
that's all I guess now let's try to
console
this current image to see what we get
here
so let me open the console bring it down
then let me open the poster status then
let me select image here
let's say an image for example this and
you will get the data here
in this
console
now we have to pass this correct image
to a function
and that will return us the link of the
image back to us so let me create that
function in API image upload API
so we have this upload image const
so make and replicate this and I mean
say post image upload
or upload post image
yes so it will take the file and I don't
think we need the rest so this should be
post images not profile images so make
it like this
so file it will take it will create the
reference so let me create the reference
for this as well
so this should be
post fixed ref
and this reference will go up here
and okay I think that's fine if it
provided we'll see an error let me
remove all this stuff
and just create a state here
so we can close the model for now and
read one state here for the image ending
so say const
image or
post image
that post
image it was to use it
they are strength because it will be
linked in a spring value
now let me pass
okay we need to call the function as
well upload post image
so let's do that
import
upload post
image and
let me
add this here when we're selecting the
image so I guess that should be
here or we can just pass it directly but
wait a second
okay what did we pass it directly
and come over here in the model.jsx file
index file
let me get it here as frogs
upload post image so
this file will take a I mean this
function will take a file directly
so we can assign it directly like this
we don't have to add this in a state and
then pass the state
so
save this
when we're select whenever we select a
file
this should be uploaded
yes
and I mean when we select a file this
function will run and the image will be
uploaded okay so close the model and let
me come over here
and
Set current image we don't need it here
let me remove that from there as well
I mean Set current image
we are not using this
okay now close this and
okay we had a state for the image link
so also let me pass it here
so pass it here
let me get it here
why am I closing this
again and again and again again
set post image
so whenever this function gets called
where you have to pass the target I mean
image and the set post image function to
set it the link
so we can get it here
and here we can simply
set the response
now let me close modal component and
come over to index
so let me just console.log this post
image
and I don't think we need this so remove
the state from here
okay now let's try this
open the console
and select up start the post
then
17 okay let me now select the file here
so let's say this file
set progress will not be fine okay some
problem we have here okay we don't have
set progress so yes
we can simply console.log this progress
and try again
so
let me select a post I mean select image
again different image let's say
this image
this image we can select
so we are having the percentage and
after that we will have this link so
click this link
and the image will open up in a new
window and a new tab now we can use the
post image as the preview of the image
so let me pass this as well in the model
component and come over here
so I don't think we need that for now
open the model component file
get it here
now add an image tag here so let's do it
after the
text area and before the labels I mean
image upload file level
so say IMG SRC
post image
fine quality will be
post
image and we will see the image tag only
when the length of this is more than
zero
it says that
if it is false I mean if it is 0 less
than 0
then we will not see that image
so also we can style this so say class
name
post image
I'm saying no post image preview
preview image yes copy the class
now let me come over to this index and
say preview image then save width should
be 100 percent
yes so we are saying this
and if it is here
the entire other probe I mean other
things break as well
so we have to make
this in a div I mean these two maybe
let's say this
it's not works perfect
okay now we can type anything
it will be like this okay
fine
so when we close this they should be
empty so we can set that
so I made this set post image should be
empty
so where's the x button that we used to
close the model
on cancel and
on
OK yes so do this
now if we close this the image will be
not here anymore we will only see
these things now let me upload one more
image here
so basically where does it let me find
the image like this
so if it is uploaded
we should see the image here
yes
so we can also add a loader here or the
same thing that we had
and this is a I mean the spinner or
flowers bar
so let me go over
to file upload model
yes and get the circle
I mean the progress from here
and I think we need let me keep this
so we'll have the progress
at the place of image so if the post
length Okay we cannot do that let's add
it here
so
let me get it
yeah let me just create it here
the second const
progress
and
that
progress equals to use state
say zero
zero because fluoride should be zero
initially
so now we can set it
after passing or not I mean passing this
yes let's pass
in here
coming up to file upload model and get
it here
set progress
wait not here sorry come to the
where is it
where is it file upload I think here yes
so we already have
okay this function is different so we
have the set orders
so let me set the progress here
okay toilet is not defined here but we
do have progress state
I mean in this state
so let's check for this
okay this progress is not defined
so let me get the progress from
this component called Phi laptop model
I mean all these items but we don't need
space so we can remove this
to copy this
come over here
just replace this
and we will see this so the progress is
like this initially so we can hide it
when it's not I mean when it's zero so
to hide that
I can simply make this as a conditional
so
if the progress is zero then don't show
it
so it is 0 then don't show it
else
I manipulate 0 yes then don't show it
okay wait
so
make a empty fragment here
then if it is not zero then only show it
I mean show the problem is increasing
so we can try let me upload a file here
called this
and we will save longness
we can make this in the center so let me
search for
okay also we need to hide this when it
reaches zero I mean not 0 hundred so or
progress
equals 200
okay
so now
we have to make this in the center
so let me copy product by class
and search for it
here it is
so we can move this thing okay it's not
in the center
so I guess what we can do is
open this file called modal and this is
a progress
and it's interesting so make this div
a class name of let's say
post
area or maybe posts body I guess
yes
now let me copy this post's body
come to this index.js and say display of
flex
justify content Center
in Flash Direction then column
now it's fine
now let's see to upload and try to
upload an image
this image we can try okay
so let me start from the beginning let
me select the image here
doesn't go away
okay let me put image
this image is
so we will see the progress bar
and now the image we see here
so
a line item should be centered
a line items how to type this enter
now if we close this and try again
let's upload the image here
let's say this and the
progress will be in the center
and after that we will see the image
here
okay
now we can type
log in and
sign up function
and by the way we also need to send the
image link
to firestore when we are replicating
post here
so this is the function and if you
remove this console log and simply add
post image as post image it will go
there
so now click post
and it will be updated and you will see
the post here
but I guess the thing is we have to add
this
user
okay we don't see it here
okay the problem is
we have to make one check here that I
forgot to add previously
so
this page only shows those posts that
are connected to the user I mean the if
the user is connected then only we will
show these posts
but if the user is same like Nishan
comma 2 then we don't have anything to
show here so we have to also make the RX
statement here and then say current ID
I mean the current user ID if it is
equal to
the posts user ID
then I will show it here and now we can
say this okay
fine and also in the profile page we can
see if you open this now it's working
so I forgot to add that previously now
what we can do is we have to show the
image here
so let me add this in the card so
it's the profile image here okay let me
add
before this name I mean not the name it
where is the status let me add it here
yes IMG SRC
say
alt tag
post
I mean post image
and the third will be post slot I think
the key name is
uh post image let's see
post image save
and we will have a big image here like
this and it looks much like LinkedIn
okay
so we will only show this image when we
have this exactly in the I mean if we
have this else we will not show it
so we can make an empty flag material
because if you see in the other posts we
had a empty image icon
wait so I guess this looks like legged
in here
so we can edit this
and if you upload another another
image so let's see what happens
let's try
this image
click update
and update it but we also have to pass
the image link to update function
so let me come over to the update page
where we are updating the data so I
think it's it's startup host we have get
in data okay
let me check here I guess I think it's
here only
update status
update post function which sends us the
current ID and the status we also have
to pass the post image press post image
so let me pass that
like this let me go over to the paid
post function
in the firestore API
so update post where are you
I think this is post user data known
this update post
yes here let me get
this post image and add it here and this
will be our new post image so here it's
done
now we can try this
and now let me read this first one
and
if you will see this image so what we
have to do is
we need to show the post image when it
is available
so where is it in the posts card
here
okay if I click x button this will close
the image so if I select another image
let's say this image okay this is for
this is for creation let's say for edit
so if you wait
okay nothing is coming
so I guess
we can select an image here or maybe we
can show this image
so if post dot post image
okay not here in the post update
function
better post okay not here as well in the
model
this model
so here
we will have the post image so if the
length is more than zero then I will
show the image
okay
post image
okay let me
do one more thing yes one more thing we
have to do is this so
if the
let's say the image link we need for
this
so
let me come over to okay we are getting
this text here
so
current name again where is it
postcard model
this model
we are having this
is edit let me come over here is it here
we have
so update status okay update then post
but what about the value which is status
so status is coming from here
and now let me check
whereas what let us is this
let me check this function
okay not this okay get a data so we also
need one more state or
we can just say Set current post we can
use this now we have to pass
this state in the model
here
so let me pass the current post
now come over here
let me structure this
and okay what is the problem okay this
is the problem that okay we have to
remove this for now
let me console this current post here
if you open the console
you will get the current post details in
an object
and we can get the post image from here
like this
so save
and you will get this image link fine
now what we have to do is if the either
one of them is here I mean if the post
image dot length or the current post dot
image
if we have here
okay not length
then we can show
the post image
or the current post dot post image
save and if you now check again like for
example if I edit this image the image
will be here and if I upload one more
image here
let's see what happens I mean New Image
let's say this image
so it's uploading and this doesn't
disappears I mean it doesn't disappear
now it gets
after some time
now if you update this the new image
will be here
and that was what we wanted
so we can try it again
click upload an image
let's choose another image for example
let's say which image should we try this
image
so let's wait for it for some time
and this image will be replaced with a
new image
okay also in the previewer image we have
to give some margin top
so margin top should be 20ps
now let me try again
start a post okay
okay so if we click this
okay I guess we have to just
close it only then the image will
disappear
but in this case it doesn't
so what we have to do is we have to set
the current post also as empty when we
close the model
so that current post where are we
passing
so we have to make it as an empty object
so Set current post
yes let me get this here
okay so when we click X
there should be an empty object
and same thing should be here
now let me try
let me click close here
okay length will be undefined then so we
can add
this which is question mark it means
only if okay I think here as well
now it will find
now if I click this
you will see no image but if I click
here we will see this image and we can
replace it if I upload one word image
here or a different image
like this and it will disappear I mean
it will replace the image in some time
like this
now we can just say
date and the image will be updated here
and okay that's fine
now let's do a few changes in our app I
mean final changes so first of all we
don't need this profile icon here we
will need our
user icon here so let me come to
collectionslayout.jsx
and we have the top bar here okay
so we have to pass this current user
here maybe we need to check where else
do we have the top bar I mean pass this
current user from everywhere to top bar
like this
so that we can use our profile picture
so add this here and here and here
now we can close all these three
and in this top bar let me get current
user
so this will contain our image
in this image
so now let me go over here
in this image link which is the user and
replace the user with current user dot
image link
now save and the image will be here on
the top
let's style this so in the user logo
class let me search
we have to make height 40 that we
already have but make it 50
okay I think 40 is fine then height 40
as well
then border radius
50 percent
and then we can do
what can we do object fit
another cover yes now it's rounded and
fine
okay in the next thing we need is
one dominate
I think we need to make this start a
pause button on the left so where is it
open this profile I mean post update.jsx
it's index file and here we can do that
so where is it where is it this open
post model button
let me search for it here
and simply add
margin left
minus 30 PX
yes that's no fine I guess it's fine one
more thing we need to do is go to this
page called I mean the index.ss file
here
and this is the color here so remove the
color scheme for now I mean from here
this will turn to White
now we have to make this as anything
like this or maybe a little bit darker
so I think this is Will fine this will
be fine redeem the opacity from this
from here okay
so we have done this as well
okay
so what if we remove all of these
okay it does nothing so maybe we don't
need and neither is this
yes so the scroll bar will be changed to
light now next thing we need is so we
have the images
on this page called
where does this post
s posts card here we have the image
links that we see here so what should
happen when we click this should I mean
we should see the image opening up in a
model so let me come over to art design
and create a model here
let me make quickly I think we should
add a component for this
or we can just add it in this component
as well
first we need to create a state so
cons
image model
that image model
equals to you state
this will be called as
false
okay now
we will have this model here
with
this vertical centered model
we need JavaScript so we need to add a
modal at the bottom
far away from here
and come to the bottom let's add it here
okay not here maybe here
make this as or just remove title from
here
and this should be known as
image model I think
and to set it we have set image model
here
we don't need the contents so remove
them from here and we need a button I
mean not a button we will need a
uh what is it a function I mean we need
only given to set this to true so that
it opens up I'm in the model
so this would be okay model is not
defined we have to Define this as well
so we can get this and let's say
okay we don't have anything from our
design so let me import
it here
now
this picture
will open up this image model when we
click it
so where it is in the picture
the image
like button we have okay
all user.filter
okay note this this is the image yes
so we can see on click
this set image model to true
let me make this as a callback function
like this and whenever clicking the
image
okay this is something else maybe
wait
all users
I think this is not the image
okay image is this
where is the image
this is the name
I think the image is here somewhere
oh yes this is the image so let me add
it here
now click this and the model will open
so we have to make the model as empty we
only need the image there
so we also need to remove these buttons
which are
on okay on cancel
maybe we have to set the footer as an
empty array using footer prop
so where does this photo
this
so
let me just curve a footer
array object sorry object settings
and make it as empty
and then save and we will have no
buttons here just in close icon I mean
one close icon so I guess we have to
bring these back
okay okay let me add it again
and yes
and maybe in this footer we have to add
the button
okay not the button yes it will be
closing okay now on the image we have to
set a cursor as pointer
so let me come to
uh post image okay this is Alt
let me check
where is the image
okay image image image text status
this is the image post image yes to say
cursor
as pointer
okay one sec I think this is not it
where it is
post image
post image wrapper posts card
okay I guess I guess status we have here
before this we have the image
let me search for image here okay we
don't see anything
maybe we have to add up maybe we need to
collect a class name we are called
post
class name
equals to
post
image
image yes
that's it
let me now add this okay
okay I think post image is somewhere
else this is the post image
so maybe we can replace this post image
or this should be not post image it
should be profile image
here so let me copy in this and replace
other post image
with this
here
we can replace now save and yes it will
be fine
now where is
okay this is the profile image
we need for post image so we can remove
the cursor pointer from here and add dot
post
image
and then that cursor to be pointed now
this will be pointer cursor and whenever
we click this image
we will open up a
we will open up this model and in this
model we have to pass the image so we
can just copy this image from here
and simply paste it in the model
here
and okay this is not the thing we want
this is profile image we need post image
sorry again
I am confused so we need
this
and add it here
it will be very big
so let me let me make profile image
sorry not profile image post image and
width should be hundred percent only
now I guess this will be small maybe not
let's see 50 percent
okay what is happening
what is happening
let me cut this post image and paste it
outside so that we can all access it
okay we can access it
yes we can let me also make margin top
let's say 30 bits so that we have the x
button here
so that we can close it and we can give
title here or remove the script item
okay
if you click this image this will be
open up open up it will open up and yes
it's working perfectly
okay one more thing that I want to do
okay so
in the other
profile image
we don't need
okay what is this
let me make this a 60 or 40 let's see
then
okay not here okay this is the problem
this
okay profile image should be one place
I mean somewhere else as well because
this is breaking
so it is not here let me come over to
post update I mean post update
and here we will have
post okay this post image is breaking
because
we are having margin top 30. if you
remove it will be fine
I guess let's leave it
okay maybe
we need to add some
uh we need to add some margin on this so
make say I will make this as margin
or maybe modal image just say model here
and let me come over to this class name
here and just same or dull
margin 10 I mean margin top 30 PX
now we will have margin here
as 30 and now it will be fine
okay now we have to do one more thing so
let's say we type something like this
hello
this is Nishan
now if you update or post it this will
be here
let's say
where is it hello this is Nishant so
what is happening what is happening here
is
we're not getting this in different
lines
so we have to make sure to do that
so let me hover to
react quill let me get this
component
I mean let me get this Library not
so let's install this in our
app open up a new terminal
and just paste it
and let it finish let it finish yes
so we will use this component
at the place of our
text area here
so where is the text area
which is this component post update in
this we have to do
so we will not have okay it's in the
middle component
modal com just murder this
so instead of this text area where here
we have aliosis react Queen
so let me open this GitHub repo because
it doesn't say how to use it
so we can import react quill and its CSS
file
so let me add the quill here and import
the CSS into the main
file
here
like this now close and it will take
some time to reload or
optimize the dependencies I think it's
done
now we don't need this
variable value
so let me add it here
or maybe we already have the value
for this text area yes status
so let me copy react quill
and just add it here
so
let me add the class name of this tumori
model input
the value will be status
and on January
date status
here so now we can remove digit text
idea from here
okay when now let's check
if you open this
you will get this but I think it's still
optimizing now that I have added react
quill here let me add some options I
mean let me edit this
so
let me just find the class name that it
has so open the console I mean not the
console the elements tab here now let me
click this button I mean the icon
and focus on
this input
so this is called as
he will container ql snow let me copy
this class name
add this in the model and remove the
border so just make it as none
so that the border of this disappears so
we have to make it as important now we
don't have the Border but still we can
type it here
the next thing we have to do is take I
mean name of the border from this and
this is called ql toolbar 12th no so
copy this
and simply add it here also it's now
working we have the
cool bar and this
okay the next ring thing we can do is
okay increase the height of this so say
height
100 maybe 100 is too much let's say 50px
or maybe 180 it's now it's very big and
I guess we need that kind of big
so
it is here
okay
but this should be okay we don't need
height here when the height on this
container not on the toolbar so the add
container here and say height as 150 PX
yes also let me write font size say
20 PX
okay it's not bigger
do we have option to write a plus folder
here in the react Queen let's check
where is the quill quill quill quill
quill here
the placeholder
say
add some or say
here something
useful
maybe we don't have the concept of
placeholder here or maybe if we close
this and refresh the page then open it
again
yes now we can say this
yes we can type it here
so in here let me make the font
family as
system UI
and it will change
so basically we can make it bold or
italic or underline like this okay
that's done
now next thing we need to do is come
over to post
uh posts card here
so here we have the P tag that contains
the status
so we don't need it here
so remove this and we need a div make
this
PR div
and here as well
and just do
this
dangerously set in at HTML
and add post dots I mean add this
now
the thing is okay we need double
underscore HTML
and then
this and I think we need one more curly
bracket
now
if you check
we can say this the same thing that we
have now let me
write this here so hello
I am Nishant
Kumar
maybe we have to make this on the
different line like
now click post
and we will have this text here like
this and it works
maybe we need to decrease the width so
the height to be one
or maybe 100
now
yes I think 100 is fine let me add
this again
hello I am Nishant Kumar
to add this here
click post and this should be
here
where is it
so I guess
it's better to remove the height
and
go with it
so let me add this
click
let me addition command to click post
and let's search for it
okay it still is not fine maybe this
should be not
they make it P again
and
then let's see what happens maybe we
have to set the status
here so
let me check for status
so here we have font
okay we have margin here so remove it
okay it doesn't work let me make margin
top
minus 20 PX
okay this will not work okay so I guess
that's fine and now we are fully
functional LinkedIn clone that we can
use